okay you guys have been screaming at me
in the comment section to cover this
story and so we are going to originally
i was going to upload a different story
today but we're actually going to
postpone that until next week because
it's not nearly as important and we're
going to cover the immortal hulk now the
immortal hulk is basically the return of
bruce banner as the incredible hulk in
marvel comics which his absence had
really been felt it was like the
fantastic four not being there right
it's just kind of like i mean you can't
it was weird they decided to kill him
off during civil war and then it was
like i don't know why you would like wow
like who thought that was a good idea i
guess it was venice is a good idea now
he's writing superman so we'll see how
that plays out but uh but nonetheless
you know it's it's it's cool to see the
incredible hulk return now what this
does is this initially picks up with a
kid named tommy and tommy actually
knocks over a gas station which is
coincidentally run by roxanne oil uh
those guys who don't know what rockstar
oil is it's like the most corrupt
organization in the entirety of marvel
comics
[Laughter]
they are they are your marvel stand-in
for your traditional corrupt corporation
they have their hands on everything like
slave trading and all kinds of they were
very very sinister organization but
tommy busts into this place and this
robbery goes exactly as you would expect
because the way this is done whenever it
comes to robbery there's only over two
kinds there's basically people who are
confident about it people who have done
it before and those who are brand new
tommy is brand new to the whole to the
whole gas station robbery scene and you
can hear it you could tell by the way
his voice is going the fact that he's
trembling he's unsure of himself the guy
looks terrified and he's sweating and
then what happens is there's a young
girl named sandy who's in there she's 12
years old and she drops a glass and when
she dies tommy freaks out and shoots her
now this happens directly in front of
bruce banner this leads to the
incredible hope you get into manifest
itself which leads to tommy shooting
bruce banner in the head now this is
kind of an important thing and the
reason why is because one of the
arguments that people make on how to
kill the incredible hulk is to kill
bruce banner this is actually going to
answer that question and it's going to
be a little bit of a trump card that al
ewing throws in here in order to bring
the incredible hulk back when tommy
takes off and he ends up you know
shooting the cashier and bails out we
end up picking up with the morgue
shortly after this now this does deal
with a detective named gloria as well as
a reporter named jackie it's kind of
cool because they're basically trying to
figure out who'd done this now initially
there's no real significance to them
right like jackie's just a reporter
covering a story about a gas station
robbery and gloria's a detective who's
you know trying to figure the whole
thing out but with regards to bruce
banner himself despite the fact that
he's essentially dead the incredible
hulk manifests itself now i want to say
that something like this happened during
peter david's run not going to swear to
it but as far as i'm aware in the
history of marvel comics the rule of
thumb when it came to banners impending
death and the incredible hulk was that
the hulk would manifest right at the
point when banner was gonna die so if
you go and you read like the incredible
hulk the end for example banner throws
himself off a cliff and then the
incredible hulk manifests in order to
save banner this is kind of a break from
tradition the fact that bruce banner can
basically be dead can be diagnosed you
know can literally be dead in an autopsy
you know prepared to be performed and
then sometime later presumably maybe an
hour later manifests as the incredible
hulk you never really see that it's a
way to just kind of invoke invoke the
hulk and bring him back and so what this
does is this picks up with a biker gank
and this is when we realize the story is
a little more tragic than it originally
appeared in the sense that tommy is
actually in debt to a biker gang just to
keep the lights on quite literally like
he's not really able to pay the light
bill he's got a family to support he's
doing whatever it takes in order to make
sure that they have the resources they
need and because he's in debt to this
biker gang he's been knocking over gas
stations in order to pay back what he
owes and so he's basically like this guy
who's caught in an impossible situation
now this leads to the incredible hulk
showing up and basically massacring
everybody and that's exactly what you
would expect i mean none of them are
prepared i mean it's it's just this
giant green rage monster showing up and
just snatching people up smashing their
bones i mean bullets are being sprayed
in every direction and none of it makes
a difference because when the guns are
going off tommy's fleeing for his life
people are screaming and when the when
when the screaming stops then suddenly
tommy turns around and he's basically he
comes face to face with the incredible
hulk himself and this is cool because
the way that al ewing kind of plays this
out it's almost like a horror film and
that's really kind of what you would
expect with the incredible hulk right
like if you really get down to like the
great incredible hulk stories a lot of
them do focus on the hulk himself
tearing things up and smashing things
because at the end of the day all
anybody ever really wants to see the
incredible hulk do is just smash stuff i
mean it's not unreasonable
that's why his catchphrase is hulk smash
because we just want to see him destroy
things like that's what the incredible
hulk does you know but it's kind of
interesting because in this instance the
incredible hulk is almost merciless and
that's why i say this is like like seven
i mean savage hulk will make his return
in the story but he's really very very
dark and merciless here because tommy
tries to explain the situation and say
look you know i'm a guy who's caught in
an impossible situation you know that i
didn't mean for it to happen but at the
end of the day it doesn't matter the
incredible hulk's response is who cares
what your intention was you walked into
a gas station with a loaded gun you had
no idea what you were doing you pulled
the trigger out of desperation and panic
and you shot a 12 year old girl and
killed her you my friend are in a world
of hurt and where where tommy put you
know turns the gun on the incredible
hulk and shoots him it doesn't make a
difference and so we kind of ask this
question he says you know i'm not a bad
guy am i in the incredible hulk response
what do you think and literally breaks
every single bone in his body and from
the way it's told a giant crater is left
outside of a hospital indicating either
the incredible hulk just crumpled tommy
like a piece of paper just wadded him up
and then took him to the hospital and
dropped him off or he just threw him at
the hospital and just threw him into the
ground regardless of the scenario tommy
will probably never walk again and he'll
probably never wake up again he's
essentially going to be in a vegetative
state forever but where you have gloria
and you have jackie who are having a
conversation trying to figure out what's
going on glory and jackie are friends
and so gloria ultimately spills the
beans and says look you didn't hear this
from me but the rumor here this
statement here at least from what we're
understanding from these bikers who have
confessed from the ones who were left
alive anyway the way this is being told
is that tommy didn't do this that there
was somebody who showed up with an
insane amount of strength and he was
giant and he was green and that's when
they start to debate they're like bruce
banner was shot and killed by hawkeye
he's dead he's not supposed to be back
and they're like but yes he is though
there's really no denying this point as
an absolute truth that he really is back
and he really is alive and so it's kind
of interesting to see because you end up
having this this really cool scenario
where jackie's going through and doing a
series of interviews you know talking to
various people getting a feel for their
stories about the incredible hulk and
basically all the stories they give is
that the incredible hulk is almost like
this this mythological being he's like
this mythological force that exists out
there that a lot of people have seen him
but it's like he's there and gone and
people don't walk up to him because
they're terrified and so in their
response in their mind it is this guy is
he's like a mythical beast that exists
out there but i'm not gonna tell you
anything about him it's like it's like
the old it's like the classic sicilian
argument or a sicilian statement for
like the mafia right like i didn't see
anything because i wasn't home and if i
was home i still didn't see anything
because i was asleep like it's it's
really how this whole thing plays out
when it comes to like people who have
encountered him being terrified by him a
couple people were kind of enamored and
that's why there's mixed stories here
because the story is like well the
incredible hulk helped people different
things like that so it's a little bit
fluctuating here now from here we
switched directly over to uh to jackie
going through her research and and so on
looking at these stories when she's
suddenly met by walter lankowski now
walter lankowski is a character that
we've never really talked about before
and we've never really had a reason to
but when it comes to the character of
sasquatch he's been around for a long
long time the old alpha flight story
well really he goes all the way back to
uncanny x-men 120
i think way back in the day he goes back
quite some time now the idea behind this
here's kind of the cool thing the idea
behind the introduction of walter
lankowski was that at the time going
really going all the way back to uncanny
x-men number 109 the idea was that the
there was an attempt that was made by
alpha flight which was canada's uh
superhero team that was monitored by the
government in department h the idea was
that they wanted to bring wolverine back
into the full because wolverine had
previously been part of alpha flight and
what you had is you had uh alpha flight
traveling to try to find a way to kidnap
wolverine and bring him back and that
really kind of led into a little more
fleshing out of logan's backstory and so
on and so forth but the way this
originally played out if you go back and
you read alpha flight issues 23 and 24.
i'm not going to swear by that although
i guess i should be right since this
comics explained uh if you go back and
you read the old alpha flight stories
the way it played out and really it's
kind of an origin that al ewing runs
over again here it's not super important
but he kind of runs over again here the
notion was that canada was looking for
its own version of the incredible hulk
basically because the first time the
incredible hulk showed up in canada they
sent wolverine after him and really
wolverine was defeated for the most part
and so the question was okay they need
their own superhero team to defeat the
incredible hulk kind of an answer to
that version of his character and so you
ended up they ended up bringing in
sasquatch and they basically bombarded
walter lankowski with gamma rays and
turned him into the sasquatch character
the difference here is that back then in
the old alpha flight stories what you
had was basically a portal that would
open and so when walter lankowski became
sasquatch what he was doing is he was
switching uh places with a being called
tanorak now tanorak was one of these
like early beasts that existed in marvel
comics that was really in like a
different dimension but always tried to
invade earth and over the years in
marvel comics at least in the early days
running really throughout the 1970s and
1980s tanorak would switch places so
when walter lankowski became sasquatch
it would allow for just a little more
control each time by tanorak until
tanorak fully seized control of walter
and took over his body entirely now the
forces led to songbird basically
destroying tanarak but tanrak had been
dead for a long long time and that meant
that it was basically walter who was
always in control whenever he became
sasquatch he was always doing his own
thing but he was supremely strong he was
incredibly capable in his various
abilities and of course that led to him
being one of the many legitimate
challengers for the incredible hulk now
where you end up having like this bar
fight that breaks out basically between
walter lankowski and like a whole bunch
of crazy guys this of course leads to
him being stabbed which leads to him
going to the hospital in and of itself
this is not wildly important the reason
why this matters is because what ends up
happening here is bruce spanner goes and
speaks directly to jackie and when she
does he basically tells her this whole
thing is happening in the middle of the
night the clock is about to strike
midnight and when that happens he's
going to turn into sasquatch again when
he does turn into sasquatch it will not
be walter lankowski who is in control
it'll be the other guy and because bruce
banner doesn't really know about the
idea that tanorak is no longer part of
the picture in his mind he believes
tanarak will be the one to seize control
and so that's when he tells jackie you
have to evacuate the hospital you have
to get everybody out of here because if
you don't everybody's going to die and
that's when walter begins to sort of
re-transform again begins to kind of
push to the next phase and then suddenly
he ends up just having his he really
just kind of takes on this form that is
almost identical to the old tanarak
character and so it's kind of crazy
because it seems like tanarack is
essentially back now this leads into a
massive fight between the two groups
when really the incredible hulk takes
over and goes through and just starts
tearing everything up now bruce banner
is the one who tries to approach walter
and try to talk reason into him but this
is when you know tanarack basically like
slashes bruce banner's throat and says
you know i don't want to talk to you i
want to talk to the other guy so bruce
banner basically manifested in the
incredible hulk and the two of them
start going at it now this is when
things get cool because on the surface
we would write this off as just a
retelling of the old 1970s incredible
hulk stories with like the incredible
hulk versus out vs sasquatch and that
would be it what happens is al ewing
actually switches it up and where you
end up having him believing like we end
up asking the question are you possessed
by like mephisto or tanorak or something
like that the response here is i'm
neither of those guys i'm the person
you're terrified of the most and we end
up finding out the one the body of
walter walter lankowski is actually
possessed by the father by brian banner
the father of bruce now for those of you
guys who don't know when it comes to
bruce banner's character over the years
a hallmark of his character was that he
was he was a child of an abusive father
but a lot of that really comes out of
like bill mantlow and peter david's runs
of the incredible hulk because back then
in those stories they fleshed out the
idea that like the incredible whole
persona was a result of like all the
torment guilt and and and hatred and
rage that bruce banner felt at being
victimized by his father so frequently
and so his father played a major role in
the stories especially under peter david
but when you're talking about those two
runs being combined it caused all kinds
of crazy situations and it really
introduced some really cool concept in
terms of how bruce mann viewed his
father and how he viewed himself but
where you end up having bruce banner
walking around with like a victim's
mindset and really almost like kind of
panics for a moment he basically starts
lashing out but what ends up happening
is the incredible hull kind of splits
the difference right he sits down and he
says you know in a matter of seconds you
know in his own mind he sits down and he
says bruce banner's the one that's
afraid of his father i'm the incredible
hulk i'm not afraid of anybody the
incredible hulk is the strongest there
is and this is when he makes the switch
and and the incredible hulk stops being
incredible hulk and turns back into
savage hulk and when he does he
absolutely goes toe-to-toe with
sasquatch now remember sasquatch was
designed to be the canadian version of
the incredible hulk minus the unlimited
strength and so sasquatch is able to
readily hold his own and does quite well
i mean literally you have you know brian
banner in the body of walter doing
exactly what he does and ripping them
apart the difference here is that brian
banner did not count on the one thing
that we almost never see from the
incredible hulk the incredible hulk's
response being i eat gamma radiation
when it comes to the incredible hulk
because he consumes gamma radiation
anything that that emits gamma radiation
he can essentially feed off of you're
basically putting him in front of a
buffet and because of the fact that
sasquatch is bombarded with gamma
radiation the incredible hulk basically
absorbs the entire sasquatch persona
unto himself and then in turn leaves
walter lankowski with no powers
whatsoever and so what he ends up doing
is speaking directly to jackie herself
and this is kind of cool he asked jackie
the question he says you're a local
reporter in some small town somewhere
but you've decided to follow me all the
way here so the question i have is why
are you here what are you looking for
and jackie's response is i want to be
like you like i want to have the power
that you have i want to be a version of
the incredible hulk now of course this
leads to the to the hulk basically
walking away and saying go home do your
own thing but it's kind of crazy because
it introduces the idea that someone is
intentionally chasing after to becoming
the incredible hulk which is not
something you normally see but where you
end up having walter lankowski saying
like the sasquatch persona is gone it's
no longer a part of him anymore when
bruce banner is basically walking away
it's essentially this really cool idea
where al ewing does a throwback to the
old peter david and bill mantlow's
stories where the incredible hulk has
reabsorbed the personality of his father
he's reabsorbed his father's ghost and
so this is one of those things where it
returns to the old style of incredible
hulk storytelling back when it was more
character driven where you basically had
the incredible hulk dealing with the
torment of his father giving him all
kinds of hell and wreaking havoc inside
of his head
okay so continuing to play catch-up
we're covering the second part of
immortal hulk the one where he fights
the avengers and i want to be dangerous
here i want to have this discussion
about like world breaker hulk versus
immortal hulk because it's kind of this
debate that's like raging across the
internet right now where like everybody
in the in the comic book fandom is just
kind of like who would win here um now
there are a couple things to bear in
mind here there are a couple things
going on with this little particular bit
of a story and to kind of pick up from
the immortal hulk which you can find the
whole first volume down in the
description the idea here is of course
bruce banner has been back for a little
while really he's been he's been back
since like the events of avengers no
surrender and and one of the things that
kind of came out of that was the idea
that the incredible hulk and why this is
called the immortal hulk is that the
incredible hulk seems to be inherently
immortal which is to say bruce banner
kind of sat down and said okay the
incredible hulk is quote unquote died
multiple times and always always managed
to find a way to come back meaning the
incredible hulk is basically
indestructible and cannot truly be
killed now in reality this kind of seems
like al viewing basically saying hey
look guys so we're probably going to
kill the hulk more than a few times
whether whether during my run or
somebody else's run after mine so don't
worry the incredible hulk's always going
to come back and for those people who
had been reading comics long enough i
mean hell we could have told you that at
the moment as it stands right now the
incredible hulk has essentially kind of
come out of his battle with sasquatch
with walter lankowski right now
sasquatch is not a hugely important
thing this is really kind of alluing
seemingly you know seeming to kind of
wrap up a few a few plot threads that
were sort of dangling during uh towards
really towards the end of like the
incredible hulk going into like secret
wars 2015 where he was basically
draining off the energy of people who
were gamma irradiated it really kind of
seems to be like al ewing sort of
clearing the field right like pruning
the tree and just kind of making the
incredible hulk title his own but
regardless of the circumstance the
incredible hulk is more amped up now
than he was before and that's really the
first part of our discussion when it
comes to the incredible hulk really
immortal hulk versus world breaker hulk
world breaker hulk was rage incarnate
right like that's basically what he was
he was pure unadulterated distilled rage
angry as the incredible hulk had ever
been but all roads lead to realm
achieving a certain level of strength
can be done in a multitude of various
ways and the immortal hulk running
around and draining off the gamma
radiation of various people is a way to
amp up his power and kind of move him up
to a higher level of strength now
valuing up to this point is not really
explicitly stated the incredible hulk is
on par like immortal hulk is on par with
world breaker hulk that's really kind of
us to sort of determine by what we see
but one of the things that's going on
here is that following the events of the
incredible hulk's fight with uh with
sasquatch and the fact that that
lankowski had essentially been like
possessed more or less and it killed a
handful of doctors what this has done is
it's led to a guy named general fordian
essentially just kind of block mailing
alpha flight now a little bit of ketchup
here for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with this because in reality
the only way you would really know is if
you were reading the captain marvel line
of stories which after the events of
civil war ii she's really really been
unpopular when it came to carol danvers
because she was free-floating for so
long what marvel did is they kind of
took the old iron fist and power man
approach to like alpha flight and carol
danvers and what i mean by that is is
kind of whining back a little bit
further iron fist and luke cage were
like really really popular when they
first came out then they lost popularity
within the span of like a year and so
what marvel did is they kind of brought
them together under mary jo duffy and
said you get power man and iron fist
heroes for hire and that was kind of a
way to boost their popularity by
throwing them in as a team and
ultimately the title was cancelled as a
result of jim shooter's editorial
decrees as the editor-in-chief of marvel
but it's kind of what's going on here
right like carol danvers had been
free-floating for a long time for like
25 years she was free-floating but in
that interim period between 2012 and the
time that civil war ii came out you had
marvel take carol danvers and throw her
onto alpha flight and then have her lead
lead sword the sentient world
observation and response department and
so what that meant was that with alpha
flight being a canadian superhero team
that nobody ever really cared about
throwing them on and having them operate
a sword basically meant that carol
danvers oversaw all operations that
dealt with sword in his charter
monitoring space and then alpha flight
was basically her strikeforce team and
so with that that being the case right
now with alpha fly basically being the
strikeforce team and linkowski having
killed the doctors is good old-fashioned
blackmail it's general forty and working
through thunderbolt ross who always
wants to capture the hulk and basically
saying if alpha flight does not go
through and capture the hulk then
lankowski will be held responsible for
the lives he took even though he wasn't
really cognizant of what he was doing so
it's kind of forcing the hand of alpha
flight which in turn forces the hand of
carol danvers now the discussion of that
the alpha flight really has here is they
sit down and they say we cannot capture
the incredible hulk by ourselves and so
carol danvers kind of responds by saying
i'll assemble my my own little avengers
team and so what she does is she gathers
iron man with the hulkbuster ghost rider
black panther thor captain america of
course and then she-hulk and so what
they all end up doing is trying to stand
their chance against immortal hulk now
in this attack like he immediately takes
the incredible hulk i'm sorry gives the
word like a concussion with one punch
now thor kind of speaks up and says like
he's more powerful than he has been but
this does not mean that thor's saying
he's more powerful than he's ever been
that's a big distinction there if you
were to say he's more powerful than he's
ever been then that would supersede
world breaker hulk and we would
basically be al ewing saying immortal
hulk is stronger than world breaker hook
all it means is that in the moment
immortal hulk is incredibly strong and
incredibly durable so again it's kind of
left to us to decide what it is that
we're going to pull off but one of the
things to keep in mind here is that when
thor starts talking to captain america
you know he basically says like what
earth seems to have reproduced here with
the return of the incredible hulk is
that he's essentially kind of a god it's
something close to a god not really a
god but something close to a god now the
incredible hulk's always been on that
level right like the incredible hulk
once his strength reaches a certain
point has always been sort of god tier
in terms of what he could do now it
doesn't mean he's on par with galactus
right like the incredible hulk decides
he wants to fight galactus galactus
would just phase him out of existence
and that would be the incredible hulk
and that fight would be five seconds
long but when you're talking about like
strength you're talking about like thor
either relating it to himself who is a
definitive god or somebody more powerful
than he is now of course the incredible
hulk being able to give thor concussion
with one punch that's no small feat not
only that you've got the hulkbuster
armor which hulk just tears apart in the
blink of an eye now again that's not
really a major feat here because we've
seen the incredible hulk do that before
that's not really a major feat here
instead the closest indication that
immortal hulk is on par or possibly
exceeds world breaker hulk comes in the
satellites that tony stark uses to
depower him now these are not the same
satellites that were used during world
breaker hulk they're basically
satellites composed of hard light they
basically like bombard the incredible
hulk with uv light and essentially hit
him with the power of the sun and and
that's kind of what it comes down to of
course the incredible hulk loses and the
immediate vicinity is totally destroyed
but what we're seeing here is al ewing
kind of giving us tidbits of what
immortal hulk is truly capable of but
not really giving us a fleshed-out you
know real discussion here on the feats
of immortal hulk and so because of that
there's not really a lot of information
to go on here that kind of goes into the
to the next little bit when you
basically have him taken and given to
general fordian and then in turn
experimented on by general 40 and
scientists they literally dismember the
incredible hulk right like they use
adamantium knives and various weapons
and things like that and they basically
like dissect him chop them into pieces
but immortal hulk is still alive and so
again we're seeing like higher levels of
durability we're seeing like a higher
level of healing factor when it ends up
turning out that the only reason why the
immortal hulk wanted to be captured was
for the sole purpose of being able to
see what his own feats were right
because what this is this is al ewing
kind of saying even when the immortal
hulk was resurrected and came back to
life even he himself realized he was
able to do things he wasn't able to do
before how far does this go and so in
this instance where you know really like
this doctor kind of realizes hey you
just want to see what you're capable of
immortal hulk shatters the glass and all
those pieces start reconstituting
themselves and then in turn like
reconstitute themselves around this
doctor who just kind of gets like
smashed meshed inside immortal hulk
which is a pretty gruesome way to die
and then in turn like immortal hulk just
kind of breaks his way out but what
we're seeing here is again higher levels
of durability we're seeing like an
enhanced healing factor because we've
never seen the incredible hulk
dismembered before and then in turn kind
of restored we'd never really seen that
take place so it's a whole new kettle of
beans with regards to the powers that he
possesses here but probably the the most
damning little piece of evidence here
when it comes to the immortal hulk is
when it kind of like stumbles across
when when bruce banner in his normal
human form kind of makes his way through
and steals like from an old man's
clothing line or whatever it is some
probably some crazy guy in texas and of
course he you know ends up shooting
bruce banner and then like the
incredible kind of is like hey look i'm
gonna punch you a little bit but like
i'm not gonna kill you and then just
kind of storms off that's it but the
introduction of crusher creel really
kind of seems to be like the damning
piece of evidence in terms of immortal
hulk versus wall breaker hulk and why
world breaker hole comes out on top and
the reason why i say this is remember
crusher creel is the absorbing man and
he's kind of given this sort of banner
gene package as it's explained in the
sense that like it's injected in him and
basically he kind of gets like the
ability to absorb gamma radiation that's
really what this kind of goes into now
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with crusher creel he's really one of
the more underrated but supremely
capable characters in marvel comics
crusher creel is a guy who can basically
absorb the properties of any kind of
material and then turn his body into
that material right like crusher creel
can touch steel and then become steel he
can touch brick and become a brick he
can touch iron and become iron and so
he's wildly capable and so if if you
were to fight fight him in like a
construction area oh he'd be almost
indestructible and so with crusher creel
showing up and fighting the incredible
hulk with this kind of enhancement
package what is going on here is
something that we've never really seen
before the absorbing man literally
starts fighting immortal hulk and then
in turn starts absorbing bits of his
gamma radiation as they fight but the
fact that the absorbing man the fact
that crusher creel can go toe-to-toe
with the immortal hulk is an indication
immortal hulk is not on par with world
breaker hulk because if he was this
fight would have ended like that but
again we never saw immortal hulk face
off against absorbing man so we don't
really know how the two translate to
each other not only that there's a few
variables here the fact that the
absorbing man can absorb bits of gamma
radiation now changes everything because
as this goes through it's one of the
things where absorbing man gets stronger
as the incredible hulk gets weaker so
he's literally siphoning off the
incredible hulk's power now it's kind of
a cool thing here because there's
something going on behind the scenes
that was not readily apparent before
when the incredible hulk essentially
fought sasquatch because sasquatch was
possessed whatever had possessed him had
been had been passed to immortal hulk
when immortal hulk had absorbed the
gamma radiation of sasquatch and so what
this meant was that this kind of dark
evil persona which had been manifesting
as brian banner once it passed to the
incredible hulk is now passing itself
directly to crusher creel we didn't
really know what it was initially it was
oh my god the father bruce banner's back
and you know whatever peter david and it
was very easy to dismiss which
admittedly i was guilty of doing the
fact remains that what we end up finding
out here is that this persona is not
ryan banner it was masquerading as brian
banner instead this is being referred to
as the one below all and this requires
some explanation as most of you have
been dying for and it seemed like nobody
really did explain it because i watched
a lot of the videos on this and they
were just kind of like it's a thing
that's happening moving on i guess
that's why i'm comics explain so
in marvel comics satan is not an
absolute construct and the reason why i
say this is that in marvel comics the
the concept of hell is multi-faceted
right so like having our discussion on
hell from asgardian mythos for example
we've talked about her multiple times
that when jack when stanley and jack
kirby first created the concept of hella
within marvel kind of adapted and then
modified traditional norwegian mythos
that hell was just the afterlife for
everyone who died those who died in
honorable battle went to valhalla those
who didn't went to hell and that was
basically it when mistress death was was
created then that started introducing
and really kind of spawned out all these
different iterations of help and then
different writers sort of bringing in
the concept of like how this how this
kind of relates to humanity and so over
the years in marvel comics not so much
by editorial decree but because it just
kind of worked out that way through
various stories you've had the creation
of what are called hell lords and these
are basically beings who kind of rule
over hell right so for the most part
with the exception of hella who's kind
of out there by herself hell is a
singular place but there's it's like
this massive realm this kind of massive
dimension that is overseen in certain
little areas by different beings and
different people are sent there for
various purposes right so like you've
got hell which belongs like a part of
hell which belongs to mephisto and then
you've got like satanish black heart
these different concepts that exist out
there in relation to like what hell
really is how it actually functions and
and so on and so forth hell is an actual
place that exists and there are
different concepts different concepts
with it now in terms of what it is that
alguin's doing because of the fact that
the incredible hulk ends up going to
hell that al ewing may change that in
its entirety but that's one of the
things that kind of goes on here is
crusher creel and this one below all
popping up here kind of changes the
landscape because there's only ever been
a one above all saying the one below all
seems to introduce what is definitively
the absolute satan in marvel comics but
if that's true then it would follow sue
with like traditional western christian
mythology in the sense that the one
above all would be like the marvel comic
stand in for like the god of abraham
basically and the one below all would be
the actual satan like lucifer
morningstar tried and true that kind of
thing that ties into like western
traditional like baptist christianity
that kind of thing so again we don't
really know exactly how this is gonna
play out it's still a concept being
fleshed out by al ewing but because of
the fact that that crusher creel is now
possessed by this one below all being it
literally manifests itself by like
splitting crusher creel in half and just
like talking through a skull it's like
the creepiest thing ever but in the
middle of this whole fight where the the
hulk us group that originally kidnapped
the incredible hulk or at least that
hulk was handed over to after the whole
thing while he was being experimented on
they're still trying to track him down
alpha flight's still trying to track
down the incredible hulk so on and so
forth when this happens while this whole
event is going on immortal hulk sees
crusher creole running off into the
distance and realizes what's happening
that what had essentially taken place
when the gamma bomb originally went off
and transformed bruce banner into the
incredible hulk what it did is it
cracked open a door to another dimension
but that door never fully opened with
crusher creel being the absorbing man
what he can do is effectively absorb all
the scammer radiation in new mexico and
then open the door all the way and it's
actually a really cool concept because
what this does is it moves crusher creel
away from being a guy who can just
absorb physical elements and in turn
like a guy who can absorb like abstract
concepts which would really move him
into like god to your status to be
honest but the incredible hook sits down
and says like this door this green door
is now open and literally alpha flight
the immortal hulk they're all yanked in
and and to the other side of the screen
door which is essentially the realm of
the one below all and so that's cool
because what's basically gone on here is
the incredible hulk has been sent to
hell but let me know what you guys think
about this and i want to know your
thoughts how do you guys think the
immortal hulk stands against world
breaker hulk because war breaker hulk
did not have the ability to absorb gamma
radiation but immortal hulk does
all right fyi just so you guys know the
next two weeks are going to be a little
hectic for me so video schedule videos
might be a little like scattered in
terms of when they come out but this
coming weekend i'm going to the ultra
music festival then the weekend after
that i'm going to wrestlemania and after
that is clear sailing but until then
it's going to be kind of crazy but in
the last video the the really kind of
what we picked up last when it came to
the incredible hulk is the incredible
hulk ended up in hell now if you're
curious how that happened go check out
the video it's kind of a lengthy
explanation but the general gist here is
that what al ewing kind of established
is that in marvel comics there's what's
called the one below alt and the one
below all is kind of like the opposite
of the one above all right which is kind
of what you would expect given the name
but while the one above all is a creator
of all things al ewing kind of runs with
like this sort of judeo-christian mythos
which is to say that like the one below
all is kind of as essentially like satan
and the one above all is like the god of
abraham is really kind of what's being
hit out here and it's kind of a bold
move to sort of adopt like the the dc
comic stance on like gods and so on and
so forth and throw it into marvel comics
but the idea here was that somewhere
along the line and we'll actually find
out in this story when that was but
somewhere along the line the one i'm
sorry the one below all basically
intended to like gain access to the main
universe by virtue of a door that was
open during the original gamma bomb
explosion of uh of bruce banner you know
when he basically became the incredible
hulk and so where he essentially kind of
like entered in where he was really kind
of like pulled into the uh pulled into
hell when the door was opened by like
the absorbing man since he was being
used by the one below all what this
means is that at the moment they're
basically walking around hell now the
cool thing about this is that no matter
what you guys see in this story all of
this tape basically takes place in
health but at the time you know as this
is kind of going on al ewing kind of
writes in that these really really cool
series of questions were things like
what is hell supposed to be what it does
is it kind of plays into the notion of
the worst kind of hell is your own
personal health one that like you can't
share with anybody else where it's just
you by yourself and during torment like
for all eternity and so it's it's kind
of crazy you know how this how this sort
of unfolds but what it also does is it
basically switches over to the absorbing
man now remember the absorbing man
crusher creel used to be a guy who could
only absorb like tangible materials
right so like metals and and rock and
you know plastics and and water
different things like he could absorb
all different kinds of things and then
like become that thing but one of the
things al ewing kind of built on here is
that absorbing man has the ability to
basically absorb gamma radiation and
that's one of the things that bruce
banner kind of picked up as a byproduct
of like their fight or at least you know
kind of an
kind of a change on his character but
because of the fact that absorbing man
had basically been used by the one below
all for the purpose of like opening the
gamma-ray door again we didn't exactly
know what that motivation was now if
this seems kind of ambiguous and
confusing to you don't worry because
it'll all get cleared up by the end of
the story we can't really explain it yet
but it is kind of a cool little thing
because he's basically met by the
arrival of puck now we have no idea why
puck's here puck's one of the guys from
alpha flight but one of the things that
ends up going on as they basically go
through this version of hell they kind
of end up running into these characters
who have essentially like passed away
but the difference is that like they've
been sent to hell for some reason or
another and what they're basically
running into are kind of like these
copies of them the difference here is
that like the various people with the
incredible hulk while they don't neces
while they do kind of know where they're
at the thing they struggle with is like
letting go but it's one of the things
that they're really kind of failing to
realize here but at the same time it
kind of makes sense because historically
speaking in marvel comics when somebody
enters into the afterlife which is to
say like when someone dies and passes on
it's possible to retrieve them but it's
kind of arguing toying with that idea
something that's like potentially
possible here the other part of this is
that of course with general thunderbolt
ross dying the incredible hulk didn't
know this and in fact we don't really
know exactly how thunderbolt ross died
we know that he's dead we know that like
in in captain america he's dead we know
in this he's dead and it's kind of cool
to see the whole thing happen but what
it does is it creates like a hell red
hulk right like a red hellhole it's like
this really twisted mutated version of
the red hulk that's just like rampaging
and facing off against the incredible
hulk himself now again one of the things
that happens here is because they fall
to multitude of times before and because
this is not really the red hulk he's not
as powerful as he normally is and so for
the most part the incredible hulk
overpowers them and literally like shuts
them down quick fast and in a hurry and
like tears his body in half so for the
most part it ends pretty quickly and so
from here what we do is we switch over
to brian banner and bruce banner kind of
being kept in like a stasis of sorts
what's kind of been shown here
consistently is that like brian banner
the father of bruce his abusive father
is like the ghost that torments him that
just won't go away but that's actually
not the case but with the this
conversation between the two what it
does is it basically kind of explains
what's going on with the nature of brian
banner in terms of like how he functions
and so on and that's one of the big
differences here is that this is in a
way brian banner but not truly it's it's
it's brian banner in terms of his forms
and memories but it's also brian banner
in the sense that like he's possessed by
the one below all but what brian banner
basically says is that he was one of the
world's leading leading scientists when
it came to gamma radiation and that in
studying gamma radiation and studying
like what it was possible and what all
could be done what he ended up doing was
having this dream where he basically
witnessed like this green door and what
laid beyond it and what laid beyond it
was basically this kind of like this
demon entity that nobody had ever seen
or heard of before but with brian banner
kind of having this this sort of torment
you know having this fear based out of
it the other part that came with that is
his anger towards bruce and what it what
it almost kind of seems to do is create
a corollary when the two were entitly
separate that when it when it came to
brian banner he was raised in a
household where he was abused all the
time he never knew anything but just
like hate and torment and abuse and so
when his wife came along suddenly like
he knew what it was like to be loved the
fear was that when his child was born
that like he would take the love away
from from him like his wife would love
the child more than she would love him
so we're sort of al young's way of
coming along just saying like yeah like
brian banner was like literally hated
his son because he was afraid his wife
wouldn't love him anymore and how did he
do that by literally beating the crap
out of his wife and pushing her away it
was kind of a screwed up tormented
perspective of himself but that's kind
of what he looks at when he looks at
bruce he's kind of like that's the
nature of things like like i'm screwed
up you're screwed up the whole nine
yards and so what we end up finding out
here is that as they're kind of climbing
their way up to the top of this tower
basically where this green light emits
from that the one below all is waiting
for them that the one below wall
basically intends to use and attempts to
like enter into the main marvel universe
using the body of bruce banner now it's
kind of cool here the reason why the one
below wall intends to do this with bruce
banner specifically is that when bruce
and the incredible hulk entered into
hell they split basically they split
into two different two different beings
which of course we've seen happen before
but for bruce it works because of the
fact that bruce banner's body is the
only one that can really withstand that
much gamma irradiated power that the one
below all uses now in terms of how
crusher creel tied into this the idea
was that with crusher creel there needed
to be a means to essentially open the
door that with crusher creel he was
really nothing more than just somebody
running around and siphoning off gamma
radiation from people and then in turn
like siphoning it off the hulk and then
being taken to like the original launch
site for the incredible whole gala bomb
and then in turn opening the door that's
really kind of how that played out like
that was that was the whole basis behind
the actions of absorbing man go around
absorb everybody's gamma radiation and
then open the door that way the
incredible hulk will inevitably follow
follow you in because he's going to want
to know what's going on when he arrives
here him and bruce banner will split
i'll take the body of banner and then
i'll go into the main marvel universe
now the question is what would happen if
the one below all did that but we have
to assume if the one below all is the
antithesis of the one above all then it
has to be equally powerful which of
course begs the question why can't it
not escape its own dimension so again
there's a few caveats here in terms of
you know some some questions that we
still need to have answered by by al
ewing himself but that's really what
kind of goes on is that in order to
basically deal with like you know kind
of keep the incredible hulk at bay while
the one below all does uh does this
whole thing what it does is send like a
veritable army of demons facing off
against the incredible hulk now of
course rick jones kind of regains
himself to a degree and then like fights
off against you know against these
demons with the incredible hulk and then
of course rick jones basically dies but
in the process the absorbing man
essentially absorbs like all the gamma
radiation he can like all the gamma
radiation that was put in there and then
in turn like blows it back into the
incredible hulk and so what this means
is the incredible hulk is supercharged
the incredible hulk is back to where it
was before but also more powerful and
amped up because of all the scam of
radiation that he's essentially siphoned
off from like everybody else right like
that was the basis behind the incredible
hulk he was a guy who was a byproduct of
gamma rays but what the incredible hulk
is doing now is he's running around with
the gamma rays of like everybody who's
ever been an incredible hulk it's an
amped up incredible hulk and when that
happens like when the incredible hulk
gets that amped up he fights the devil
like he literally fights he fights satan
like he just he just unleashes like this
massive clack and like dissipates this
cloud that makes up the the one below
all and then in turn like he just kind
of you know vanishes for a little bit
now one of the things that i'll ewing
hits on is that like the incredible hulk
did not actually kill the one below all
there's no way he could because the one
below all is just so astronomically
powerful that all the incredible hulk's
done is just kind of dissipate him and
buy them a few minutes enough to be able
to basically like travel through the
doorway and return back to earth but
that's basically exactly what happens
like the two of them just kind of you
know dim alongside like like sasquatch
and puck and everybody else just
basically like travel through this this
barrier back in the main marvel universe
but again it wraps up pretty fast not a
whole lot doing here i mean it's a cool
little story but it's more of one of
those things where it just kind of wraps
up quick fast and in a hurry but the
overall gist here really kind of the big
takeaway from what it is that al ewing's
done is he's created a whole another
cosmic entity you've got a being who who
presumably is on some level equal to the
one above all but it's absolute opposite
and so that begs the question if the one
below all can only jump into the bodies
of those who can basically house gamma
radiation and can withstand its power
basically being bruce spanner then what
would happen if the one below all
traveled into the main marvel universe
successfully arrived would it be like
dormammu where like everybody's gonna
die and there's no two ways about it you
know is is that how it's gonna play out
is that how it's gonna go down we don't
really really know here uh but it is
cool and it is pretty interesting
okay so continuing on with uh the
immortal hulk man here is the thing i've
been reading the incredible hulk for
years right like even before greg packs
run like i've been reading the
incredible three years and for the most
part the stories always just kind of
seem to be rehashed that's why greg
pack's run was so cool like greg patron
basically did things that we hadn't seen
before like you had you had bill mantlo
you had peter david it was like okay the
psychological torment of bruce banner's
father on bruce himself and the reason
why we have the hulk and all that kind
of stuff and then for something like 20
years it was basically to sort of like
fill in stories right like the
incredible hulk smashing things now you
know and so on and then greg paxtron
brings in like like planet hulk and and
world war hulk and you know world war
hulk after smash all that kind of stuff
you get like these really really cool
stories and then like al ewing comes
along and turns the entire thing on its
head because the way this ends is nuts
it's one of the coolest things ever i
don't really even think most of you guys
know who it is that shows up at the end
and it kind of makes sense because he's
only ever really appeared like once but
what this does is it initially kind of
picks up with it with really with like
rick jones right because that's one of
the things that really kind of came in
with the stories that we saw was that
rick jones's body was taken and betty
ross was shot in the head right and it
was really a way for like al ewing to
kind of thin the herd so to speak of
like the incredible hulk mythos or at
least that seemed to be the case but
what it does is it kind of switches over
to uh to jackie mcgee now remember
jackie mcgee is the reporter that we've
seen over the course of al ewing's run
on on the immortal hulk so it works in
terms of her just kind of being here and
and really ever since the events of like
the incredible hulk in hell which she
was part of she's like okay i kind of
like sit back and just not be a part of
anything right now because what i've
seen was crazy and so i need to kind of
regain my bearings
get back to a state of normalcy and try
to figure it out and her boss is like
but like no you're not either because
like we need you to go
we need to go figure out what's going on
with the fact that a giant hole was
smashed in the house of betty ross and
like something's going on here right so
it's basically like get back into the
incredible hulk investigation and that
kind of stuff which is kind of wild and
so from here you end up picking up with
with bruce banner and with doc sampson
now doc samson is a character that we
haven't really talked about much before
and in all honesty there's not really
been a reason to i mean leonard
sampson's okay but basically he's he's
infected with gamma radiation but he
never really turns into a tried-and-true
hulk right like the green scan and all
that kind of stuff instead his hair just
turns green whenever he taps into his
super strength now he's not infinitely
strong well there is a finite level to
his strength but in reality he's always
kind of been more of an outlier in the
hulk family than anything else right
i've always kind of kind of considered
him to be that way it's one of these
things where he's a guy that bruce
usually always goes to whenever he needs
help right i mean it was doc sampson who
was working with bruce banner when we
got professor hulk when we ended up
getting gray hulk merging with with
savage hulk and then creating like a
whole new personality doc sampson
usually always been kind of like the
psychologist behind what's going on with
bruce but he also works with him outside
of that stuff too so it's it's kind of
cool for what it is but again he's just
sort of here and bruce essentially says
hey look there's things going on here
but my memory is in little blocks i
can't really fit in all the pieces we
need the incredible hulk to do the rest
now this is one of the things that al
ewing has really kind of touched on when
it's come to the incredible hulk and
really kind of established that wasn't
really there before whenever it came to
the incredible hulk he would just
manifest there have been times over the
years when bruce banner and the
incredible hulk have kind of worked
together and bruce can bring the hulk
out and say hey man we need your buddy
and the hulk will be like okay and then
he'll pop up and do his thing but more
often than not they've been conflicting
personalities and when that happens
basically bruce doesn't really remember
anything the incredible hulk does again
there have been instances where he does
but it's not normally part of the mythos
but one of the things that al ewing has
really kind of established here is an
almost werewolf kind of situation where
the incredible hulk comes out at night
and bruce banner comes out during the
day it's kind of a cool thing now al
ewing does not dismiss the notion of of
the incredible hulk popping up when he
needs to but one of the things that he
focuses on is that if bruce banner's in
the presence of like uv rays of sunlight
then the incredible hulk's not going to
be able to pop up it's kind of cool the
fact remains the incredible hulk's able
to kind of fill in the missing pieces
and so when him and doc sampson break
into the shadow based facility that
bruce banner was previously held at this
in turn leads to like all these gamma
irradiated animals right and this is
kind of cool because what this does if
you if those of you guys who've been
reading marvel for a long time this
really hints hard with different notes
of like weapons plus right like that's
what it feels like weapons plus was like
was it was like weapon one was captain
america right like if you go back and
you read grant morrison's uh x-men i
think it was captain america was weapon
one nobody knew how to duplicate the
super soldier serum so what you got
under weapons plus is you got weapon one
with captain america then you got two
through nine which is just random
experiments trying to create super
soldiers then you got weapon 10 which
was wolverine and then you got
characters after that you got deadpool
you got phantom x you got the step for
kakoos you got like all these different
versions but this is what this feels
like and so what they've been doing is
like irradiating animals with gamma
radiation to see what happens so you've
got like gamma radiated bats you've got
a gamma radiated dog is what it looks
like you've got a gamma irradiated
gorilla which actually looks awesome but
what they're also doing is they're
basically wrapping someone or something
in a cocoon with the intention of like
creating another gamma irradiated beast
and it's kind of an interesting thing
because when that happens what we end up
finding out at least once all these
animals are destroyed is that basically
this was a trap that had been set these
were basically a distraction and when
that whole thing pops off it'll
basically lead to like the defeat of the
hulk or at least the attempt to defeat
what they didn't account for was the
sudden emission of solar race like
ultraviolet race and when that happens
the incredible hulk is forced back into
bruce banner's form and then they're met
by the arrival of bushwacker now
bushwacker's been here since really like
the beginning for the most part of
alguin's run but bushwacker is an
old-school character he was created back
in 1987. it was a daredevil comic i
don't remember which one but it was it
was ancenti and rick leonardi i think is
who it was uh but basically he was just
like this guy who was a con not really a
contract killer well kind of i mean he
really kind of was right like the idea
was he built on mutant hysteria
originally when he was created he built
on mutant hysteria and started taking
out mutants wolverine figured it out and
then his wife thought he was crazy and
so the result was that wolverine started
tracking down bushwacker and then his
wife basically went to matt murdock and
was like we got to get this guy
committed and ultimately it led to like
the two of them coming into conflict in
an effort to catch bushwacker they
didn't and ultimately like like carl
ended up going to work for kingpin i
think it was and then after that he just
kind of free-floated marvel comics for
years but it's kind of a cool thing
because with with bushwacker getting the
upper hand on bruce what bushwhacker
didn't account for is the arrival of joe
fix it right like the return of joe
fixit hulk now joe fixed it hogan in
fact it's kind of cool because alguie
sort of covers this in the story but we
can explain it here joe fix that hulk is
really more of like mobster hulk and in
truth he's the original hulk so in in
terms of like real world publications uh
the incredible hulk was originally gray
most all of you guys probably know that
the six issue mini series marvel had to
change them to green because of printing
issues but what marvel never explained
in the comics is why the incredible hulk
originally showed up gray and then
turned green it wasn't until later on
down the line that joe fix it was
introduced that what marvel said is that
in terms of the incredible whole
continuity appearances which is to say
inside the comics in the marvel universe
which hulk came first it was joe fix it
that when bruce banner was first blasted
by the gamma radiation he turned into
joe fix it then joe fixed it went
dormant and then the savage hulk came
out and he'd been that way ever since
but one of the things that goes on here
is you can't actually transform into the
gray hulk persona because of these solar
rays so it's basically bruce banner with
the strength of joe fixer at least part
of the strength of joe fix it but then
he doesn't have the ability to like heal
from anything and so when you have
someone like bushwacker who's got
cybernetic enhancements what it does is
it gives bushwacker the upper hand over
bruce banner himself and so when that
happens and joe fix it has to basically
rely on like ingenuity and intelligence
in order to be able to pull it off and
that's kind of the cool thing because
with these enhancements again bushwacker
does stuff like make his arm make his
hand into like a gun different things
like that but when he goes through he
basically manages to like hack the
lighting system and when that happens he
starts sorting through all these
different wavelengths ultimately
reaching gamma radiation and when that
happens like it just starts like because
of so gamma so much gamma radiation at
one time it kind of overwhelms his body
he turns into like this giant crazy
looking hulk form and then like smashes
bushwacker
and actually just ends up killing him
but then we end up finding out that what
what shadowbase has been working on here
is creating a new version of abomination
and this new abomination that they've
been working on is actually rick jones
so it's kind of a way to kind of bring
the rick jones concept back and then
just sort of go forward from there but
what this does is it switches over to
jackie mcgee and then it jumps into the
character of betty ross and we find out
she's not actually dead she's what
really seems to have happened is she
seems to have evolved this is one of the
things that no one's ever really seemed
to hit on when it comes to the
incredible hulk mythos and it's actually
a new concept as far as i'm aware when
it comes to the incredible hulk one of
the things to bear in mind is that it
really is a mutation of genes but the
gene mutation is unstable right that's
the reason why bruce banner can go from
like the incredible hulk and back again
his genes literally change from one form
to another but it would make sense that
there would be like a next stage of
evolution that like any one of the hulks
could reach and turn into something else
with the mutant population it was like
that for years right the mutants were
just like a singular a singular power
right like a mutant pops up their powers
manifest and then they have those powers
forever more it wasn't until grant
morrison's run on new x-men then
suddenly we got secondary mutations it
doesn't happen all the time but it can
that's how emma frost got her diamond
form and that seems to be what's going
on here with betty ross so like she's
basically mutated and transformed into
like a new version of like a new kind of
hulk that we haven't seen before now the
reason why this matters and the reason
why this is important is not because
betty ross is a new version of hulk
because it sets a precedent because what
it means is that from this point going
forward al ewing can at any point change
the incredible hulk into something else
the status quo is maintained and it
makes sense and so from here like you
literally have bruce banner who goes to
essentially like vegas basically like
goes to this this really shoddy looking
hotel and then starts talking to the
incredible hulk through a mirror right
and what he says is there's these
versions of ourselves that we haven't
really accounted for or at least that
are out there somewhere right so like
savage hulk child hook is a really good
one devil hulk this is the first time
we've seen it referenced in quite some
time joe fix it hulk we have bruce
himself then you've got professor green
scar hulk who we have not seen since
jonathan hickman's run on avengers and
new avengers when the incredible hulk
was running around so there are these
versions of bruce these versions of hulk
that bruce cannot account for and
doesn't know where they are but then
we've also got this new immortal hulk
and so it's kind of cool because bruce
is basically sitting down and
reconciling all these versions of
himself really kind of arguing saying
here are the versions of hulk that i
care about and here are the ones that
you'll most likely see over over the
course of the immortal hulk story but
then of course they're met by the
arrival of the new abomination in the
form of rick jones now abomination when
it was emil blonsky was just like this
violent guy who destroyed things that
was really all it was with this version
uh he's actually kind of got a mutation
in the sense that what it does is it
basically consumes other people right i
mean it really seems to consume their
heads more than anything else but what
it also has the ability to do is spew
this kind of stomach acid that really
seems to like negate the healing factor
of the incredible hulk right and we know
this because when that happens the
incredible hulk's hand is basically like
like dissolved and destroyed but it
doesn't come back and so what this does
is create a kind of final weakness for
the incredible hulk which is to say this
version of abomination is the deadliest
one we've seen before and the reason why
is because again unlike emil blonsky
this one can emit an acid that will take
away from the healing factor of the hulk
right so it's like the miramasa blade of
wolverine or like carbonation when it
comes to anybody with a healing factor
it's a cool little way for for al ewing
to kind of reach out into the mythos of
what marvel's done so far and then grab
these small little tidbits and roll them
in but these forces of shadow base which
basically kind of destroy these loose
ends these folks who witness what
happened and are running out of the
hotel uh when they take them out now
they're met by the arrival of betty ross
as like this giant bird hulk looking
thing which is actually incredibly
violent she's like ripping people's
heads off and like tearing off their
legs and like gutting them and it's like
the most violent thing ever and it's
amazing dude i i dude i'll ewing i love
this
[Laughter]
i love this it's actually pretty awesome
but nonetheless this version of betty
she is still coherent to a degree but
she's not like her former self right
she's actually seems to be a little more
simple in terms of her function when she
was read she-hulk she was a lot more in
control of herself and able to function
like a normal coherent human being and
this one she's almost kind of reverted
to like a very base form and while
shadow base is watching all this unfold
and the abomination is like you know
seems to be like tearing up the
incredible hulk and really like it has
done a number on him taking his eyes and
so on and so forth and left him for dead
betty ross where it would seem that she
was going to go save or going to go
fight a fight abomination instead she
turns on the incredible hulk rips his
heart out and then eats it and so it's
kind of like okay so like basically the
incredible hulk's dead now and
everyone's turned on him and so what
this does is it switches through spanner
being sent back to hell right like being
sent back to the realm of the one below
all where again he basically meets with
us meets with the one below all in the
form of his father but then we get this
sort of information drop that we didn't
have before that al ewing is really
again kind of interjecting and changing
things up so when it came to gamma
radiation in marvel comics for years it
was just one of the various forms of
light wavelengths right like that was
really it was just an energy that was
out there you could blast somebody with
gamma radiation or whatever but it was
basically just a form of ultra like a
form of light ray what's established
here by al ewing is what he says is that
in this instance that's not all of it
like it is a it is a light ray that's
true but it's also like the other half
of it is also like energy that basically
is emitted from like the realm of the
one below all bruce banner exists partly
because the one below all allowed him to
right the one below all was always
looking for a way to kind of escape his
realm and enter into like the main
marvel universe essentially like being
satan more or less right like satan's
desire to escape hell and then show up
in earth and wreak havoc among you know
all kinds of crazy stuff that kind of
seems to be the case here and it's cool
because what it says is that like bruce
banner like you are essentially part and
parcel to the realm of hell this is
where you belong by virtue of everything
that's happened the energy you need to
become the incredible hulk is here what
triggers it is the gamma radiation light
that exists out there in the main marvel
universe the incredible hulk couldn't
exist if the one below all didn't exist
it's kind of a crazy theme because the
response of bruce is like there's no way
that's true that can't be the case but
the response of the one below all is no
but it is though like it's an absolute
truth but here's the issue and this is
why i like what it is that alewing does
we don't know if he's telling the truth
we don't know if he's being honest like
you could kind of assume he is but
there's no reason to believe he is right
because of the one below all is kind of
like this prime version of evil right
like this absolute evil in which all
other forms of evil stem from all other
demons and things like that like
mephisto and so on and so forth if all
that's the case then like there's no
reason to believe that it would be
telling the truth if being deceptive and
being duplicitous would basically lead
to his goals being achieved so again
it's a cool little moment here because
in the middle of all this what suddenly
happens is bruce banner wakes back up
again right like he pops back up the
incredible hulk manifests again and
starts tearing into abomination and
actually seems to rip him apart pretty
easily right the fight's over like that
i mean it's over in the blink of an eye
and so from there like of course jackie
mcgee shows up and she's like what the
heck's going on like i thought you were
dead and it's kind of a cool explanation
here what al ewing says is that the
incredible hulk having his heart ripped
out jump started his healing factor
because remember the incredible hulk
exists as self-preservation that's the
the most important charter of the
incredible hulk that's why it is in the
comics whenever bruce banner was was
like fatally wounded and the incredible
hulk popping up would save him that's
exactly what would happen the hulk
exists to save himself and the only way
the hulk can really exist is if bruce
banner's physical form exists right
there have been a few instances where
that's not been the case where they've
been separated from each other but
that's not the status quo that's not the
norm they always end up merging back
into a singular being again the only
other exception to that is during the
dot green run i think it was when doctor
doom created a new host body and
basically put banner in this new body
and then the incredible hulk went
forward in banner's body and then just
kind of stayed that way right so you had
like bruce banner walking around then
you had the incredible hulk walking
around and then they eventually you know
merge back into a singular being again
but again it's kind of cool here i mean
literally the incredible hulk just like
rips open what's basically this shell
surrounding rick jones and then you have
rick jones physical form back again so
it seems to have kind of been a way for
for al ewing to bring back rick jones
right because he'd been dead more or
less it seems to have been a way for him
to bring him back by saying hey look
rick jones was physically dead he was he
was he was in the ground that was the
end of it and then you have his body
taken by the shadow base initiative you
know by the hulk initiative they cover
him in this basically like a shell that
essentially is is the new abomination
and then once that that shell is ripped
off and that version of abomination is
destroyed all you have left is rick
jones's body and so it's kind of a cool
thing because we don't know if rick
jones is actually going to come back or
if he's just going to be left to be
buried and that's going to be the end of
it but it is kind of a cool little
moment a small little thing for for his
character we don't really know where
things go from here and so what ends up
happening is that in the midst of all
this you basically have like like bruce
banner who seems to have kind of been
whisked away we don't know exactly when
this takes place all we know is he's
essentially kind of yanked away into
this dark void surrounded by a few stars
he's hanging out with like mr immortal
which is really weird uh and then like
like this this kind of you know bright
figure approaches him and says like you
know who i am do you know what this is
all the things you've ever done over the
course of your life do you truly know
what you are do you know what you're
meant to be and what you are to become
do you have any real idea what it is
that's going on here and it's kind of
crazy because bruce banner here is met
by the arrival or really met by like
metatron i don't know if you guys know
who metatron is i feel like most people
don't because he's so obscure but
metatron is basically the voice of the
one above all and it's cool because what
this means is the one above all is
paying particular attention to
everything going on with bruce spanner
whether or not the one above all chooses
to act we don't know we assume he will
like we assume that one above all will
act but basically like everything that's
been going on here with the immortal
hulk with regards to the one below all
and everything that's been happening on
earth has all gone noticed by the one
above all and presumably it will act it
will intervene or it will do something
and i don't know maybe it'll make him
like angel hulk or something like that
okay so we are getting into the immortal
hulk uh tie-in for the king in black now
for those of you guys who are not
following immortal hulk and i think
we're about one story arc behind um
there's a lot that's happening in there
right so what's really happened more
recently is that the leader had
basically found out or figured out a way
to essentially tap into and remove in
essence the personalities of the
incredible hulk right so like devil hulk
and all those different versions so
devil hulk that personality has been
killed off uh the mind of bruce banner
so like his consciousness was extracted
from the body of the incredible hulk and
so all we really have right now in the
immortal hulk line of stories is the
savage hulk who's been drained of a ton
of game of radiation so he's really
emaciated and whenever the savage hulk
turns back into banner it's basically
joe fixit hulk who can essentially
controls the body of banner right so
bruce banner's mind isn't actually there
so whenever we see bruce banner in this
story it's essentially joe fix it who's
walking around pretending to be banner
right but uh the funny thing about this
is this is one of those comics that we
rarely ever get to see well we don't
have any words whatsoever instead it's
all just art and it's an awesome idea
see these are the kind of comics that i
love right that's why one of the reasons
why you guys like for king and black one
it's definitely a story you should be
buying but two comments like this are
comics that i would personally buy those
you guys don't really know how i deal
with comics for the most part i only
really buy digitally the only time i
ever buy a physical copy of a comic is
if it's of significance so like i have a
physical copy of giant size x-men number
one uh fantastic four annual number two
which is the original origin of dr doom
i've got uh i think x factor issue
number five which is the first
appearance of apocalypse but i only
really buy comics that are that that are
like super significant i only really buy
physical versions of that beyond that i
just i just buy them digitally right
because it's infinitely easier to read
all my comics on an ipad than it is to
carry around like 15 physical comic
books right i mean after all this is
2020 digital is the name of the game at
least for me anyway so one of the cool
things about this is that what you have
here is essentially like christmas eve
more or less right now this takes place
of course after knoll has basically
descended on to uh on to new york and
presumably the rest of the world but one
of the funny things that's shown here is
is that when we initially saw the king
in black one shot it basically looks
like all was lost right that like all
humanity was conquered all was lost it
was the end of the day for everybody
what this really points to is the idea
that it's not necessarily all is lost
but a lot of people are in hiding right
a lot of people are kind of retreating
and trying to stay hidden away from
being attacked by null ah but that new
york in and of itself in terms of the
heroes that we know have more or less
fallen right and a lot of this comes by
way of a guy who's just making his way
through the street right taking some
presents some different things that he
has and trying to leave but when he
drops one of these gifts he's suddenly
met by the arrival of the immortal hulk
now again the immortal hulk is drained
of a ton of gamma radiation and that's
why he's not nearly as huge as he
normally is he's still strong as all get
out like make no mistake he's by no
means like on par with like the average
guy right it's not like you know
immortal hulk versus captain america
who's gonna win an arm wrestling contest
it's not really like that he's still
super strong just not necessarily where
he used to be in terms of all his
abilities and all that kind of stuff but
this guy basically sees him and is
scared out of his wits right he's just
like what in the heck
[Laughter]
so he just he takes off running now when
this present drops the immortal hulk
because of the fact that he's basically
a childlike savage beast reacts the way
a child would right like presents you
know and then just goes to grab it but
then suddenly he's met by the arrival of
one of the grendels of knull and this is
where things get interesting now the
funny thing about this is that when it
comes to savage hulk and marvel comics
over the years he's largely been
displayed in a few different ways but
those ways have essentially been limited
right so either you see what is in
essence a child-like persona not in so
far as like he acts like a kid but in
the sense that he thinks like a kid
right he thinks in simple terms that
he's not by any means the sharpest tool
in the shed the idea that the savage
hulk always wanted to be left alone
right he just wanted to live in peace
there was a time and i think it was
either doing roy thomas or bill bantlow
or peter david's run or maybe all three
um where he basically just kind of
wanted to live out in the wilderness on
his own and just be left alone right and
people just kept running up on him and
causing him problems i want to say that
was roy thomas because that was when the
whole arcs about general thunderbolt
ross really started to take off in terms
of him being a villain for the immortal
hulk but in terms of how he's shown here
which is a very very childlike person
right so the incredible hulk operating
and thinking on the level of like a four
or a five-year-old is not really
something that we've seen before we
haven't really seen him depicted exactly
in that way and so one of the things
that happens here is of course the
immortal hulk basically ends up grabbing
you know this this street light post and
then just like beats the crap out of the
grendel symbiote with it
now of course this is by no means going
to stop this thing right i mean it's
just it's not going to work but what
happens in all of this and this is
really a really really cool moment what
happens in all this is that when the
grendel symbiote goes to seize control
of the immortal hulk to take him over
and then bring him into the fold as
being a servant of null the immortal
hulk grabs the the stub where the light
posts used to be and because of the
because the electricity coursing through
it it goes through him and then into the
grendel which basically fries the thing
to like it totally incinerates it and so
that's kind of that's that's kind of a
cool thing because i like this idea that
the the savage hulk is kind of this
childlike lumbering beast that kind of
bumps his way into success because it
still kind of maintains the nature of
the hulk that like that by and large the
incredible hulk was just brute strength
that's all he really was and there was a
kind of element to there that like the
incredible hulk did whatever the sword
he needed him to do in order to win but
a lot of really really classic and great
writers you know steve englehart even
people like that focus on the idea that
the incredible hulk despite being
childlike and stupid still had this sort
of understanding of how to utilize the
things around him right now i'm not
saying this child like hulk is like okay
hulk grab electric post electric post
shock grendel hulk escape like i don't i
doubt it was that line of logic we're
not really giving any kind of of thought
pattern here that's what's really cool
is it gives us the ability to kind of
make it up on our own or at least
reference the immortal hulk as we go
through it but what ends up happening is
that when he opens this this you know
little present that it's basically just
this small little you know keychain type
device that looks like a whistle of
sorts but because of all the pandemonium
and the chaos that you end up having
these uh these cops show up right now
the incredible hulk consistently wanted
the incredible hulk consistently
untrusted you know not trusted now even
you know especially now in the aftermath
of really everything going on with the
leader the aftermath of the events of
shadow base and all that kind of stuff
the hulk's like public enemy number one
right like everybody's hunting for this
guy and so where he points down to the
ground to where the symbiote was but
it's no longer there then like one they
don't really know what to make of it and
two if there was something there to see
it's not there anymore so as far as
they're aware the hulk's just being
crazy like he always is and they
immediately opened fire now of course
this leads to the immortal hulk
basically jumping away but both of these
cops are seized upon by the grendel
symbiote now as the immortal hole kind
of makes his way through he ends up
coming across a place called mantlos now
of course this is an obvious reference
to bill mantlo kudos to you al ewing for
doing this algae is the one who's
writing immortal hope right now kudos to
you man it's like one of the most
prolific incredible hulk writers in the
history of the comic if you care about
the you know character dissection right
if all you want to do is see the hulk
smash then greg packs the writer for you
but if you care more about like the
interpersonal relationships of the hulk
why he does what he does the the whole
idea of like psychological trauma and
all that kind of stuff then bill manlow
was kind of the writer for you from back
in the day right bill mantlow and then
peter david who just kind of continued a
lot of the writing that bill madlow did
now the reality is this story is
basically a stand-in for like fao
schwartz just a ridiculously overpriced
and expensive toy store
you'd only ever buy like two things
there right it's just it's ridiculous
[Laughter]
kind of a funny story myself mariah sal
and tiffany and i think ben and ethan
over at comedypop and maybe danielle um
we all met up during the weekend that
myself and i were going to wrestlemania
and we all went to like we went to eat
and went to go shopping in new york we
went to like fao shorts and it really is
just that expensive right
they're really selling products based on
their name that's really all it is
but when the incredible hulk sees this
kind of of toy set here something akin
to like connects right which is just
mechanics is what it's called here but
what is something i can to connect that
he kind of has this flashback to when he
was younger and he enjoyed science
studying things like that and the
abusive nature of his father now this is
a really really great moment and this is
one of the things that i really really
praised al ewing for with his handling
of immortal hulk because it would have
been very easy for al ewing to be like
okay guys i'm writing immortal hulk and
all he's gonna do is just beat stuff up
but it's not really that way right in
the early stories in the early run of al
ewing a lot of it really was like the
bill mantlo peter david's style of
storytelling which was like
psychological trauma different things
like that the one below all basically
appearing is like bruce banner's father
brian banner kind of tormenting him in
that way it was it was kind of wild but
the the whole theme when it comes to the
immortal hulk is that the psychological
trauma he experienced at the hands of
his abusive father still reigns supreme
right it's still like the one thing that
bruce banner is the most terrified of
and so that's what makes it kind of
intriguing because when he sees that he
immediately starts lashing out right
like a child he doesn't really
understand his emotions he doesn't
understand what he's feeling and so all
he does is take that lack of
understanding and turn it into rage
right and that's kind of how we as
people are whenever we feel a certain
way but we don't really know how to
interpret our emotions effectively by
using our words we turn to the most
basic primal instinct which is rage it's
the fight or flight right like our
emotions literally put us in a fight or
flight mode right like it's just you
know i don't know how to handle it so
just fight just just attack you know
just be angry and that's kind of how
that's how you sort of differentiate
between a rational thinking human being
and a person who really is childlike in
nature right a rational human being
would kind of be like okay this is how
i'm feeling how do i interpret this and
then go forward accordingly a child like
human being would just immediately
devolve to like rage and anger and just
lash out at people right it's what kids
do and so because of that the the
immortal hulk basically kind of
transitions back into banner again now
remember this is not technically bruce
banner it's the body of bruce banner but
the mind of bruce banner is occupied by
joe fixit right the actual mind of bruce
banner is just kind of out there in in
the ether somewhere and it's just kind
of out there you know uh taken away by
by the leader and doing its thing and so
with that being the case of course the
grendel manifest now this is something
kind of twisted and something we don't
really normally see that the grindel has
actually merged both cops into one
entity right so they're like a cinebite
from like the hellraiser movies
the hellraiser books from clyde barker
damn you clyde barker for writing those
books the world is now a darker place
because of because of the fact that
hellraiser was created but this of
course leads to uh leads to really joe
fix it banner we're just gonna call him
banner for the sake of it oh you know at
least him just kind of making an escape
and trying to figure out a way to come
out on top now this is one of the big
differences between joe fix it and
almost any other version of the
incredible hulk almost all the other
personalities of the hulk whether he was
the horseman war for apocalypse or
savage hulk or like you know world war
hulk or something like that what warlord
probably would have done this too uh but
one of the big differences is that joe
fixit was a thinker he was a guy who
thought he was by no means on the same
level as banner but he would basically
reason and rationalize his way out of
different situations that's what made
him so dangerous as it was a man who was
exceedingly strong but was also a guy
capable of intelligent rational thought
and so as the grindel basically follows
him into this toy store he kind of
starts making his way through right this
grinder's kind of slinking along and
it's really twisted in morbid and really
you know really macabre to be honest
with you guys but joe fix it and you
know really banners just kind of like
okay so like we buy our time here right
like i know how to take this kind of guy
out something else that's really awesome
here is he's wearing bunny slippers and
those slippers look amazing
i would love i would love to have some
of those bunny slippers i'd walk walk
around those things like hell yeah like
what's going on guys this is rob and
i've got my bunny slippers on my feet
it'd be pretty awesome but what he
basically ends up doing and this is this
is what's so smart what's so cool about
fixit is he plots any schemes and he
basically lures uh lures these guys into
a uh in front of like a giant speaker
system and then immediately sets the
volume to 100 and puts it on blast and
like the sheer just impact of sound
right because remember grindels just
like any other symbiote out there have
an inherent weakness to sound the sheer
impact of sound literally scatters the
grindel symbiote almost all over the
place right it certainly like takes away
from these guys who have basically been
dissolved and absorbed and that kind of
a thing but where it tries to begin
reconstituting itself he walks around he
literally walks up on him with the
stereotypical makeshift flamethrower a
candle and an aerosol can and literally
just sprays these guys down right just
phrase them down it's like yep business
is done like that's that's pretty much
how we do it
when you mess with joe fix it you mess
with the best
right i love phrases like that right
like like it would have been cool like
it would have been cool of that if we
got like just that one line at the end
of the comic where he just looks at him
and he's like when you mess with the
bull you get the horns right like
it would have been amazing but of course
this allows you know the the incredible
hulk to kind of revert back into his
childlike form and literally just start
having fun inside of this toy inside of
this toy store in all reality i know
it's probably not exactly what you guys
were expecting but if i'm being honest i
loved it like i love this comic right
because one the immortal hulk stories
are already incredibly dark and then two
we kind of get like the the king and
black being an exceedingly dark story
it's kind of nice to see this almost
sort of dark humor going on here i like
it i really enjoyed it
okay so in the last video we did on the
immortal hulk uh we had done technically
only like four of the five issues that
we were supposed to right and the whole
reason why was because this issue is
going to be double-sized right so it was
like okay we don't really have enough
time to fit it all into a reasonable
time frame i know some of you guys would
love it if i made videos that were like
45 minutes long but the reality is that
we just can't really do that in a
feasible way right you know for for most
of the people on the channel they would
just kind of be like all right that's a
little nuts the fact remains here i'm
glad i waited right because this
double-sized issue is kind of crazy
right it's not really a descent into
madness but it's certainly
wildly intriguing right and it
definitely is one of those that's going
to take us a little bit of time to get
through but this particular comic and
this is something that i didn't notice
right off the bat and in fact i read
this when it came out and then waited a
day and now i'm recording it
i actually had to read it like two or
three times to really understand
everything that was going on here
because it was just so far away from
what i'm normally used to but this
actually takes place in the ninth unit
in the ninth multiverse right it takes
place in the next multiverse and the
reason why is because at the at the end
of one of the more recent stories the
immortal hulk had basically ended up at
the very end of all reality right like
the end of the entire time stream when
everything comes to an end and i still
stick by the idea that it was possessed
by the one below all right the one below
wall had totally taken control of the
immortal hulk and in that in fact this
actually confirms it but the one below
all had basically taken complete and
total control of the immortal hulk and
it kind of got on a rampage and what it
had done was made it to the very end of
time we didn't know what all it had done
we simply known and it just made it to
the very end of time and then consumed
the sentience of that universe right the
idea that was was essentially kind of a
repeat of galactus right galan was the
last survivor of his of his own universe
and in fact the multiverse and
ultimately was reborn into the newest
iteration of the multiverse as galactus
basically it was really seeming like it
was going to be the same thing that in
some form or fashion the incredible hulk
would become like what was basically the
new galactus but the immortal whole
consumed the sentience of the universe
like literally ate it took all of his
energy and basically the new multiverse
was given form we're not really given a
time frame here all we're told is at
some point between when the new
multiverse came into existence and this
moment here the immortal hulk has
destroyed everything and it's kind of
nuts right it's it's kind of crazy here
because what we end up getting are what
are called basically like these
post-humans they're not really a race
they're and in reality it's kind of
interesting because al ewing gives us
like a man and a woman insofar as you
can just because of the fact that the
way these creatures are designed and the
way they look aside from their colors
you know blue and pink are really not
traditionally a man or a woman right but
this picks up with a being whose name is
actually spelled
interestingly it's p a r percent l right
so i'm going to say like parcel or
parallel you know something along those
lines let's say parcel just because you
know percent and then l so you know
personal or something along those lines
but regardless this being has is
basically tasked with like perusing the
cosmos and has been for some time
perusing the entirety of either the
universe or the multiverse itself and
then trying to basically figure out if
there's anything left and what is
basically realized is that there isn't
that basically all the worlds in the in
the entirety of this universe all
totally broken there's nothing left all
the worlds are completely eradicated and
completely destroyed and there's nothing
left here it's just a giant expanse of
what's basically blackness and like some
planets that have been torn to rubble
and so on and so forth like it literally
looks like a massive explosion went off
in the universe and so what this does is
it leads to parcel coming to encounter
another being by the name of what we're
going to call we're going to call it
danielle you know just for the for the
sake of it but with the two of them
communicating we get a couple cool
things here the first is that they don't
use traditional speech right they don't
use words hence the reason why we can
consider them post-human uh because of
the fact that they seem to have evolved
beyond that there's no real indication
that they were human at one point in
time right it's just kind of the best
description i can come to uh with the
exception of the fact that there's a
wholly different race that existed out
there but regardless of the situation
they use these kind of plants you know
devices more or less to communicate and
what they basically discuss here is the
existence of things and and what parcel
basically says is there there's nothing
left there's there's no life no nothing
we're it like we're the only things left
in this this universal space everything
else has been destroyed by the creature
and that's all they really describe it
as is the creature and it really kind of
presents a scenario of hopelessness here
because what this does and the way this
is depicted it almost seems like this
universe is coming to an end and in a
lot of ways it is it's being done
prematurely but it's coming to an end
and it begs a lot of questions here when
this new universe was created how did it
look were there similarities there was
it this universe came into existence and
then right off the bat the the immortal
hulk started killing everything the
reality is is from what we've seen in
the timelines when a universe comes into
existence you basically get this
explosion this kind of big bang that
leads to you know really like the
formation of the celestials which leads
to the aspirants and the war between the
two of them that always breaks out the
celestials start creating life and
different things like that but the
overall gist here is that time passes
right like it takes some time even with
galactus galactus laid dormant for
billions of years before he emerged and
consumed consumed his first world time
passes from one point to the next from
the beginning of the universe to when
life starts popping up so it's not like
this universe was created then all life
sprung into existence maybe it did again
we don't really know the origins of this
place all we know is that between the
time it came into existence and now the
immortal hulk has destroyed everything
but notice this the immortal hulk is
almost depicted as like this mythical
figure right like these guys they know
it as the creature but it's like they've
never encountered it before like they've
never actually met it before all they
know all they all they've done is like
witness you know the destruction that's
that's been brought here so there's a
lot of ambiguity here but what you also
end up learning here is that there are
these things called tiding flies that
this particular group were able to
create and tidying flies are a means of
communication but they're a means of
communication that spans both time and
space right so think of it like a
telephone where you could call somebody
in the past and that's basically what
this is these these organisms that are
created that are normally supposed to be
bred under regular circumstances or have
been engineered here because what this
is designed to do is show a moment of
panic now again because there's so much
that's unexplained with regards to this
race how its culture functions and how
it operates and so on and so forth the
only thing we know is that the means by
which these tide flies were i guess
these tiny flies were created is
considered to be heresy that they were
artificially created as opposed to
basically being born so to speak you
know for for lack of a better word but
the result here is that parcel is
basically tasked with taking this tiding
fly and sending it to the past now
here's the funny thing about this is
parcel's responses well that's
ridiculous though because like it would
lead to the destruction of all things
because we don't know how it would
change the past and the response of
danielle is but like everything's
screwed up anyway though so like who
cares like it doesn't matter
it can't get any worse than it is right
now the only direction from here is up
and so as a result of that parcel takes
a tidy fly and leaves right ends up ends
up departing here and that's when we
start to get into like this appearance
of the immortal hulk and things popping
off and this is when it all really gets
cool because what you end up getting is
is parcel basically showing up to the
home world of their planet right the
homeworld of their people and again
we're not given a whole lot of
information here outside of what it
looks like outside of how the tribe
functions and it doesn't really matter
anyway and the reason why is because
partial notice is off in the distance
this green light and realizes that the
immortal hulk is coming for them and so
the result of this is that when the
immortal hole gets there this guy is
colossal right and this is the funny
thing about it is when you think of the
incredible hulk as a being that can
basically transcend and go into like the
universal space that you think of that
and you're like okay so this is cool
this is interesting but like the
incredible hulk would still for the most
part be the same size right because you
think of the incredible hulk and you say
okay the biggest he's ever really been
was heart of the monster right when he
was just colossal in size because he
just been feeding off of so much energy
so you kind of chalk that up and you say
okay he might be about that big but
that's basically it but when you're
talking about a version of the immortal
hulk that's really just kind of like a
vector for the force of the one below
all basically this is an ultra powerful
entity right we'll talk more about this
here in a second once we actually get
into how the one uh one below all is
involved in all this and so far as how
it's you know how it's how it's
functioning here but basically you're
talking about a cosmic level hulk is
really what you're talking about here a
cosmic level of the immortal hulk that's
as big as a planet because literally
he's flying through this system flying
through moons and so on and so forth and
these moons look like they're about the
size of of like grapefruits in
comparison to the size of the incredible
hulk so it literally just shows up and
just punches the planet like it's the
craziest thing it shows up and just like
punches the planet shatters it destroys
it and basically all things are pretty
much dead now like every all forms of
life in the universe are dead save for
parcel who manages to send this tiding
fly out back through time to the modern
day in order to keep this from happening
but one of the things that parcel does
is it basically communes and mentally
bonds with the immortal hulk simply
asking the question why are you doing
all this and this is when we start to
get into what's going on with the one
below all that what ends up happening
here is that when this communication
takes place that it's not simply the
immortal hulk being controlled by the
one below all tearing everything up that
what it's been doing is as it's been
going through and killing all these
various races and in these groups out
there that it's been in turn consuming
their souls right so like all these
souls all these forms of life are
confined within the uh within the the
immortal hulk which essentially is is
really appearing to help bolster its
power and then all of that in turn is
being controlled by the one below all
that's somewhere along the line the
immortal hulk as we know him in the
moment right now in the present day in
marvel comics has been totally taken
over controlled and dominated by the one
below wall who now uses the body of the
immortal hulk as a vector right like
uses it as a means for it to take
control right so it's like removing the
immortal hulk from the shell that is its
physical body and then the one below all
stepping in its place but here was the
big question that i had here right
because what the one below all basically
says is like i am the one below all like
with the power that i have all i want to
do is destroy things like i am being
powered by hate all i want to do is
destroy and eradicate all things which
i've basically succeeded in doing the
question we would ask here is where is
the one above all where's like the
living tribunal different things like
that now for a lot of those cosmic
entities for the living tribunal for
like the phoenix force and for you know
the the other entities like eternity and
so on and so forth we can basically go
on what the one below all is right it's
the antithesis to the one above all
meaning that they would have to
basically be equal in power or the very
least with the purpose that they serve
the fact that the one below all was cast
down by the one above all indicates the
one above all is even if only marginally
more powerful than the one below all but
regardless of the situation the fact
remains that you're talking about a
being that's more than enough to destroy
the living tribunal any one of those
guys who are out there right so assuming
the living tribunal even intervened and
even stepped in it never stood a chance
in the first place right it never had a
chance to basically win but as far as
the one above all goes this is where al
ewing is being a little bit a little bit
ambiguous here now in truth we can kind
of run on the position of the one above
all historically in marvel college right
for those of you guys who are familiar
with it the one one above all almost
never appears and never acts in fact
there's only ever really been a couple
of times where it has three times where
the one above all has actually acted or
done something that allowed it to
interact with the larger various
superheroes who were out there right the
first real instance of that came when
the one above all interacted with the
fantastic four and took on the form of
jack kirby the second instance of that
came when the one one above all took on
the form of a homeless man and
interacted with peter parker in order to
basically say hey look sometimes folks
die you know it sucks that aunt may's
dying but that's just kind of the way
that it goes right it's just the nature
of things it's all part of the plan you
don't have to understand it you just
have to accept it the final time that
i'm aware of with the one above all
actually interacting was during uh jim
sterling's conclusion for his whole
infinity saga after the events of secret
wars when the living tribunal had died
and the result was that adam warlock of
that alternate reality was tasked with
becoming the new living tribunal and was
appointed to that position after after
encountering and speaking directly with
the one above all and that's it the one
above all almost never really acts and
marvel really kind of takes the stance
of saying well if it happened in the
marvel universe it happened because it's
part of the plan of the one above all
right like the one above all allows it
to basically happen in reality based on
what we've seen the one above all is an
absentee landlord right like he never
does anything like it's it's kind of
crazy it's like why do you even exist if
you don't do anything at all
it's really kind of crazy there uh but
what seems to be going on here is it's
one of those things because it's like
kind of like events are being set in
motion and and the one above all only
ever really seems to act under the
circumstance whereby it's its council is
basically needed in the case of like
when it spoke to reed richards of the
fantastic four and said hey look you
know here's basically the cycle of life
and death when it spoke to peter parker
about the same thing or when it was a
case of the living tribunal and somebody
had to take the living tribunal's place
and only the one above all can appoint
someone to that position aside from that
it's the only time that it ever really
seems to act and so we can kind of look
at this and we can say okay so the
reason why the one above all never
really decided to take a stance here is
because of this very action of this
tiding fly being sent back to the past
it was a way out right the one above all
didn't need to act it's really
indirectly alewing essentially saying
this is all going to be averted
this is all going to be stopped and so
the one below all will basically be
stopped before this future can come into
existence in the first place and it
successfully destroys everything right
so it's kind of interesting there's sort
of a way where marvel kind of answers
its own question they sort of answer
that question by virtue of the story or
they leave it to us but it is intriguing
albeit a little bit sad to basically
know that one below all using its power
through the immortal hulk killed
everybody right it killed thanos and it
killed like all the avengers and the
x-men and everybody assuming they all
even existed in this timeline in the
first place and so as a result of that
what we basically get is this kind of
last little tidbit that everything is
broken that everything is gone here that
in this future where the one above or
the one below all you know basically
uses the ammo hulk that the one below
all wins right like it basically comes
out on top here that everything will
continue to be destroyed all things will
basically come to an end here and there
will be nothing left right because if
the sentience of the universe was
essentially eradicated by the one below
all and in turn the one below all
created this new you know universe and
then destroyed everything in it then the
buck stops here there is nothing else
there's no more universes coming after
this there's no more life here there's
no sentience of the universe to die and
recreate everything that's it there's no
going forward this is where it ends
right which is something that we've
never seen before you know even if you
look at the what if stories jean grey
becomes a dark phoenix and she wipes out
the universe the universe would be
reborn again because all that life
existed therefore the sentience of the
universe has existed had existed but
that sentience of the universe was never
destroyed it was one of those things
where like it would basically die of its
own volition insofar as it would kind of
coalesce in on itself and then be reborn
into a new universe this doesn't it
doesn't happen here there is no
sentience of the universe there's no
nothing everything is gone here because
what you basically have is the most
powerful form of the incredible hulk
ever created in the history of marvel
going on a warp path and consuming and
destroying everything so it's kind of
nuts right like the one below all hulk
like it's it's crazy in terms of this
level of power we've never really seen
this from anyone like it's it's kind of
nuts here but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end i
know this one was pretty abstract
relatively speaking to the stories that
we're kind of used to it's one of the
things that al ewing acknowledged he was
kind of like hey guys so when you read
this story you're going to see some
crazy stuff and it's going to look
pretty bonkers don't let that turn you
off to it i doubt that the rest of this
is going to look that way it's really
just designed to show what the universe
would look like in the far flung future
when everything comes crashing down
okay so we are getting back into the
immortal hulk and a lot of you guys have
been asking for this this is because we
really kind of let this most recent
volume finish before we went back in and
covered it so we're kind of covering the
the whole volume now right it's just the
traditional volume uh volume type
stories that that we do kind of off and
on you know sometimes we do single
issues sometimes we do whole volumes it
kind of depends on how i feel about it
but this story is particularly
interesting right because i wouldn't say
that this takes a break away from the
kind of angels and demons devil you know
one below all sort of situation that
we've had before this really shines a
light more on the direction that the
immortal hulk is going in at least for
right now anyway right like really
focuses more on banner and focuses on
the the immortal hulk and the reason why
that's important is because al ewing
really likes to kind of start his
stories off with a bang right for
example for those of you guys who read
ultimates by al ewing the first story
arc was turning galactus into the
lifebringer right so it was like totally
shifting galactus up and it was like
okay that's cool right and then you
start to go into the more of like the
meat and potatoes let's build this up
let's kind of focus on the character
with the ultimates i would go as far as
to say that was a series of comics that
was only ever going to be short-lived
right because when you look at it a lot
of people weren't really buying it so it
wasn't really like it was going to be
lasting for like 100 issues or something
along those lines and the other thing is
to kind of build on stuff right so with
the incredible hulk uh really with the
hulk himself he's like a timeless
character right so al ewing's run would
last a lot longer than it would with the
ultimate since that's why you see him
really delving a little more into the
human side of things but to kind of get
into this right to kind of have this
discussion what this does is it
initially focuses on essentially bruce
banner inciting revolution and it's kind
of cool right you know because what he
does here is he kind of makes the speech
to humanity more or less kind of like
this this sort of pirate speech where he
basically uh is in a location of course
we know it's in shadow base and he even
says he's in shadow base but doesn't
really tell anybody where he is right
he's just kind of like this is the place
that i'm at and then kind of broadcast
this message now the overall message is
sort of peppered in over the course of
this story but we can kind of
consolidate it all at the beginning of
this video and it's one of the coolest
things right because basically what he
says is the world that we live in the
human world as you guys call it
basically sucks and this is kind of a
big moment because what it is is this
bruce banner kind of walking away from
like the human side of himself and kind
of focusing on the fact that he is in
fact a hulk right that's what he is you
know he and the incredible hulk are part
and parcel and it's interesting to see
that because we've always kind of seen
this this scenario where bruce banner
hates the incredible hulk side of
himself right but in this instance he's
kind of welcoming it in right he's kind
of you know being like this is who i am
now but what he does is he really kind
of illustrates this is an organization
that was funded by the federal
government with a budget of 1.2 billion
dollars and that money could have gone
to education that money could have gone
to any number of things that could have
made the world a better place but
instead the government decided to use
that money for to basically track me
down and track down people like me and
then try to harvest me and make other
versions of me for their own personal
use right to basically use gamma
radiation to make their own personal
army and and he starts to go into these
interesting scenarios right he starts to
talk about how what you have in in the
united states at the moment is basically
a kind of system that exists where you
have exceedingly vastly exceedingly
powerful people amassing great
quantities of wealth for themselves and
then just kind of leaving leaving
everybody else out there to you know
sort of high and dry but the funny thing
about this is he doesn't really let the
american people uh get away with playing
the victim right you know where the
american people would look at this and
they would shake their nod their head
and say yeah he's right man they really
are letting us you know they really are
screwing us over instead he kind of
turns the table on them and then says
okay so like what have you done about it
right like if this is the kind of
country you live in then what have you
done to fix it and then that's when you
hear crickets right that's when you see
empty pockets because it's kind of like
well i mean you know it's it's uh
you know like you guys have all these
complaints about how like amazon never
pays taxes so why are you still buying
products off the website right like it's
one of these things where he kind of
points a finger at people and says you
know look like the issue that you have
is doing things changes things doing
nothing keeps things exactly as they are
but you're lazy you're comfortable right
and because you're comfortable you don't
really see a reason to change things you
don't want to change the status quo
because it means life would be
uncomfortable so all you're going to do
is reduce yourself to posting on reddit
forms or making reddit posts and doing
twitter hashtags and that's the extent
of your involvement now from there it
jumps into a conversation he has with
amadeus cho and the response this is
what's kind of cool about this is while
the message of bruce banner is one where
it's kind of like okay this is a little
heavy-handed basically telling the
american people if you want to change
things then quit being lazy and do
something about it they do right they
start to respond and that's really kind
of what you needed right you kind of
needed a scenario where you needed
somebody to get out there and give
people a swift kick in the ass right and
just be like you're the source of your
own problems everything wrong with the
country comes down to you right you're
the one that votes for people you're the
one that buys companies products it
really is all your fault so if you want
to change things do something about it
and people are people are responding
right and it's kind of a cool thing
because you know initially amadeus cho
is kind of like okay i'm on the fence
about this a little bit right like i'm
on the fence about this whole thing
because i don't really know how i feel
about this one what you're doing is
resonating with people but two you're
inciting revolution and usually whenever
people revolt people get stupid right
because people people revolt based on
their emotions in the moment right like
this is bad so let's do something about
it okay cool let's execute the kings
he's kind of like people don't people
are highly emotional individuals right
when people get highly emotional logic
goes out the window and so yes you're
getting people to act but you're getting
them to act emotionally you're not
getting them to act logically and
reasonably but at the end of the day
that doesn't really seem to be a concern
right you basically have people who are
just kind of spray painting on walls we
believe in bruce spanner you have this
idea of people who are basically using
these outfits you know that basically
helps them to kind of deal with tear gas
who are yelling like you know like hulk
smash you know and then just like
grabbing tear gas canisters throwing
them back at the governments that
launched them at them in the first place
you have like a full-scale revolt on
your hands but one of the things that
you see here you know in addition to
rioting is you also see what's called
rocks news now rox news is where we
start to really get into the the kind of
meat and potatoes of this right because
you've got like djs right these sort of
these sort of political pundits who are
like hey everyone we should all do
something and by by all of us i mean you
i'm just going to stay here behind my
radio and just talk you know that's
that's what i'm going to do
you know and it's interesting because
you kind of keep getting like these
rocks news blips right you know these
these rocks on news corporations these
these rocks on things where it's always
this idea of like dude the country's
going to pot things are going to pieces
the hulk is bad you know so on and so
forth everything's kind of going nuts
and so what you end up having is you end
up having amadeus cho kind of almost
sort of washes his hands and says look
man i get where you're coming from i get
what you're trying to do but this kind
of situation never really ends well and
then name where the submariner steps in
right he was just kind of there
overhearing things and bruce banner was
aware of his presence and was really
kind of like thanks man for not stepping
up here while amadeus cho was here
because he would assume that we're
working together and you end up getting
you know neymar who kind of offers a
couple bits of wisdom but we don't
really get an exact uh specification for
what that is basically what we get is we
end up getting bruce banner basically
saying like you know if these companies
and this world around us doesn't really
want to change right if these companies
can do what they can do because there's
no consequences right because they've
purchased politicians they kind of you
know pay those politicians to ensure
nothing really happens because you guys
aren't going to do anything then we will
right like then basically i'm going i'm
gonna start like the first strike in a
war right it's basically the hulk
revolution you know the incredible hulk
initiates a revolt in the united states
and it's kind of crazy because when all
that happens then suddenly you switch
over to dario agar now the reason why
dario agra is doing this and this is
kind of an important thing dario agar
was introduced as part of jason aaron's
run basically on thor right thor god of
thunder issue number 19 i think it was
and dario agar is the head of he's the
ceo of roxon oil roxanne corporation
really it's technically it's roxon
energy corp but they're they're a
multinational company right and they're
about as crooked as it gets if it's if
it's slavery if it's drugs if it's
anything illegal right purging you know
buying politicians if it's anything
illegal roxanne likely has their hand in
it and so what you get here is this sort
of coalescing of themes right you
basically got the shadow based group who
are essentially like okay look you know
we're gonna send bruce banner in but one
of the things to understand about
translocation essentially teleportation
is that it's a very risky maneuver right
like it might be easy for reed richards
because he's super smart but for the
rest of us it can be kind of difficult
right so the fear is that when bruce
banner teleports to this location this
roxanne location where he's going to
launch his first strike that he could
end up being teleported there is just a
giant amorphous blob of like bones and
organs and blood and veins and muscle
and all that kind of stuff or he might
make it there in one piece
there's no way to really know we just
gotta give it a shot and find out and
hopefully you make it there now because
of the fact that the immortal hulk is
immortal he would come back right he
would be fine but like at the end of the
day even if you could heal from all that
you don't want to go through it
[Laughter]
because it would suck at the same time
you have dario agar really sort of
putting off what's really is this
overconfidence right this idea that we
don't really need to worry about
whatever strike bruce banner is going to
do because the forces we have the
berserkers are more than capable of
being able to withstand a hulk now where
you have dario agar who's talking to his
guy you know one of his one of his guys
higgins and he's kind of like i'm not
really worried about this you know i'm
not really worried about whatever it is
a hulk's going to do whatever attack he
launches it's not going to matter
everything's going to be fine the the
immortal hulk shows up here and just
starts crushing all these berserkers and
i don't even mean by like a little bit i
mean by like a lot like he's just
absolutely you know decimating these
guys you know out there in in oregon and
the reason why that matters is because
once dario agar is being told what's
going on his response is what did you
say and that's what we end up learning
the significance of all this that in
oregon that when it comes to roxanne oil
corporation in order for them to kind of
maintain the image that they have which
is a positive one they essentially
influence all forms of media right they
influence television they influence
newspapers the whole nine yards in terms
of their own their own newspapers they
release their own uh television shows
they're you know radio jockeys that are
kind of bought and paid for different
things like that now at the end of the
day it still doesn't really matter right
like the job of the average person is to
consider multiple sources of information
not just one but it is kind of a cool
thing because it means that roxanne has
her hands in a lot of propaganda out
there and and really the the strike or
the center in oregon is really kind of
the main hub of it all that's where all
the servers are that's where all the
information gets sent out there from and
so because of that it's a terrifying
prospect for uh for roxanne because what
it means is that bruce banner is true to
his work that he's basically bringing
the entire institution crashing down
right that's the whole idea it's a kind
of insight revolt among people and bring
the entire institution crashing down
around all of them and so with that
being the case well it is it doesn't
really mean like a full and total you
know destruction of the united states
right he's not really saying like let's
tear down the government let's let's do
those kind of so on and so forth but the
result is that it's kind of leading to
you know the american people in a lot of
ways sort of kind of coming out and
saying yes we're tired of everything
being the way that it is and so with
that being the case dario agar in turn
takes the smart approach and this is the
smartest thing that he could have done
right if the entire idea behind this
revolt more or less rest on the
shoulders of how people perceive bruce
banner and the incredible hulk that he's
kind of a rallying point then take away
their reason to believe that right like
at the end of the day people believe
what they want to believe but people are
also easily swayed and they're easily
manipulated right that's kind of how
people are not to sound too cynical
about it but people aren't very
intelligent when they operate in groups
and so because of that it's one of these
things where he's like well then let's
shift the whole thing and turn it into a
smear campaign against the immortal hulk
that's what we need to do is basically
tarnish the guy's name so nobody will
really believe in him right if people
you know it's if people don't believe in
him then nobody will have a reason to
follow him and so this comes in a
multitude of different ways one of the
first people to get hit is jackie mcgee
now if you guys recall jackie mcgee was
the one who was really following the
immortal hulk around in terms of all the
events that were going on and kind of
documenting them right so she could
write a paper on it and what's happening
here is when she's writing this this you
know writing about this kind of revolt
that's going on that she writes it you
know not from a neutral perspective of
like this is the thing that's happening
or the who what when where why and how
instead she's doing what most members of
the media do which is writing it from a
a perspective where it's how i see it
right so she's writing it like you know
we are being affected and this is
bothering us and we should you know we
you know should we revolt and different
things like that when in reality the
media is not supposed to really be part
of society it's supposed to be removed
from society in that way of here is a
here's an objective depiction of what's
going on not a hey guys look at what's
happening that's affecting all of us
right it's not really supposed to tie
into the emotional element of people now
tying it into people's emotions makes
them want to read about you and watch
you which is why you see things
unfolding that way but with regards to
what jackie's doing it's kind of flying
in the face of what the news corporation
what they're supposed to be doing so
it's not really dario agar kind of
intervening and it is but but not
necessarily the other way in which he
intervenes is by basically stepping up
and releasing these kind of monsters
into into the city of phoenix arizona
and the reason why is because when this
happens of course he knows that right
off the bat as soon as that takes place
the immortal hulk and all of them are
going to respond and the reason why he
knows that is that because when you have
shadow base who runs up on bruce banner
says hey man like there's these monsters
that showed up in in phoenix we have to
respond then he's question is why and
it's like well because the avengers are
off planet which they are they're they
were dealing with star brand at the time
the fantastic four are off doing their
thing right the x-men are totally tied
up in krakowa they're really not going
to worry about it too much the champions
are currently on the east coast with no
real fast mode of travel to get there
right so it would take them hours to
arrive on the scene and the agents of
atlas suck and so because of that it's
kind of like all right like no one no
one can respond except for us dario
agger knew this right because he had
people in different locations that were
feeding him this information and so
launching this attack in in phoenix
arizona instead of like san francisco or
seattle or new york or something along
those lines or even in the middle of the
united states right so like kansas or in
missouri or something like that what
this basically meant is that it presents
a scenario where they're the only ones
that can really get there in time enter
the actual main campaign itself that
when the immortal hulk teleports in
suddenly he's swallowed by one of the
monsters now this is where you end up
getting the really smart played by
daario really this is where you really
kind of learn that as a ceo he's
exceedingly effective right because when
this goes down he's basically swallowed
by this monster the immortal hook is
swallowed by this monster and set upon
by like all these you know different
things in there these these you know
bugs and and different you know
organisms and and so on and so forth and
and you know what have you but while
that's also going on you've got the rest
of the uh of the immortal hulk team who
are essentially showing up and and
facing off against these various forces
and so on and it's cool to see right
you've got rick jones who really is more
of like a gamma level god now i don't
really know what's going on with him
he's kind of resurrected from the dead
so i guess he's partially alive but
partially dead i'm not really sure but
he's like floating around right like he
looks like molecule man or like the
beyonder or like doctor manhattan it's
kind of what he looks like right like
just showing up using like telekinetic
and telepathic gamma powers and like
destroying things and so on and so it
looks kind of cool you've also got doc
sampson you've got uh you've got red
harpy or betty ross here but the other
thing about this is again you get the
absorbing pressure creel and that's one
of the things that i've been talking
about guys crusher creel and this it's
important you guys understand crusher
creel is underrated and it's so good to
see somebody using him right like it's
so good to see somebody using crusher
creel in an interesting way he doesn't
really get a whole lot of screen time
here which is fine you know i mean the
story kind of revolves around a lot of
different characters not just him but
crusher creel is probably one of the
most underappreciated and most dangerous
characters in all of marvel comics right
like let let wolverine's adam you know
let his skin get blown off his bones and
then let crusher creole walk up to him
and just touch him and then absorb
adamantium and become adamantium
regardless you basically get alpha
flight showing up here right like you
get the forces of puck and uh and
titania you get uh absorbing man crusher
creel and so it's kind of kind of cool
to see here but at the end of the day
dario agar is not super concerned about
all this he is in so far as it's like
okay like this can kind of be a little
bit of a struggle for us but at the end
of the day he's not super freaking out
about it and the reason why is because
where you end up having you know all
these forces who were you know taking
out these these monsters and they're all
done in pretty fast the immortal hulk
rips himself out of one of the monsters
and when he does he unleashes all these
smaller monsters all over the entire
city of phoenix arizona and that's
exactly what dario agger was waiting for
that's exactly what he was hoping for
that by releasing all these monsters who
in turn are going to start ripping up
you know and killing people throughout
throughout phoenix then it's basically
the news which breaks in oh my god man
look at all the stuff that's going on
the immortal hulk has unleashed all
these monsters across the city of
phoenix this is his fault we don't know
exactly what's going on here but it's
definitely his fault right and people
will usually always believe the news if
it's what they want to hear and so
because of that it feeds right into what
it is that dario ag is shooting for and
then he basically says we have our final
person coming in to discredit the uh the
immortal hulk kind of going towards this
idea of getting rid of the immortal hulk
and replacing the hulk with basically an
agent of our of their own we end up
getting zem nu or zin zinmu or whatever
it is people call him the original hulk
he's not he's just like a criminal from
his own world who like was called a hulk
at one point right but like not really
that's like saying the original human
torch jim hammond is is like the human
torch not really it's johnny storm you
know that's that's really kind of what
it is but nonetheless it's interesting
we're gonna see like a giant furry guy
who's got hypnotic eyes and he's really
smart we're gonna see him fight you know
face off against the immortal hulk it's
cool i guess
what's going on guys this is rob and
it's been a little while since we
covered the immortal hulk it's been
quite some time and i figured why not
kind of get back into it a little bit
right especially because these most
recent stories have been really really
good the reality is alleywing's run kind
of lost me for a little bit i was like
it was kind of tough to stay to stay a
part of it and kind of stay into it but
he's recently gotten me back into it
right so uh what this does here is this
is basically the return of world breaker
hulk right so we get to see world
breaker hole come back which is awesome
but this basically picks up initially
with uh with mcgowan now for those of
you guys who don't really recall from a
lot of the videos that we've done
mcgowan was originally part of what was
called shadowbase which was led by
general fordian and the idea behind this
was that general fordham was a guy who
had a personal vendetta against the hulk
and shadowbase was designed to be this
kind of government sanctioned
organization that operated underground
and it was by all standards of
measurement a black ops group that would
essentially try to either capture or
kill the incredible hulk along with
anybody else who was mutated through
gamma radiation right so anybody
associated with the hulk family more or
less mcgowan ended up becoming the lead
scientist and then ultimately when
general fordian was destroyed mcgowan
ended up siding with the incredible hulk
and she's basically been an ally ever
since what we didn't really know about
mcgowan's history is kind of how she got
there and so this isn't really the most
important thing by any standard of
measurement but there is a moment that
happens in the comics later that is
important for this segment the the thing
about her character is she initially
started out working at uh well really
working in a research lab and was
ultimately given the boot due to drug
use now the argument she created was
that she did drugs in order to kind of
cope with her gender transition but
regardless she was fired for drug use
and ultimately hired by the kingpin and
that's when she started getting involved
in mgh now mgh is what we call mutant
growth hormone and that's been around
for a long long time in marvel comics
but it really rose to prominence in the
events of civil war right that's really
where it blew up where you had nitro who
basically detonated destroyed stanford
connecticut and uh and led to the deaths
of you know 600 some odd people and led
to the superhuman registration act ever
since then uh mutant growth hormone has
kind of gone back to being sort of a
background concept that's never really
seen or used all that often but it can
be repurposed for a variety of effects
right some people use it to get high
some people use it to kind of amplify
their existing abilities there's all
kinds of different applications for this
thing but what she also had was this
idea that because she herself was
transitioning and because the cost of
gene therapy and hormone therapy was so
incredibly expensive that she actually
ended up you know really as a direct
employee of kingpin approaching him and
her superiors and saying like we should
essentially create a black market for
like hormone therapy now this is highly
unethical and could probably get you
killed if you're if it's done by
somebody who doesn't know what they're
doing um but because of the fact that
you know she's she's already knee deep
right might as well get you know dig a
little deeper into into the the criminal
underbelly
uh ultimately kingpin and those guys
sanctioned it and so when she ended up
starting a lab for the purpose of really
kind of building up this this kind of
hormone therapy process she was suddenly
and really met by the arrival of
daredevil right now this is particularly
important because one of the things that
she says here is that that she says she
remembers thinking that she'd never seen
a superhero so close before and she
remembered thinking how much she always
wanted to meet daredevil that's
incredibly important and the reason why
is because what we do is we transition
to the present moment when you basically
have zem nuke now zymnu was given to us
originally is like the original hulk
kind of like the hulk before the
incredible hulk um we've got a video on
it so you guys are welcome to check it
out if you want to in fact i'll link the
whole uh incredible whole playlist down
in the description so you guys can kind
of go through all the hulk videos we
have i want to say and we might kind of
combine those all into like a full story
video once we're done with like uh once
algae wings finished i want to say that
the incredible hulk series is the
longest full story series we have at
something like 18 hours or something
stupid like that i can't remember off
top my head we have one that's over 12
hours right it's insane regardless
being here we don't really know a whole
lot about him right we knew a little bit
about him but not a whole lot about him
he's one of these mysterious characters
that's kind of appeared in and out
through al ewing's run uh but the
overall gist here is that while the
incredible hulk and zemnu are fighting
that you've got dario agar who's
watching the whole thing unfold now
dario agur is also called the minotaur
and he's basically the ceo of rocks on
oil the the important thing to
understand about him whenever you see
dario agar it means some some nefarious
stuff is going down you know so it's
like whenever you see mark zuckerberg
doing anything right the owner of
facebook right like no matter what he's
doing whether he's buying groceries or
shopping at ikea you can assume
something bad is about to happen right
there's some kind of criminal element
tied to it because mark zuckerberg sucks
but the important thing here is that
where you end up having the hulk kind of
overpowering uh zimnu and getting the
upper hand one of the things to
understand zim new in terms of his
physical strength he's not really on the
same level as the hulk but he does
possess a couple of abilities now one of
the things that kicks off here is that
there really is just you know seemingly
a giant monster that was kind of
unleashed in the city of of phoenix
arizona and then once you had zim new
show up there he kind of fought it off
the incredible hulk stepped in and the
incredible whole kind of keeps talking
about how like you know white hulk or
white white monster is always lying that
kind of a thing and and xenu kind of
reaches out to the uh to the staff uh i
guess the rock song network guys or news
network who are kind of recording the
whole thing and kind of like beseeching
them and almost puts off this air of
like he's just trying to do the right
thing but he's exceedingly helpless
there's nothing he can do to fight the
hulk and so it's very much a kind of
victim thing going on here and everybody
who's watching this is influenced by it
and they even go as far as to talk about
how they recognize them even the gamma
team is sent in right which is kind of
like it's really gamma flight it's kind
of like alpha flight's anti-hulk kind of
group organization whatever it is but
essentially you have like crusher creole
right the absorbing man the guy that can
turn himself into essentially any
material like he shows up as well and
one of the things he comments about is
how like he remembers zemnu from like
the from like a show when he was younger
right the magic planet he's like i
watched you when i was a little kid and
it's one of these things where people
kind of recognize them new as is
somebody from a long time ago almost
like this long forgotten hero that for
whatever reason people just don't really
remember anymore and him showing back up
here and facing off against the hulk is
pretty intriguing because it puts off
this error that it's like okay the
incredible hulk is essentially the bad
guy here right he's literally showing up
and he's kind of getting into a fight
and you know with what is basically
everybody's favorite cartoon or you know
childhood tv host and it's just bad pr
right bad publicity so when the hulk is
yanked back by by mcgowan she kind of
tells him like what are you doing right
like why are you attacking zimnu right
he had he had the the children show he's
uh he's he's trying to do the right
thing he's trying to to perform heroic
acts you're making yourself look like
the bad guy but all the hulk really
keeps saying here is like he has to be
destroyed he has to be smashed and one
of the things that's interesting about
this is when it comes to the immortal
hulk he's not necessarily childlike the
immortal hulk was perfectly capable of
having normal and rational conversation
but a lot of his his discussion here
really is as far as mcgowan is hearing
it it's just hulk is hulk that's all
he's really saying right hulk is hulk
that's all she really gets out of what
he's saying and then ultimately he's
like the hulk will go and then
ultimately the immortal hulk kind of
pops back up again right so effectively
it was savage hulk that was facing off
against uh zimnu instead of immortal
hulk but when immoral hull kind of
re-emerges then is a clear and concise
conversation and one of the things he
talks about is like this is a little
weird right like even for the savage
hulk and and all this stuff none of this
really makes any sense like there hasn't
been an instance where i faced a foe
that had that kind of effect on me
mentally right so like something else is
going on here and initially you have
mcgowan who's like okay well we should
have like doc sampson look into it but
the reality is that hulk doesn't like
doc sampson right he considers him to be
kind of nonsensical now doc sampson is
more or less the answer to the question
what if like a psychiatrist got the
powers of the hulk he's not on the same
level as the incredible hulk is nobody
ever is in marvel comics but uh with
regards to samson like hulk just always
struggled with him and never really took
him seriously for a variety of different
reasons right but regardless of the
circumstance he's kind of like no like
somebody impartial needs to be able to
look at this somebody confident so he
kind of tasked mcgowan with going
through this right and just kind of like
looking through all this we're kind of
going through all this different stuff
and and figuring out what's going on and
that's what mcgowan where she's talking
to the hulk and and she keeps talking
about things like like you know well the
the hulk and he just kind of keeps
saying over again you know hulk is hulk
hocus hulk then like immortal whole kind
of wonders to himself like who the hell
is hulk like he doesn't really know who
the hulk is almost as if he's kind of
lost himself and mcgowan starts to kind
of flash back and she says she starts to
remember the situation with daredevil as
it really was and it wasn't daredevil
who showed up it was zim new who showed
up right so zimni basically has the
ability to manipulate the minds of
others and that's what she starts to
pick up on right like she literally goes
directly to uh to to doc samson and
starts having this conversation with him
and it's like something's going on man
right like there's this instance right
there's a there's a tv show right
there's a tv show like did you ever
watch a tv show called the magic planet
when you were younger and the response
of samson is i'm pretty sure i did you
know i'm i don't really know with an
absolute but i'm pretty sure i did and
so she asked them like have you ever you
ever heard of something called the
mandela effect now the mandela effect is
a real world phenomenon right it
actually exists and it's basically where
collective groups of people remember a
thing that didn't actually happen the
most notable example and the reason why
it's called the mandela effect is
because there are huge portions of
society that will tell you if they were
alive at the time that they remembered
nelson mandela's funeral in the 1980s
but it never happened in the 1980s he
was in jail in the 1980s right like oh
well i don't know if he was really in
jail in the 1980s i'm a little fuzzy on
the timeline of mandela but he was
basically alive right he died more
recently but like he was he didn't die
but there are huge portions of people
who remember that either we're all
living in the matrix and the machines
are screwing with our minds or there's
basically just huge portions of people
remembering a thing that didn't actually
happen and so it's one of the things
where where mcgowan having this
conversation with uh with with samson
where he kind of confirms that he knows
what the mandela effect is what she says
is like the magic planet a show that
nobody remembers but nobody ever watched
it never existed right it's all
basically in our heads so essentially
zemu's like just putting this idea in
their heads that he's basically a good
guy here right like he's kind of putting
all that stuff inside their head and one
of the things that really begins to kind
of set the panic into everybody is when
mcgowan says that like this guy is
essentially targeting people in
particular basically those individuals
who are watching through tv or those
individuals in the immediate vicinity
that it's entirely possible that like
the incredible hulk's being impacted as
well now here's where things get a
little finicky when it comes to the
incredible hulk and telepathy by and
large over the years it's been
established that a person can take over
the mind of the incredible hulk but they
have to be an incredibly high level
telepath and and when i say take over
the mind i don't really mean like
planting memories that's kind of the big
difference between like xemnu and
somebody like professor x of the x-men
right i know jean grey has in the past
but in terms of being able to full-on
dominate the mind of the hulk and be
able to force him to do whatever it is
that you want him to do it doesn't
really work that way like whether it's
the incredible hulk's rage or his
healing factor even when you're dealing
with somebody like the purple man
marvel's kind of consistently
established over the years that
telepathy doesn't necessarily work on
the hulk the same way it does with
pretty much anybody else and that's one
of the reasons why it's kind of given to
us here that with zimnu kind of using
his abilities at least attempting to use
them on the incredible hulk it didn't
really work because the incredible
hulk's mind doesn't really work that way
that whenever xenu or even a telepath or
somebody like that is using their powers
on someone that they're basically using
them in their current form right how
they think and feel as a human being as
a normal adult but the incredible hulk
is more childlike than anything else and
so one of the things that kind of goes
on here is you basically have rick jones
right now rick jones had died at a
previous point in time and has
essentially been resurrected kind of
brought back to life by mcgowan when she
was part of shadow base and has
essentially kind of been part of the
hulk team ever since but it's one of
these things where like banner kind of
freaks out and smashes a mirror and then
just kind of starts talking about how
rational it is and how important it is
how the incredible hulk was trying to
get the upper hand but one of the things
that the whole tells us here is that you
know at least the persona stuck inside
the mind of banner is that in reality
like banner's under the control of of
like zimnu right his his mind is being
manipulated by zemnu and so that's kind
of the big difference here that's one of
the the big caveats is marvel often
times despite the fact that they're in
effect the same person marvel treats the
incredible hulk and bruce banner is two
distinctly different people in terms of
how their brains function their drive
their motivation and so it's almost as
if the immortal hulk is like a separate
physical manifestation of banner which
technically he has been in the past but
being able to telepathically control
banner is pretty easy in comparison to
being able to telepathically control the
hulk now what usually ends up happening
in a circumstance like that is if
somebody goes to telepathically control
banner and the hulk realizes it the hulk
will manifest right and and the hulk
will keep that from happening but
sometimes it doesn't really work that
way and that more or less seems to be
what was happening with xemnu is that
he's manipulating banner and kind of you
know banners operating under his control
the incredible hulk is seemingly the
only one who knows what it is that zimnu
is doing right and so and in his
frustration where he's kind of stuck in
you know on the inside which is
basically the inside of banner's mind
right this kind of internal persona
again kind of smashing against this
glass trying to trying to get out in
order to kind of retake control of
himself away from xenu then suddenly
like this this kind of voice comes out
of nowhere right and literally it tells
them like zem news rewritten banner
right that's not something that you can
punch you know it's stronger than you
are and where immortal hulk doesn't
really know who that is then like you
basically end up having world breaker
who appears and it's like but but
regardless of the power of xenu he's not
stronger than we are right like after
all i'm the strongest one there is which
is true right like like world breaker
hulk i would really say heart of the
monster hulk is the strongest version of
the hulk but world breaker hulk as he's
presented here is super strong right
it's astronomically strong and so it
gets kind of nuts because it's one of
these instances where you have mcgowan
and you have samson who kind of try to
explain to banner exactly what's
happening in the sense that he's more or
less being manipulated by xemnu now this
next little segment takes place over the
span of about a couple minutes right so
basically the span of the conversation
that mcgowan and and samson are having
or really mcgowan rick jones and samson
are having with uh with banner but you
basically kind of switch over to sort of
the internal mind of bruce himself at
least with regards to where all the hulk
personalities reside right and what you
have here is you literally have like
world breaker hulk you've got immortal
hulk who are just kind of traveling
through this this whole you know huge
different area and kind of understanding
what all is going on here and it's very
much like a journey right like it's a
great big huge journey and experience
and it's kind of interesting and kind of
wild the way that it unfolds but
ultimately the the effort taking place
inside of banner with regards to the
immortal hulk dealing with like world
breaker hulk the conversation they're
having this idea that it's not as simple
as just punching his way out that they
have to essentially get to the source of
banner's mind where xemnu is kind of
orchestrating his control that that is
it causes a little bit of turmoil with
regards to bruce but more in terms of a
mental state one of the things we also
know finding out too is that like joe
fixed hulk has just kind of been locked
away uh the zimnu managed to get a hold
of him so in essence it's almost kind of
like having a physical xemnu in the mind
of banner who kind of went through and
started locking away different versions
of the hulk but once they get to like
the source or the the main area that you
literally have banner as a little kid
who's just watching like magic planet
with zimnu and zimnu just kind of
manipulating him right like magic planet
they're singing the song and all that
kind of stuff and banner bought into it
you know subconsciously bought into it
because it was the childhood he always
wanted the childhood that he got was a
childhood that he they received from his
father brian banner who just beat him
all the time and beat his mom all the
time right like that's the childhood he
got but this is the escape this is the
way for him to basically get away and
the fact that there's so much trauma and
so much so much destruction and really
so much so many issues in banner's life
made it infinitely easier for for zimni
to get in and that's one of the reasons
why banner is such an intriguing
character and really relatable for a lot
of people i mean none of us can relate
to the idea of turning into a giant
green rage monster and like trashing a
town but we can relate to the idea of
like struggle and strife and going
through just like the thick of it in our
lives and how easy it is or how easy
that we've been manipulated by other
people due to their desire to
essentially you know achieve whatever it
is they're looking to achieve by preying
on our weaknesses and so at the end of
the day the important kind of takeaway
here is that banner really is just a
little kid inside his own head who just
wanted his childhood to be better he
wanted his life to be better instead
he's stuck with the life that he has and
so what you get is the immortal hulk who
kind of goes through and starts trashing
everything right like destroying quote
unquote the method by which zemnu is
controlling banner but in doing so once
it's all trashed he realizes there's
kind of an access point there right a
way by which he can crawl through and
then effectively get out right and
that's exactly what he does and it's
done in a pretty gruesome way like he
literally claws himself out of banner's
body and just like rips himself out and
so physically becomes like his own
manifestation which more or less is kind
of how that happens just not really in
such a gruesome way um under normal
circumstances i mean it's happened
before and under normal circumstances
he'll just revert back into banner is
really all that'll happen uh but the
important thing here is that he kind of
tells everybody look like yeah zimnu is
manipulating everybody and he was
controlling you and all that kind of
stuff that's why all you heard me saying
was hulk was hulk you could understand
what i was saying because xemnu was
screwing up your head so that you so i
would you wouldn't basically know what
was actually going on when it was me
trying to talk to you and so it's kind
of a crazy thing because then you have
rick jones kind of examining this corpse
which is really weird he's like man like
you know isn't it fascinating all the
permutations
it's kind of weird and kind of wonky but
at the end of the day hulk has
essentially come to the realization that
uh that that basically zimni is working
on behalf of roxanne right working on
behalf of dario agar and so ultimately
they take the fight directly directly to
rocks on oil now one of the things that
goes on here and one of the things that
kind of happened behind the scenes is
that zimni had kind of been going
through and more or less transforming
all the staff into like his own kind of
screwed up twisted looking henchmen
right but they all are more or less like
beholden to him the hulks go through and
kind of start trashing everything but
then you get to dario agar himself who's
having a conversation with zemnu and one
of the things that he's talking about is
like why is any of this happening right
like like i thought we had an agreement
right we had some kind of system set up
where basically we would destroy the
incredible hulk's public image the the
general public would turn against him
since they're in favor of him at the
moment and then we replace him with you
and you are essentially a person
masquerading as a hero in the world but
doing things to our whim right to what
it is that we want but ultimately zimni
doesn't really care right he's still
like going through and converting people
he had managed to kind of internalize
the conversion process and so literally
like when like he's because he's like
part machine like he just kind of bends
over and then like his whole back opens
up and then just pulls things in and
that's exactly what he did with dario
agar right like he literally just bends
over his back opens up and then it just
snatches up dario agar and then just
drags him down inside to convert him
into like one of these crazy looking
weird things it's pretty dark right not
gonna lie it's pretty crazy and and it's
cool but it's pretty crazy now
ultimately the incredible or really the
immortal hulk and they managed to smash
their way directly into dario's office
only to find that he's all just i mean
he's all messed up right i mean this
this guy is is he's also i mean just
look at that man like this this dude's
just a he's just a bloody pulp right
that's that's all this guy is even the
immortal holder is like my god man and
then that's when you basically end up
having xenu kind of pops up right and
initially kind of goes to control the
immortal hulk now one of the funny
things that's kind of revealed here is
that with zim new having his control
over banner oh having control of banner
is only having control of one facet of
the the the incredible hulk or the
immortal hulk because there's so many
different permutations of his
personality there not only that world
breaker hulk managed to kind of slice
off a section of banner's mind that was
basically kept safe and hidden away from
zimnuk and so the result of this is that
when xemnu goes to essentially take over
the hulk's mind and he does he
successfully manages to kind of to take
over him while at the same time talking
to everybody on tv using his hypnotic
powers to kind of manipulate everybody
on tv the the immortal hulk starts to
succumb and that's when you have rick
jones who shows up and is like that's
enough right like you're making a really
bad mistake if you keep doing this you
don't really know who you're dealing
with and at the end of the day like
ximena's like like whatever man it's
it's the immortal hulk right like your
little green light isn't gonna do
anything to me you're gonna feed him
gamma radiation like i mean that's cool
but like none of that really matters and
ultimately you know xenon's kind of like
i mean you can take his body if you want
but like i have his mind right so give
his body all the game of radiation you
want to i don't really care i've got
control of this guy's mind and that's
when rick jones reveals only what was
available right look deeper and look
who's coming up for you and that's when
you have like like literally world
breaker hulk who just looks directly at
zemo through the hulk's eye and is just
like like welcome to the magic planet no
no welcome to my planet and literally
world breaker hulk emerges and just bam
one shot zem new just just like that
right just like one shot's this guy and
that's it right that's it it's just it's
one shot right like literally the world
breaker hulk manifests one shots and
then and then goes back now this is now
here's here's the thing about this right
this is one of the reasons why this is
so cool under normal circumstances i
would look at this and i would say okay
you know whatever it's a thing that
exists you know and and it's cool to
kind of see him for a moment the reason
why this is so important is this is al
ewing effectively establishing that at
any point in time the immortal hulk can
and will pull out the world breaker
persona right that's going to happen
somewhere along the line world breaker
hulk will full-on come back he'll make a
return but but that's kind of the nature
of banner and that's kind of the nature
of the hulk is that it's like drawing
index cards right and sometimes it's
done arbitrarily sometimes it's random
so like the immortal hulk will turn into
savage hulk he'll turn into like joe fix
it who will turn back to savage hulk and
then into banner sometimes just done
indiscriminately otherwise other times
depending on the circumstances a
particular hulk will emerge because
banner wants them to and that kind of
feels like one of the directions that al
ewing is moving in where banner can in a
lot of ways control which version of the
hulk comes out it's kind of nuts and
it's a really really cool concept to
bring in to the incredible hulk mythos
because outside of professor hulk there
wasn't really very many instances where
that actually happened but the big
takeaway from this and one of the big
moments from this is that where the
immortal hulk's just like done right
walks away kind of goes back to his base
calls it a day that that rick jones
stays behind and and rick kind of starts
talking to dario agar right this this
giant corpse thing and says like you
know the crass little billionaire who
thought the four winds would forever bow
to him so you summoned them and in they
have blown uh but you couldn't control
zinmo so you certainly can't control me
not now and not ever and so what he
basically reveals is that in this in
this circumstance like this is this rick
jones that we see here is not actually
rick jones right instead like it's
basically somebody impersonating rick
jones and the person who's impersonating
rick jones is actually the leader
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking back up with the immortal
hulk we're getting caught back up again
i know we were kind of dropping off from
this so this is one of those weird
stories not really even weird well it is
weird right it's immortal hulk like i
don't you know alleyways and mortal hulk
is so wonky but it's so cool at the same
time like it's so different from any
other incredible hulk story that i think
i've ever read in my entire life but
this one kind of picks up seemingly in
the middle of everything and what you
basically have here is this instance
where something popped off and the
incredible hulk basically let off or
immortal hulk basically let off like
this uh this gamma explosion right
basically detonated like a gamma bomb
and the result is that no one really
knows how to handle it right all you
really have is rick jones and you've got
the incredible hulk and so it's kind of
like okay like what's happening here now
you do have jackie for those of you guys
who don't remember jackie's basically
the friend of the the immortal hulk she
was a member of the press and still kind
of is but she's the one who's kind of
become an ally of the hulk family which
was kind of a way for al ewing to have
this situation or to write these kind of
stories where you would at least have
some story out there that wouldn't shine
a negative light on the incredible hulk
or on the immortal hulk and kind of just
like show him as he is as opposed to how
the public generally perceives him
whether or not it's popular among the
public is something that alguin's never
particularly explored but it's kind of
cool to see the important thing is that
because of all this gamma flight
ultimately responds right now gamma
flight is by all standards of
measurement basically an anti-hulk force
right i mean gamma flight has had
different histories and different
rosters over the course of marvel comics
but in its current form like it has been
over the course the entire immortal hulk
run it's an anti-hulk force and that's
why you have guys here who are some
pretty heavy hitters right you've got
titania who we've talked about in the
original secret war story from 1984
because she's been around for so long
he's basically just a super strong chick
you've got the absorbing man crusher
creel who was one of the most criminally
underrated characters in all of marvel
comics really until immortal hulk that's
the reason why this story is so awesome
for crusher creel it is an it is a story
that focuses on the hulk right this is
al ewing's hulk run but he's done so
much work to expand on crusher creel
that it's amazing and then you have puck
i don't i never really understood why
puck was on this team
but you have puck right just this really
short guy but the the result here is
that of course they basically kind of go
after the incredible hulk with the
intention of taking him out now the
entirety like like jackie yourself is
like trying to keep this from happening
but at the end of the day gamma flight's
main their their main prerogative right
their number one goal here is to
incapacitate the hulk to essentially
take the hulk out and so in this
conflict he basically rips off the arm
of crusher creel which he's never gonna
lose his arm forever right all he has to
do is just bond himself to metal and
then his arm will regrow or any
substance out there it doesn't really
matter titania gets pissed off because
her and crusher creel have been banging
for a long time and so ultimately she
goes after the immortal hulk now while
all that's happening jackie notices
something jackie notices that rick jones
is smiling the whole time now one of the
things that we learned in the last video
is that this is not actually rick jones
right rick jones is possessed by the
leader by by samuel stearns one of the
main enemies of the immortal hulk but we
don't really know how that happened
right we don't really know exactly how
it is that the leader managed to take
control and basically possess rick jones
but then you also have crusher creole
who comes with this this like amazing
idea right he's like okay he's like
think about it at home slice he's like
you're the absorbing man you can absorb
and turn into essentially any material
out there the one thing we've never seen
him absorb and turn into is adamantium i
guarantee we will at some point along
the line just because of all the work
that's being done here but he's like i
can absorb and turn into anything and
then he realizes i can also do it with
gamma radiation right if it exists i can
turn into it and so literally he just
absorbs all this gamma radiation like
he's done before and then just emerges
as like this giant huge mountain of a
man now from there we switch back over
to shadow base where the main hulk
family is kind of residing right doc
sampson and and so on and then suddenly
you have like basically this guy del fry
who's currently sitting in a in a giant
tank now del fry was a character we were
previously introduced to in the early
launch of of immortal hulk right and
it's been a little while so kind of a
refresher here del fry was basically a
kid who or really a high school kid who
was playing football and his dad
essentially injected him with gamma
radiation under the idea that it would
basically enhance him a little bit but
it would prevent any of the major
injuries that he would likely sustain
while playing football right so ligament
tears broken bones different things like
that and it would give him the best
opportunity for success the problem with
this is that he died
[Laughter]
like immediately right he died like
immediately when that happened and so
what ends up going on here is that the
the immortal hulk and his and his allies
have essentially stumbled across this
kind of gamma radiation signal and then
came across a grave of del fry dug him
up and they've just kind of been i guess
experimenting on him to a degree or
trying to get a better understanding of
him since they don't really know
anything about him but by and large he's
just kind of been in the background well
suddenly he pops up right he just
emerges like literally emerges from his
tank disintegrates one of the one of the
scientists and then immediately goes
after the whole group now one of the
things that we find out here kind of a
little bit of a flashback is that when
you do get this origin where he was
exposed to gamma radiation by his dad
and then ultimately died that the
reality is the green door opened behind
him and instead of the one below all
passing through it was the leader so
somehow or another the leader managed to
find his way to the realm of the one
below all we'll actually find out how
that happened but basically del fry has
been reliving the same moment over and
over and over again uh that was
essentially his death and so the leader
kind of steps in and then basically
possesses del fry and that's how del fry
is coming to life at the moment right
now the leader is literally going
through and just attacking him right now
initially like leonard sampson like doc
sampson doesn't know who this is right
he's just he just thinks it's like you
know del fry who's just kind of popped
up and maybe like del fry's been
listening quote unquote that he wasn't
actually dead right he was really alive
the whole time and just kind of in a
form of stasis but then as soon as as
leader starts talking about things like
remember how i made you who you are
right because he's the one that more or
less made doc sampson that the result is
that doc sampson realizes it's the
leader and that's when he kind of starts
to panic a little bit of course he ends
up going after him but the reality is
there's not much doc samson can do in
the face of the leader especially with
with a guy like this because he
immediately sees samson and says okay
now it's time to play the game and then
basically snatches him and takes him to
the below place right to the realm of
the one below all with one below wall
just kind of resides there and for the
most part it's a little bit of of you
know some exposition but not a whole lot
here right instead of it's more of just
kind of playing mind games and just
basically saying that like you know the
leader has managed to reach the realm of
the one below all by passing through a
green door and and again not a whole lot
there there's not much in the way of
explanation but one of the things that
he does kind of hit on here is he enter
he introduces this idea of what's called
the red door now again this is kind of a
big deal and the reason why is because
if you guys recall what's been going on
with the immortal hulk so far that
whenever a person who's exposed to gamma
radiation dies that they basically end
up being taken to the realm of the one
below all there's this kind of
connection that exists between the one
below all and grammar radiation itself
and it all kind of goes back to the
formation of the hulk but the long and
short of this is that when a person with
gamma radiation dies quote unquote they
go to the realm of the one below all and
a green door opens which is basically a
means for them to pass into the real
world this is why being possessed by the
one below all is such a big deal because
if a person like doc sampson were to
arrive there and then become possessed
by the one below all they could pass
through the green door and enter into
the real world and then have this
virtually non-omnipotent level of power
uh the result of this is that with the
door being changed to red what it
essentially means is that if doc sampson
were to pass through it what it
basically means is that either doc
samson cannot pass through the red door
meaning he can't come back and that
seems to be the case because you know
the way that that samuel stearns
describes it is he says red for danger
red for stop uh from this side at least
so basically mean that like no magic can
return him to life that he's basically
stuck here or the possibility exists
that if he does pass through the green
door he would actually die and go on to
the realm of mistress death that more or
less seems to be the case we're not
given an actual explanation here all we
really have to go by is what you know
the leader says which is the red door
means you can't pass through it right
it'd be like walking into a wall you
can't go back to the realm of the living
you're essentially stuck here the
results of this is that the incredible
whole kind of going back to immortal
hulk facing off against absorbing man
it's a cool bit of a conflict here it's
it's interesting right i mean you see
the immortal hulk literally fighting a
giant you know form of like gamma energy
but one of the things that happens is
that with the leader in possession of
both rick jones as well as del fry when
one of them is talking the other one is
as well so you literally have rick jones
who's just kind of talking to somebody
who's not there because of the fact that
del fry is talking to like the people
who are there right in the in the gamma
base and so ultimately charlene who
again is kind of the science like the
head science group of the the hulk
family ends up kind of initiating this
teleportation right there's this kind of
thing where she basically ends up
ripping del fry away uh literally like
translocating him at the same time you
end up having doc sampson who basically
cracks uh the one below all version of
the leader over the head and so what it
does is it creates a kind of energy
effect right where basically the leader
as he's in possession of del fry as well
as him being in possession of rick jones
kind of reflects this pain right this
anguish because if you consider these
guys to be like facsimiles then the
leader as he exists in the realm of the
one below all right now is like the
leader prime right so it's like if if
the leader duplicated himself and then
you attacked the main leader the other
duplicates would feel the same pain
right i don't know if that really makes
any sense but that's basically what's
happening here and so ultimately they're
kind of teleported away and then one of
the things that kind of goes on and this
is all really kind of the plan of the
leader the idea of counting on what
gamma flight would do with the
incredible hulk being pushed continually
over and over again and the rest of the
team being distracted nobody really
being there in order to talk him down
jackie tries to but the leader knows
gamma flight and he knows the history of
the immortal hulk well enough to know
the gamma flight is not going to listen
right their their main goal here is to
destroy or at least to to uh kill
immortal hulk which is really just kind
of incapacitating them which they're
aware of and that nobody's really gonna
bring this to uh to a peaceful end and
that's exactly what happens gamma flight
basically kills the immortal hulk and
then the immortal hulk is teleported to
the realm of the one below all when the
green door opens and so again that's
kind of his his bit of a situation here
now what you also have is this really
interesting concept where you have this
being that's effectively chained up
right like literally chained up in this
giant uh steel container and essentially
held there and kind of talked about how
like they can feel everything that's
going on right they can they can feel
everything taking place it's kind of
called the inner world which is
basically the mindscape of bruce banner
right inside the mind of banner himself
and that this individual was essentially
captured by the leader and chained up in
this location and basically kept there
right indicating whoever this person is
their power is far beyond anything the
leader can really can really pull off
here right and so what you end up
getting is kind of the leader in the
form of world breaker hulk which is
pretty nuts and by all standards of
measurement we'd have to assume he
contains the same level of power as the
world breaker hulk does right otherwise
why give us this form of the leader why
would alewing make him look this way and
it's one of these things where again the
immortal hulk is kind of experiencing
these dreams or this kind of memory
series in his mind and speaking outright
as he's experiencing that right but
ultimately he's taken to where joe fix
it and bruce banner are chained up
inside of banner's own mindscape now
this is kind of the crazy thing and this
is an important thing to understand here
when it comes to the immortal hulk i
know it seems a little strange but
what's basically going on here is a
foreign entity has infiltrated the mind
of bruce spanner and then in turn is
controlling it that's not uncommon for
the incredible hulk mythos not insofar
as some foreign entity taking over the
mind of banner but in the sense of one
of the personalities in banner's mind
essentially taking over all the others
right we've seen that happen in
different forms we've even seen these
personalities merge into a singular
personality which is professor hulk
right we've seen what happens when these
kind of things calm down right when
these kind of things take place in in
the incredible hulk's mind and so
basically joe fix it is chained up here
bruce banner is chained up here and now
the immortal hulk is chained up here and
that the whole idea here of the of the
leader is to take bruce banner and send
him through the green door and into the
realm of the one below all why it is
he's doing this again we don't fully
understand we'll find out here uh here
in a minute or two but in that moment
bruce banner cries out for help right
cries off for help from anybody who will
listen and then in comes this guy who
was chained up who's basically revealed
to be the devil hulk now here's the
crazy thing about this the devil hulk is
one of the more interesting concepts or
interesting versions of the incredible
hulk marvel comics but you don't really
see a whole lot about it the way it's
kind of given to us here because the
mindscape is one of these things where
the personifications of the different
versions of the hulk are directly tied
to the emotional state of the immortal
hulk and really just the experiences of
banner over the course of his life that
the devil hulk in a lot of ways
represents all the torment and suffering
he's experienced over the course of his
life kind of manifested um in a lot of
ways it's almost given to us as this
idea that the devil hulk was the first
version of the hulk to manifest in the
mind of banner when he was being abused
by his father and then once he actually
was exposed to gamma radiation because
of the gamma bomb the incredible hulk
manifested then you've got things like
joe fix it and so on and so forth but
the devil hulk is the most emotionally
powerful of all the all the versions of
the hulk that exist out there and so
that's why you essentially see this kind
of fight breaking down between uh what
is basically world breaker hulk uh who's
more or less possessed by the leader and
then devil hulk and devil hulk literally
crushes world breaker hulk i mean just
pummels this guy absolutely pummels this
guy it's not even close right because
it's just sheer raw emotion here and
that's one of the big differences is
that with world breaker hulk it was
technically the incredible hulk at his
angriest but he had also achieved this
just kind of pure form right in the
sense that it seemed like the incredible
hulk at his angriest but also his most
calm at the same time and i know it
sounds like an oxymoron to say that but
that's why like when you go and you read
you know world breaker or world war hulk
by by uh greg pack that the the world
breaker hulk is basically like i
wouldn't really say like peaceful but
he's methodical like it's just one of
these things where it's like okay like
i'm so pissed off that i'm rational now
and that's like a whole nother level of
being angry but uh but nonetheless you
know it's one of these one of these kind
of crazy things here where you basically
switch over to the leader and we kind of
find out how all this popped off with
him now the idea behind this is that
those individuals who are able to access
the realm of the one below all through
gamma radiation that it is most usually
only allowed by those individuals who
are of pure gamma radiation right
meaning that they are rooted in the
incredible hulk and the gamma radiation
he contains the leader is a little bit
different here the way is explained here
is that the leader essentially
synthesized a means by which to enter to
basically create a green door and enter
the realm of the one below all but when
he got there he met brian banner and one
of the things about this is that brian
banner kind of depicts this idea that
when he was doing all these crappy
things and when he was kind of kind of
tormenting the the immortal hulk you
know during at the beginning of ali
ewing's immortal hulk run that is
because he was possessed by the one
below all which we know we know that was
the case right we know that to be the
case but one of the things that that
leader doesn't really understand is what
is it that the the one below all is
looking for right and how is it that a
person can kind of reach into the real
world and then manipulate the immortal
hulk from here because the leader wants
to just destroy he's always wanted to
destroy the immortal right that's kind
of his main goal and that was all that's
you know as basic as that ideology is
here the way he goes about it is genius
given the fact that the way that brian
banner explains it the one below all
needs a physical body that the one below
all doesn't actually have a physical
form itself instead it's just raw desire
and exceedingly terrible desires right
but it's just more or less raw emotion
what it needs to do is bond itself to a
host and then in turn use that host to
enter into the real world that the one
below all in its current form cannot
pass through a green door and then just
enter into the real world and then just
take on some kind of a physical form and
conquer all of the multiverse it doesn't
work that way and so that's when when
leader realizes i can get behind this
and so literally leader basically tricks
brian banner and then completely absorbs
him and so the idea is that in some of
these instances when ryan banner
appeared in the immortal hulk run that
it was actually the leader in possession
or appearing to look like brian banner
not only that now that he's consumed
brian he has what's called the mark of
the one below all and then in turn he
reveals his goal is to actually achieve
a means by which the one below all can
enter into the real world and then
conquer all of reality kind of
hearkening back to the story that we did
with the immortal hulk was on a cosmic
level and basically destroyed the
entirety of the multiverse when the
multiverse is reborn in its ninth
iteration um that basically leader
realizes the only way for the one below
all to achieve its full totality of
power is if it is in possession of the
immortal hulk and that's the whole goal
behind this that that the leader wants
to help the one below all succeed the
only way to do that is to mess with uh
to basically end up snatching the
immortal hulk and banner bring them to
the realm of the one below all and then
allow the one below all to essentially
possess them and then go into the
multiverse and destroy everything in
existence right he literally wants to
help the end of creation and so again
kind of jumping back to the current
moment that when you have the devil hulk
just absolutely pummeling immortal hulk
the big fear that kind of pops up here
is you end up having the arrival of the
leader manifest into the form of brian
banner now it's not one of these things
where it terrifies the devil hulk to the
point where he starts crying or anything
like that but the devil hulk was born
out of the abuse of brian banner and
really in a lot of ways it's part and
parcel to brian banner and so that's
when he's kind of like like where do you
think like all this rage and everything
that you are you are me right you you
are my rage incarnate right you're my
wrath you're you're a reflection of me
and as abusive as i was where do you
think you got your personality from how
do you think you became the person that
you are you know where is the lie in all
of this right if you tell me that that
i'm not you you know or you're not me
and that i'm lying to you where's the
lie look at yourself look at me right
look at the abuse that i put you through
and look at who you are look at the
things that you've done right you are a
reflection of me and bruce banner kind
of refuses to accept that and then
immediately goes after the leader now of
course this leads to the immortal hulk
kind of watching all this unfold and
desiring to kind of end the conflict
right and it's not because of the fact
that he doesn't want want to fight for
the sake of wanting a fight it's because
of the fact that in seeing brian
banner's persona the immortal hulk or
really kind of i guess is really just
the baseline incredible hulk at this
point is not the sharpest tool in the
shed and so ultimately he kind of comes
to this idea that all i want my father
to do is tell me that he loves me right
that's the only thing that i want i just
want my dad to say like like i love you
i love you i care about you and in doing
this he stops the devil hulk from
destroying the leader who he's kind of
seeing as brian banner and because of
the fact that brian banner is absorb has
been absorbed by the leader so to
destroy the leader is to destroy brian
banner and to destroy brian banner is to
ruin the immortal hulk's chances of
getting his father's approval and his
father's love and so in that moment it
basically allows the leader to kill the
devil hulk right to basically decapitate
him and that was their one shot at
success there was their one shot to come
out on top there's no real conceivable
way for them to win anymore and so what
you have is the leader who snatches up
bruce banner takes him through the green
door and disappears and all you're left
with is basically the hulk and joe fix
it and joe fix it is pissed right joe
fixit is mad as hell because he's kind
of like okay this is a problem right
like this is a major issue like why
would you do this right why why would
you do any of this like you've literally
just destroyed our chances of saving
banner and quite possibly doomed all of
creation right and so from there you end
up jumping to the to the the base of
gamma flight right to really the alpha
flight space station but you end up
jumping to the to the gamma flight team
and you have of course walter also known
as sasquatch who's still dead after
being shot in the head who's just kind
of in a in a kind of not really i guess
a coffin and that's what you want to
call it but basically he ends up popping
back to life right now you also have
jackie who kind of introduces this idea
that where gamma flight's operating
under the guys that like the immortal
hulk just for whatever reason went crazy
and destroyed an entire town in a gamma
explosion her response is it doesn't
actually seem to be that way right that
that the immortal hulk was pissed off
like exceedingly mad for a second or two
and then calmed down due to whatever it
was that was going on and then rick
jones showed up and rick jones touched
him and then something happened and then
like literally the immortal hulk just
snapped and just let off this massive
explosion and so looking at the facts
because of the fact that you know she's
a journalist her job will ideally her
job is to look at the fact that she kind
of looks at this and says from what i
can tell rick jones was the one who
caused this right and that's when you
basically have leonard sampson who is
kind of the new sasquatch took over the
body of walter and then just kind of
popped back up again and says yeah
basically it was rick jones that caused
all of this how he caused it and why he
caused it i don't fully know but we know
that he did and so during this time of
course while the the immortal hulk is
kind of held kind of put in a holding
facility because again he's more or less
immortal right in the sense that he'll
always heal and the the injury he
sustained it didn't really kill him his
body would more or less heal and come
back that he's met by the arrival of
henry peter geyrick now henry peter
guyer is old school this guy is og og
technically he is the head of the alpha
flight program right now but for those
of you guys who who aren't really
familiar with this history this is the
guy who helped the spearhead project
wide awake the sentinels against the
x-men and all that kind of stuff that
was henry peter guyer right this guy is
og right i mean this guy has worked
against the superhero community in
almost every conceivable way since he's
been introduced in marvel comics right
if you're a superhero team that exists
out there there's a good chance you've
had a running with henry peter geyrick
and so basically he's kind of held here
now one of the the reason why i include
this little tidbit here because normally
i would have skipped over it but the
reason why we included this little
tidbit here is you have this moment
where again like everything that henry
peter guyrick says kind of echoes so to
speak through the mindscape of of of
banner so essentially joefixit hears
everything that henry peter guyrick is
saying and one of the things that
geyrick says is that you can't escape
your bonds right if you decide to turn
back into banner and shrink down into
your current form your your human form
which of course we know he can't do that
the bonds will shrink with him and
that's when it hits on joe fix it oh i
know exactly what to do right like
apparently this guy hasn't kept up on
things we don't just shrink down back
into our human forms anymore our human
forms bust out of our physical forms
right just literally emerge from which
leads me to believe there have to be
like these these immortal hulk corpses
all over the world we're banner where
instead of like the immortal hulk quote
unquote shrinking back down into banner
then instead banner just like busts out
of his immortal hook form and that's how
banner returns to normal but that's what
it hits on on joe fix and who's kind of
like like okay we can escape this so
literally he busts out of the form of
the immortal hulk right which is how he
returns to his normal self and then
takes out henry peter garrick and the
two guards grabs a gun and then
basically starts to leave now of course
he runs into samson and the rest of
gamma flight and uh and samson realizes
okay this is joe fix it right this is
one of bruce banner's alternate
personalities that's why he looks like
banner because it's just one of his
other personalities that exists but like
joe fix is not as crazy as he used to be
right which for any of you guys who know
the history of joe fixed in marvel
comics this guy used to be intense right
like joe fix it i still say joe fix it
personality wise is the best version of
the hulk who's out there i loved joe fix
it he was so cool and he was so fun he
was literally like literally the guy ran
vegas at one point so it was just kind
of like damn like this is awesome his
personality is amazing in any event uh
where where samson's kind of like yeah
you know joe fix it he's a he's a lot
more reasonable than he used to be he's
like yeah that's me all over reasonable
and then fires a gun into the window of
the space station right
it gets sucked out into space now the
protocols immediately kick in right
which just starts shutting down you know
shuts down this access hole but like
literally joe fix it's ripped into the
vacuum of space now you would normally
expect that to kill him it doesn't
because again like he turns back into
the immortal hulk and it's a genius
strategy there right emerge from the
immortal hulk into your human form in
order to escape your confines jump into
space the danger of the situation will
just force them to turn back into the
immortal hulk and that's exactly what
happened ultimately he ends up landing
on the coney island channel the problem
is that when he gets there he's
immediately met by the thing ben grimm
which you guys had to know it was only a
matter of time before we saw this
conflict unfold
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking back up again with the
immortal hulk and this more or less gets
us caught up right with the exception of
a couple issues or so like maybe one or
two issues but basically we're caught up
with the most recent run right and so uh
what this does it kind of comes out of
what we had with the last story arc
right where things were kind of popping
off and and things were a bit crazy but
ultimately the immortal hulk and this is
something that i actually didn't realize
at first and i'm glad you guys said
something um it turns out that the
immortal hulk or i guess devil hulk more
or less has just kind of been defeated
and almost seemingly temporarily
destroyed instead what you have in the
body of the immortal hulk is kind of a
combination it's not really even
immortal hulk per se it's really just
kind of like savage hulk and joe fix it
hulk right which is actually kind of a
cool way to sort of shuffle things
around but one of the things that had
happened is that hulk had essentially
escaped uh the clutches of the
government in the form of henry geyer
and we'll talk more about him here in a
second and then crash landed in coney
island only to be met by the arrival of
ben grimm now there's a couple reasons
why this happens one because it's just
alduing paying homage to ben graham and
the incredible hulk fighting it's one of
those age-old battles right it's like
the incredible hulk versus thor or
something like that it's not really a
hulk run unless somewhere along the line
the thing and the incredible hulk get
into a fight and then have some kind of
a rematch right it's really the only way
you can really call it an incredible
hulk story but one of the funny things
about this is that you have the you have
ben graham who's kind of talking to the
fantastic four as he's engaged in this
fight and talking about how much weaker
the incredible hulk is now than he has
been in the past now a lot of that's
because so much gamma radiation has kind
of been siphoned off of him but the
important thing to know here is that
with the incredible hulk hearing it he
in turn gets pretty pissed off right
considering the fact or really being
told that he's consistently weak until
ultimately he actually ends up stopping
the fight right and just kind of crying
throughout the in an entire ordeal now
ultimately he turns back into joe fix it
and that's kind of the crazy thing about
this is one of the things to remember
when it comes to the savage hulk is he's
very much a child in terms of how he
works and how he functions he's very
childlike in that way and so you know he
kind of reacts the way a child would in
the sense of like getting overly angry
not really knowing how to process their
emotions but at the same time also kind
of lashing out or experiencing emotions
they simply just don't know what to
handle and so with joe fix it kind of
being the one to sort of take back on
the forum there's a bit of a
conversation that goes on here in
reality it's not overly important it is
kind of cool to see joe fix it and and
ben grimm talking but unless you're a
big fan of either it's not really
relevant here instead it's just one of
these things where joe fix it kind of
explains what's going on with regards to
the immortal hulk and and all that kind
of good stuff and ben graham talks about
having kind of like a moment of faith or
something along those lines and that's
more or less it the big takeaway from
this this little bit of a conversation
here isn't really the conversation
itself but it's back at shadow based
site g and we'll talk about again where
that is here in a second but in effect
the one below all manages to kind of
send a facsimile of himself into the
main marvel universe now i do want to
specify it's not the one below all in
its full totality invading the main
marvel universe if that were to happen
based on what little itty bitty
information we have there'd be almost
nobody who could stop him but there is a
facsimile of the one below all here
which is in its own right exceedingly
powerful now one of the things that also
happened in the immortal hulk stories if
you guys recall is that dr lankowski the
former sasquatch had basically been
killed right and while that in and of
itself was not the most significant
thing ever because the reality was he
just hadn't been a significant character
for a long long time when doc sampson's
physical body was seemingly destroyed
when he was basically killed he was
resurrected in the body of sasquatch now
again sasquatch kind of has a bit of
gamma radiation history with the
incredible hulk it's not really a whole
lot to run home about but it is a little
a couple cool things you were there but
that's why you don't really see
lankowski in the traditional sense you
end up seeing doc sampson instead but
one of the other things that goes on
here is henry peter geyrick now henry
peter guyer because we talked about in
the last video this guy has been around
for a long long time he was originally a
chris claremont character in marvel
comics but the idea is that he really
made his claim to fame and it kind of
made his bones in marvel comics is like
the anti-mutant guy right like him and
and dr valerie cooper who contessa for
the most part seems to be based off of
in the marvel cinematic universe that he
was basically a guy who was staunchly
anti-mutant and led a litany of
different organizations that were
designed for the purpose of promoting
project wide awake try to contain and
control the mutant threat the result of
this is that over the years in marvel
his role has kind of expanded to become
a threat to not just the mutant
community but really to the larger
superhuman community and that really
kind of came out of his involvement with
the commission on superhuman activities
it was a way for marvel to kind of segue
his character into something beyond
simply being an x-men villain who exists
out there the big thing about this is
that gyrik is used to getting his way
and he's used to running a pretty tight
ship and a pretty harsh ship and that's
why when he kind of starts talking to
gamma flight and really starts talking
about like threatening them and and this
whole idea of like um you know crusher
creel for example who's in the hospital
he sends a text message and now there's
like warrants out in all 50 states for
crusher creel different things along
those lines really using more of fear
tactics to get his job done as opposed
to working with the team or kind of
managing the team that works under him
it ultimately leads to gamma flight
basically bailing out now that in and of
itself is not a huge thing uh but that
basically allows for the the launch or
the bringing in of the ufos and we'll
talk about them here in a second instead
what we do here is we switch over for a
second and you basically pick up with
jackie now one of the things that's kind
of gone on here with jackie's character
and it's a little wonky is she's
basically been picking up not really an
infection from gamma radiation but she
basically has been exposed to gamma
radiation multiple times and the result
of this is that she's actually able to
start seeing the world through gamma
irradiated eyes now one of the big
things that al ewing doesn't really hit
at here is whether or not she's wholly
unique it seems like she is because
we've never really seen exactly how the
incredible hulk sees the world right
like we've never really seen a comic
book panel where it shows us the world
through the incredible hulk's eyes and
if they have it's simply just the way
you would normally see the world instead
because there's so much gamma radiation
out there that you have all these kind
of gamma irradiated ghosts and we're not
really told where they come from they
really just kind of seem to be you know
forces out there that feed on gamma
radiation or in some form or fashion are
inextricably tied into gamma radiation
potentially even victims of the hulk due
to his his you know assaults and attacks
and campaigns and so on and so forth
based on gamma radiation that's kind of
a little bit of an important thing that
i want to talk about here because al
ewing looks like he's moving jackie in a
more interesting direction as opposed to
simply just kind of like this this will
really uh former member of the of the
press and she recently quit and uh just
kind of being out there and just sort of
recording and blogging and documenting
the the incredible hulk's experiences
one of the things that i want to talk
about here also is kind of switch over
to the one below all and the reason for
this is because if you guys recall the
leader uh basically had been
masquerading as rick jones all this time
so from the time that rick jones first
showed up in this immortal hulk story up
until now it's been the leader the
entire time that what had happened was a
leader had basically found a way to
enter into the one below all into the
the realm of the one below all and then
basically come back in the body of rick
jones in order to get closer to the
incredible hulk and then find a way to
bring him down with everything that had
happened in the last story arc bruce
banner had more or less been taken to
the realm of the one below all and he's
kind of been hooked up to this really
sadistic looking machine so the one
below all can kind of siphon the gamma
radiation off of him the issue is it
doesn't really seem to be working as
intended that brian banner the father of
bruce when he was in the realm of the
one below all was able to get it to work
somehow and when the leader had taken
over the the really kind of absorbed the
mind of brian banner and his essence
into himself all the knowledge came
along with him but nonetheless the
efforts of ryan banner simply don't seem
to work here and he doesn't quite grasp
why it is that it's not working the way
that it's supposed to and that's when
the spirit of brian banner kind of pops
up and says remember like it needs a
host personality it needs someone to
bond itself to in order to be able to
utilize this machine initially it was
bonded to me but now it's not bonded to
anybody and that's why it doesn't work
so it's going to bond to you and the
leader starts freaking out
the leader starts begging for his life
right not knowing what he was getting
himself into the whole time bruce banner
is just having these crazy visions with
these weird things hooked up to his eyes
and all kinds of stuff hooked up to this
weird tentacle machine but nonetheless
like it's it's kind of nuts right
because ultimately the one below all
takes over the body of the leader and
that's what kind of allows the one below
all to leave its realm or at least to
send a facsimile of itself from its
realm into the main marvel universe but
again you know kind of jumping back to
to the idea that the gamma flight had
more or less been removed from the
equation and then now you've got uh
you've got you know ufos in their place
the ufos are not incredibly important
the only thing you really need to know
here is that the ufos were originally a
handful of villains who wanted to
essentially duplicate the powers of the
fantastic fort so much so that they
actually recreated the whole incident
that led to the fantastic four getting
their powers uh but the other part of
this is that with uh with joe fix it
kind of making his way following his
encounter with ben grimm that one of the
things that he realizes is that you know
is really more or less like the hustler
version of bruce banner right i mean the
hustler persona of bruce that he has to
make some money and so one of the things
that he does here is he actually
pickpockets a guy and then he in turn he
uses his uh his credit card to basically
buy a whole bunch of jewelry and then
pawns it now this is this actually
happens i don't know how many of you
guys are familiar with the world most
people out there are like yeah i mean
this definitely happens it does right it
happens quite frequently and that's why
when they say like if you're gonna go to
a foreign city even or go to a foreign
country uh take like a fanny pack or put
your wallet in a place where one you can
constantly feel it on you you can always
touch your pocket to check and make sure
it's there every minute or two and then
also put it in something like a fanny
pack or something like that to where it
would be difficult for a person to
access it without you knowing because
what what's going on here with joe fix
it is he snatches this guy's credit card
up and then makes a whole bunch of
fraudulent purchases so by the time this
guy knows that his credit card's been
stolen and reports it basically joe fix
it makes his money he spent like 1900 on
all this jewelry 1900 doesn't belong to
him and then he in turn pawns it for
something like 650 and so it's a pretty
raw deal for for you know i mean that's
the nature of pawn shops right they're
designed to rip you off but it's 650
bucks that's entirely entirely his money
right and so again that's kind of how he
how he hustles in that way but it's kind
of going to be a kind of a funny thing
because for the most part joe fix it is
not going to be a main focal point of
this story instead you basically pick up
with uh with doc samson in the body of
sasquatch along with puck the member of
alpha flight uh really a long time
friend of wolverines to be honest who
all friend enemy frenemy more or less
and then shaman now the whole reason why
they're here is to locate the body of uh
of doc sampson and then essentially
transfer his essence from the body of
sasquatch back into his regular body
again uh but one of the big issues that
you kind of go on with here this is this
is kind of interesting shadow site g is
actually the original location where the
gamma bomb radiation or gamma bomb
incident happened and it's one of the
funny things that puck kind of hits on
because he's like this is the best place
to hide right there's not really any
gamma radiation here anymore and it
would largely be believed by by gamma
flight that as far as bruce banner is
concerned that bruce banner doesn't like
being the incredible hulk and this is
kind of a reminder that of of when he
became the hulk it'd be like the last
place he would want to visit right why
would you want to go back to the place
that has the worst memories for you and
so ultimately it's kind of this this
interesting little situation but they're
basically met with this kind of
facsimile of the one below all now this
is where i say things get a little wonky
here just because of the fact that when
you're dealing with with the one below
all in a being on this level of power
the way he he's portrayed here is kind
of intriguing but it's also very very
very important i'll talk about why here
in a second but before i do that i want
to kind of jump over to what's happening
with joe fix it real quick in the sense
that there's a guy who's wearing a hulk
smash uh jacket basically the cops get
pissed off because of the damage of the
hulk and they go to basically you know
tackle this guy to give him a hard time
and basically joe fix it turns into the
incredible hulk and then in turn goes in
and you know he's confronted by the ufos
that'll matter here in a minute the the
plot with the ufos isn't exceedingly
important all that really happens i mean
to really kind of sum that up real quick
is they kill him right that's basically
it like they end up destroying the
incredible hulk uh which pleases them
finally after all these years being able
to pull it off and we'll wrap back
around to the conclusion of that here in
a second but one of the things that
that's you know kind of getting back to
the one below all here because i imagine
that's what you guys really care about
one of the things that's kind of
interesting here is that under normal
circumstances when you have a being of
this level of power that's able to take
over the host body of somebody and then
send a facsimile of himself into the
universe it's insanely powerful right
that's the way the cosmic entities work
then in marvel comics the cosmic
entities like eternity infinity so on
and so forth the way you see them in the
comics that's not actually them right
it's a facsimile of themselves that if
eternity it needs to show up and do
something in the universe he'll go to
the dimension of manifestations and this
is occupied by a guy named
anthropomorpho and anthropomorpho will
provide him with an m body basically a
body in which the uh the you know the
cosmic entity of eternity can put his
essence into and then show up in the
main marvel universe i mean i guess
technically he could just appear if he
wanted to he is a living embodiment of
the universe but he has to do it in such
a way to where mortal beings would be
able to understand and recognize his
presence otherwise it would likely just
be a ball of light or a swirling mass of
energy or something along those lines
say for example eternity wanted to
possess someone didn't seem essentially
they would seem to have all the power of
eternity but what you have here with the
one below all is not necessarily the
same way and this is a huge limitation
it's a it's like the biggest weakness of
the one below all in the sense that in
order for the one blow wall to reach its
full power it has to possess the
incredible hulk because there's
essentially this bond that arguing
hasn't necessarily expanded on and it's
in its fullest form but there more or
less seems to be this irrevocable bond
between gamma radiation and the one
below all the one below all is more or
less the source of gamma radiation but
it seems to be that it can only really
operate at its absolute peak when it
possesses somebody who is who really has
the most pure form of gamma radiation in
their body and despite all these
irradiated individuals like sasquatch or
the leader or different things like that
none of them have a quote unquote pure
strain the way the incredible hulk does
he's the perfect host and that's why the
one below all is always searching for
the incredible hulk because he's so
incredibly powerful he gets stronger the
angrier he gets there's no limit to how
strong he can get he's perfect in in
seemingly every conceivable way now why
it is that the one below all doesn't
just possess somebody who can alter
reality right somebody like franklin
richards or something like that i would
chalk that up to just the nature of the
story right it's just storytelling i
mean i would have to believe that the
antithesis to the one above all right
this demonic evil being that represents
the sum total of all evil it could
possess seemingly anybody and it would
be fine but the way that al ewing has
crafted this story it operates at its
peak when it possesses somebody with
gamma radiation and so what ends up
happening here and that's kind of the
crazy thing is the one below all or even
seemingly like this this leader
facsimile doesn't quite know exactly
what it is right it doesn't quite know
what's going on and even the shaman
who's kind of analyzing all this stuff
is like there's a whole bunch of host
bodies that are all kind of bonded there
and i can try to like bring them
together but i can't separate them right
i have no idea what would happen if i
did it could potentially kill the people
who were a part of it right it's kind of
like this twisted amalgamation this more
or less seems to be the form that the
one below all would take on if it
possesses a being that is not the
incredible hulk right that is that is
not the immortal hulk again it really
kind of seems to be a bit of a test here
can it make it in that landscape and
seemingly not but but sasquatch
basically runs up on and attacks this
facsimile of of the one below all now he
doesn't kill him it doesn't really have
the power to do that but again it's a
little wonky because it doesn't really
know what it is it's like a leader like
what are you talking about leader you
know it's a little strange and so what
you get here is basically the uh the you
know joe fix it as as the incredible
hulk being destroyed by the ufos and
then essentially waking up in the realm
of the one below all remember that's one
of the things that we talked about is
that whenever anybody who has been
exposed to gamma radiation on any
measurable scale uh basically dies that
they are whisked away to the realm of
the one below all and that a green door
will open which will essentially allow
them to resurrect themselves as how the
incredible hulk basically always comes
back but the green door can become a red
door and the red door will keep a person
from leaving and that's exactly what
happens right this uh this version of
the leader possessed by the one below
all basically says like the red door is
locked and you will become my host you
will be the perfect host for my power
and using you i will traverse across the
universe and i will wipe out everything
in existence and i'll do it in the next
universe and the next universe and the
next universe the across the entirety of
the multiverse forevermore right this
really kind of is essentially al ewing
playing forward to that that story arc
that we saw where in the next version of
the multiverse the immortal hulk is
running through and just wiping
everything out right just destroying
everything and essentially eliminating
the entirety of the multiverse in and of
itself now again why the one above all
doesn't step in i don't know but i mean
it's kind of it's sort of a mcguffin
right the one above all has all that
power why doesn't it just stop the one
below all we don't have an answer to
that question yet we don't really know
here instead you get a couple really
cool things that happen the first is
that you have um you have doc samson who
basically goes into shadow base g proper
and when he gets down there he basically
ends up realizing okay the body's gone
right like my physical body's gone so
somebody else has it now i don't know
who has it but somebody else does the
other thing that goes on is that in
order to subdue the the a really
incredible hulk or emerald hook whatever
you want to call them um along with joe
fix it that the one below all starts
summoning all these different demon
entities that exist down in its realm
and so ultimately in the midst of all
this joe fixit begins to lose his mind
like begins to get angrier and angrier
and angrier starts to rage and then does
something that we've never seen before
he turns into the red hulk now this is
wholly new for those of you guys who are
new here one make sure you guys check
out the entire incredible hulk playlist
i have which will make you an expert on
the incredible hulk but two uh the red
hulk is not bruce spanner right that's
thunderbolt ross that is a wholly
different person joe fixit is the grey
hulk right he's like a smart hulk he's
he's weaker than your your you know
normal savage hulk or really a lot of
the hulks that exist out there a lot of
the the forms of banner but nonetheless
like he's still pretty capable but we've
never seen the incredible hulk become
the red hulk that's nuts that's a whole
different thing and it's kind of nuts
because this is this is basically cosmic
hulk is what it looks like right like
this is god hulk because it's kind of
nuts because this guy basically has the
ability to shatter the red door now to
give you guys perspective here the red
door is created by the one below all and
seemingly the red door can only be
opened or destroyed by the one below all
and so at this point the immortal hulk
has the power of god and that's kind of
the crazy thing is because what ends up
happening is with the the body of joe
fix it having been destroyed by the ufos
it begins to remanifest it begins to
re-emerge this time it's a holy new
version of the incredible hulk it looks
like joe fix it but almost with a tint
of green and then like this almost just
red veins pulsing throughout his body
it's nuts right like i really want to
call this guy god hulk it's crazy and
it's really really cool
you know i got to be honest with you
guys i'm a little sad that al ewing's
run on the incredible hulk is going to
be ending relatively soon uh because
it's alleyways right on the hulk is one
of these weird things right like if
you're not a fan of alguin's writing
style you're gonna hate the hulk but if
you love al ewing's writing style you're
gonna love the hulk it's one of these
things where there really isn't an in
between here it's it's kind of divisive
right it doesn't mean people hate it
this only just means it's not
necessarily for them right so what we're
doing here is we're covering this kind
of one shot called time of monsters
right which is this kind of uh one of
these stories where it looks like it's
introducing a new version of the hulk
that seems to be the case and it's
really cool right so what this does is
this whole story takes place about 9 500
years before the modern day and what it
looks like is it's the very first host
of the one below all right the very
first person to ever really be exposed
to his power and to really take it on in
his full totality now what you end up
doing here is picking up with a kid by
the name of tammuz and basically the
leader of a local village and the way
this is kind of told is that at some
point in their early days like a lot of
primitive cultures they worshipped
essentially a goddess right and this
idea was that the land they lived in was
lush and green and it was beautiful and
there were all kinds of animals and
plants and things for them to feed and
feast and so on and so forth but
ultimately all they did was consume and
they never gave anything back and so as
time passed the land began to become
barren it began to lose its rich water
deposits the various animals that
existed there were either completely
consumed or fled and this was
interpreted by the tribe as being
punishment by the goddess for the fact
that they just never gave to her the way
they were supposed to that all they did
was took and they never gave back and so
the result of this is you have what's
kind of called the green light right and
it's almost like this pit that exists
down there and what happens is seemingly
people are sacrificed to it now tamu
seems like one of these kids or really
the part of the generation and that
usually happens with each passing
generation they fall less and less in
line with the particular religious
beliefs of the generation before them
and so this is no different and what you
end up having here is tamuza kind of
comes forward or not really comes
forward but word has reached the ears of
the village elder that he's not he
doesn't really hold the faith the way
other people do right his faith is as
described as having faltered right that
he believes that the the village elder
is is essentially rattled that he's
losing his mind that things need to
change and things need to progress but
he's holding on to the way things used
to be and so the result of this is that
tomus has basically been chosen as a
sacrifice now there's gonna be a lot of
duplicity that goes on here that will
actually be established later on but
ultimately tammuz is kicked inside this
pit and when he is he's sacrificed to
this kind of green eye which literally
starts tearing his body apart right it's
almost like a like it just kind of
absorbs him and it sends it it's almost
like a gravity well right it just kind
of starts sucking him in and ripping the
flesh from his bones in a pretty
gruesome way and then he's completely
consumed by it like kind of consumed by
this this green eye as they call it and
when that happens the green door opens
now for those of you guys who are just
joining us with regards to the
incredible hulk stuff one i highly
suggest you check out the playlist down
in the description to get caught up on
everything related to the immortal hulk
but two as a kind of quick run over here
the green door is essentially an access
point right and it's almost like a door
of the chosen so when a particular
individual out there dies and they've
been exposed to gamma radiation which is
essentially the case here right if
anything it's probably more like a gamma
uh meteorite right or some kind of
artifact that's been exposed to gamma
radiation somewhere along the line that
uh that when a person's been exposed to
gamma and they basically die the green
door opens which takes them to the realm
of the one below all if they choose to
pass through it and when that happens
tammuz is essentially taken to the realm
of the one below all now what we end up
getting here is this kind of of
explanation right something that goes on
with regards to his friend now his
friend is a kid by the name of shaleem
who's actually the son of the village
elder himself and the way this played
out is that at some point in the past uh
tammuz's mother actually died and he was
more or less adopted by the village
elder who kind of took him on as
something akin to a son it's not
necessarily one of these exact things
where he is a biological son it's more
just kind of an adoption process but the
important thing is that shalem has kind
of a an uneasy feeling about what's
going on with tammuz and he's kind of
out and about uh seemingly he doesn't
really know where he is and the concern
is almost kind of this ache in his
stomach that something's going
something's happened to him now when his
father returns home of course he asks
him like do you know where where tamooze
is and his answer is no like why do you
ask and that's when chilean picks up on
the fact that he's done something to him
now when he goes to attack his dad his
dad immediately you know just kind of
knocks him down refers to him as a milk
stop basically a colloquial term for
somebody who's weak or incapable of of
handling themselves in any real
measurable way that has to like rely on
others for help and things like that and
so the results of this is that one of
the hunters comes running back and talks
of a beast that has appeared in the
woods in an area near the uh tribe and
that it'll basically be enough because
of its size it'll be enough to feed them
for quite some time and so what you end
up doing is switching over to uh tammuz
who's basically re-emerged as a
hulk-like monster and it's one of these
funny things because even though he's
here traditionally as what we would call
a hulk he's not here with nefarious
purposes instead in being here he's
realized certain things that one there's
actually water below ground and if the
water can be irrigated then it'll be
enough for the tribe to be able to
sustain themselves to grow crops
different things like that presumably
animals will return to this place and
it's a way to kind of turn it back into
a lush environment and that's what he
starts doing right he literally starts
tearing through the ground trying to get
to this water and so because of that he
looks pretty he looks pretty badass i
mean to the average person who sees him
he looks wildly monstrous and almost
like a demon entity and that's how the
village village members treat him that
when he emerges he's trying to talk to
them trying to have a conversation with
him but all that comes out are just
garbled growls and in his frustration he
lashes out much like we've seen with the
incredible hulk do with regards to
people who are kind of moving against
him and so the result of this is that
he's essentially killed by an arrow uh
which is fired by shaleem not knowing
that it's to mousse but ultimately he
ends up coming across the corpse and
then he sees a tattoo or a birthmark on
his body and realizes that it's that
it's to move that he's somehow been
changed or modified or altered and so
the result of this is that when he kind
of dies and he falls back to the realm
of the one below all that essentially
he's kind of met by the one below all
himself and when this happens the one
below all kind of tells him like you
bear my mark right like i turn my face
towards you i am the one below all and
he says with these hands i break with
this mouth i how my weapon is hate and
the reality is tomus felt betrayed by
his own tribe and so when that happens
uh he basically says like so is mine
right he's basically bound by vengeance
here and so that's what's kind of crazy
is because following that they actually
end up feasting on the body of of tammuz
in his hulk form you know and just kind
of like like literally eating all parts
of him and that's when the village elder
kind of stands up and says like this
beast was brought here as a bounty to us
right it was brought us brought to us
here by the goddess right she gave it to
us uh and and that we destroyed it and
we we killed it so it means that she
still cares about us it's a gift she's
simply just testing us right she's
putting us through these paces with this
harsh environment because she wants us
wants to make sure that we're worthy
whatever excuse he chooses to use to one
essentially maintain his own position
and two to keep things as they are the
other thing that happens is that as they
continue to go through and to consume
this corpse the shaleem does not but he
also begins to notice that one of the
eyes is starting to open up right that
it's just slightly open and that's what
he tells his father like no like do not
eat this thing but they consume it
anyway right they're consuming the gift
of the goddess that's been given to them
and the hope that by consuming the gift
that she's given they're essentially
offering right they're giving something
back they're showing appreciation and
then in turn their their realm will
start to kind of grow back to the way
that it was before that you know life
will return so on and so forth and they
can go back to
no longer living such a harsh and
terrible life the exact opposite happens
that as they consume this corpse it
literally starts to destroy them right
it starts to kill them and break them
all down until essentially the eye
completely opens and temu starts to
reform right because now he's
essentially an immortal hulk given that
gift by the one below all like he
literally starts to grow starts to
reform and then turns his vengeance to
shalem now for his part shaleem really
didn't know that it was tammuz like he
really had no idea that it was his best
friend that he had essentially killed
right even his brother if we're being
honest with ourselves he didn't realize
that he had fired the arrow in his own
friend's eye and essentially brought him
to an end but ultimately uh the response
to moose is i don't care right like you
know in one of these instances he kind
of has essentially the voice of the one
below all kind of speaking into his mind
saying like you will never be a rid of
your vengeance right you'll never be rid
of your anger and your wrath that will
always be a part of you right that's
gonna be who you are forevermore and so
the results of this is that he basically
kills shaleem now the reason why this
matters this is one of the reasons why
this story is so cool is because
following that he just goes forward out
into the world he doesn't die right he's
not killed by shaleem it's not like
chilemio has to kill his own friend
again and then kind of go forward from
there like it literally says temuz
leaves the village alone right like he
he's he's the only person that emerges
from this place presumably he's gonna
show up and probably face off against
the immortal hulk which would be cool i
don't really know what what name to give
this guy maybe like the demon hulk or
something like that which is kind of a
cool name because he he looks like a
demonic character right he looks like a
demonic being and unlike the immortal
hulk which is just kind of a
manifestation from bruce banner and is
still in a lot of ways a relative good
guy depending on the circumstance but
doesn't really intend to cause harm to
other people tamu seems to be the exact
same way right like the hate hulk that's
basically what he is like he's literally
bound by hate and vengeance and that's
it right he's just going forward it's
kind of like this force of of violence
this force of seemingly entropy
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the immortal hulk yes we
are red god hulk versus thor or the
avengers i'm not really sure what i'm
going to call it yet but this is
basically like the most powerful version
or not i wouldn't say the most powerful
version but it's a super powerful
version of the whole i think he's
incredibly powerful the biggest issue
with this is we don't really get like a
world war hulk story line with him but
it is really really cool uh what this
does those of you guys who recall the
red god hulk if we want to call him that
it's like savage hulk just pulsing with
red hulk energy uh had essentially come
up against the ufos now the ufos as we
talked about the previous video that we
did for those of you guys who are
catching up we're basically long enemies
of the incredible hulk but it recently
been contacted by peter geyrick of
course gyrik basically being like a
government agent who was a long time foe
of the x-men and is now kind of being
invoked here so marvel's obviously
turning him into one of these guys where
he just kind of circulate him around
based on the nature of the story i'm
surprised to see him in here but the
ufos have always proven to be pretty
capable with regards to the incredible
hulk the biggest thing that always set
the ufos back is they would bicker
amongst each other and that would
basically give hulk the opportunity to
take them out in this instance like
literally red god hulk just crushes
these guys and it's not even not even a
contest and they do everything they can
even vapor's helpless and vapor is
arguably the most powerful member of the
ufos now as you guys have probably
figured out vapor's ability is to
basically turn into pretty much any gas
and it doesn't even have to be a gas
that you find on earth it can be a gas
from like extraterrestrial landscapes or
anything like that and it's kind of
crazy because she literally turns into
sulfuric acid gas right which should be
enough to like dissolve the incredible
hulk to give you guys perspective on
what we're dealing with here sulfuric
acid can dissolve metals right i usually
charge it but it can dissolve metals
right you just break them down if you
add it if you have like water or alcohol
to it it'll just create heat right it'll
it'll create like a violent reaction
just explode but it's kind of it's it's
nuts it should be more than enough to
take out the incredible hulk having it
in a gaseous form is a way for her to
just kind of envelope the hulk the
problem with this is he completely
inhales her right he completely inhales
like this sulfuric acid gas and then
just spits it back in the face of
another member of the ufos right and the
problem is like simon literally starts
choking and dying on this stuff right
like that's kind of the crazy thing the
overall gist of this is that because of
the the really the power of the immortal
hulk here he's able to overcome these
guys quite readily and the result of
this is that they kind of just whisk him
away right literally he just gets
punched across like across the sky right
across the land and ultimately the ufos
end up contacting hiring geirk and it's
just like okay look we kind of had him
on the ropes they didn't and it's like
if your guys hadn't screwed up then like
we would have ultimately gotten a hold
of him we would have been able to bring
him in the problem with this is they're
like we're not a match for him now right
like whatever form he's in now is not
enough for us to be able to take this
guy out we need something more and
that's when henry peter guyrick
basically ends up getting a hold of the
avengers and has the avengers respond so
following that you essentially pick up
in manhattan and of course immortal
hulk's not too worried about the ufos at
the moment it's just kind of like you
know like whatever right i mean they're
going to come after me they come after
me and i'll give them more of the same
right i mean you know that's that's kind
of the crazy thing and so in the midst
of this kind of thing where he's just
kind of standing in this bar one of the
things to remember when it comes to the
hulk is that society at large is still
fearful of him even though the the
immortal hulk is kind of is really more
intelligent and kind of wants to be left
alone to a degree different things like
that this version not necessarily the
immortal hulk but a more intelligent
version of the hulk that's essentially
powered by the mind of of joe fix it at
the end of the day people are still
terrified of the hulk right the fear
still reigns supreme and that's why you
see this kind of crazy thing when it's
just like you know people are horrified
by this guy the problem is that in the
middle of all this thor shows up and
immediately attacks the immortal hulk
right immediately goes after him and
this is one of those things where the
response to the avengers seems to be
more or less containment right the idea
that like the immortal hulk is probably
going to go on a rampage again and
that's the overall assumption whenever
it comes to the hulk whenever the hulk
appears unless it's some kind of a
situation with like the onslaught saga
where he's necessary and the avengers
like call the hulk in or some kind of
situation like that whenever he's just
kind of out there the assumption is he's
about to go and you know cause craziness
and all kinds of stuff so the avengers
respond accordingly but there's actually
something else sort of going on here
something else is actually happening but
the funny thing is that thor despite the
power that he possesses is just not
enough for the immortal hulk now this is
something that i want to point out here
what this looks like and we can't
definitively say this because they look
a little bit different but what this
looks like is the version of thor who
currently rules asgard and if that's the
case thor has his equivalent of the odin
force now i wouldn't go as far as to say
this is like immortal hulk fighting odin
and so like immortal hulk can beat odin
but he's more powerful than your
baseline version of thor and that's the
whole significance behind this is this
is the power boost that the immortal
hulk got not only that it's all the
avengers that are here and this is why i
say this is probably king thor's because
you've got the the current roster of the
avengers who are here the reality of
this is even despite their best efforts
there's not a whole lot that they can do
to make things even more difficult
you've got the arrival of red harpy
betty who shows up here which is
basically like another gamma irradiated
mutate i mean we had a discussion on her
previously so make sure you guys check
the uh the immortal hulk playlist down
in the description so you can get caught
up and you can really you can find out
more about who she is but what you end
up getting here is essentially like this
this red god hulk facing off against
like the avengers and that's kind of the
nuts thing is because this whole
situation is kind of looked at and
really even narrated by like jennifer
walters by she-hulk now there really
isn't a whole lot she could do anyway
against this level of power i mean
there's not really even anything the
like like thor or like iron man or
captain america black panther or even
captain marvel could do against this but
at the end of the day she's kind of
narrating it and she's just like all the
incredible hulk knows is rage and chaos
right that's that's all this thing knows
that's all it's known over the course of
its life that ever since the hulk came
into existence all it's known is being
chased and tracked down by various
people that is it's like these small
moments of reprieve when he finds a kind
of ally in the avengers but for the most
part it's always somebody hunting him
down somebody attacking him somebody
coming against him and and really
jennifer walters sees this version of of
the hulk as kind of like the epitome
right this idea of the hulk's rage given
form now this almost kind of seems to
fly in the face of world breaker hulk
but that's one of the funny things to
keep in mind is even though world
breaker hulk was the strongest version
of the hulk that we'd seen the reality
was that his rage had reached a point
where it was almost a kind of inner calm
right it was almost a point where he was
just kind of had reached like a
stillness like you ever had that where
you get so pissed off that you're just
calm right and that's almost like the
the scariest version of a person being
mad where they just kind of stop and
calm down and it's like oh my god right
like it's about to pop off man like
that's kind of the crazy thing and
that's why you even see references to
like world breaker hulk where you kind
of have this scenario where blade is
basically like thrown into the sky by
hulk and then the response of captain
america he tells iron man go get him and
and iron man's like well i mean no like
i mean you guys can't stand against a
hulk on your own and at the end of the
day like black panther is like no we
retain the the the advantage of numbers
right like a single warrior is you know
that's disciplined enough can handle the
hulk on their own and that's when whole
kind of comments and says like you know
like you're disciplined enough like if
you're disciplined how'd that work out
for you last time you know and that's
what uh black panther is like like i
offered you mercy right like i attempted
dialogue you taught me a lesson when you
crushed us all so badly that's what's so
kind of crazy about this right it's
literally learning lessons from their
experiences facing off against the hulk
and so what you end up getting in the
middle of this huge fight where the
avengers are quite literally just
getting it handed to them is you have
the arrival of gamma flight now remember
gamma flight is really trying to reel
the hulk back in but get a better
understanding of what's going on because
behind the veil of all of this and
that's the thing that jennifer walters
does not initially pick up on here but
then starts to realize it's kind of
going on behind the veil of all of this
is the one below all there's a kind of
rage that's permeating everybody a kind
of wrath that's even permeating thor
right something behind the scenes it's
kind of tugging and almost instigating
right almost increasing this kind of
violence that each of these heroes have
towards the incredible hulk and the kind
of rage he has towards them and there's
this kind of comment this kind of moment
where you have a titania who approaches
she-hulk with the intention of trying to
trying to take her out and the response
of titania right with gamma flight
working alongside the the hulk group
more or less is do we take out the
she-hulk chick or or like do we just let
her stay and the response of betty is no
like she's with us right like you've
seen the door haven't you and the
response of she-hulk is yes i've seen
the green door so she's aware that the
green door exists now whether or not she
knows what lies beyond it isn't really
explained here we assume that maybe she
does but at the end of the day the
effects of the one below all kind of
permeate out into everything so much so
that there's actually a point where thor
like smashes the hand of the immortal
hulk with mjolnir and then doing that
literally just like destroys his arm
right like literally just fractures his
arm and then following that like
immortal hulk just takes the tentacles
or the the little bits of his arm that
are there and starts to suffocate thor
and it's one of the things that jennifer
walters kind of hits on is that like
thor's not normally like this right he's
not normally this extreme and aggressive
that's not usually how he is right he's
he he can be if he needs to be but it's
almost like thor's in a berserker state
but not in a berserker state that the
response of thor would be one of
containment and control not like assault
and and almost like an attempt to kill
and that's the whole thing behind the
avengers is understanding the immortal
hulk as he exists in the sense that he
can always kind of be resurrected and
always come back and their experiences
facing off against him in the past in
his most powerful forms really leads
them to the position of we gotta take
him out black panther literally cuts his
arm off i mean it's just it's things
like that right it's it's really extreme
in a lot of ways the fight that's going
on here but that's when jennifer walters
even looks at black panther and realizes
okay so black panther is not necessarily
governed by rage here but the steps he's
taking are even a little extreme for him
right where he just kind of looks at
hulk and it's just like we have to kill
him right like we have to kill this guy
and that's usually not the response of
black panther like the only time black
panther really takes a response like
that is it's like somebody invades
wakanda or they're like an imminent
threat to wakanda or even like the world
or something like that then black
panther will take that approach like we
need to kill them and while there is
recognition here that black panther is
operating in a more calculated form he's
offering operating in a more methodical
form even then it just seems chaos right
it seems like chaos and pandemonium and
so ultimately you end up having betty
who approaches she-hulk and she doesn't
go to attack she just kind of looks at
her with this expectation of are you
going to do anything about this and
that's when she-hulk seemingly has to
choose her allegiance she's at this
point where she kind of has to choose
the hulk family or she has to choose the
avengers and the reality is that it
makes sense here because of the fact
that she was really the last holdout and
that's what makes things kind of
intriguing because one thing to bear in
mind we're like three issues out from
the conclusion of al ewing's run so who
knows what form this is gonna take but
the reality is she's part of the hulk
family whether she wants to admit it or
not whether she sees herself that way or
not she definitively is and so she
basically quells the entirety of the
conflict with just one of those sonic
claps and sends the avengers all flying
and so in response to that a kind of
teleportation gun is ultimately fired
and that basically allows uh gamma
flight and the and the hulks to
essentially take off right to basically
bail out and that's when uh that's when
she-hulk ends up going with them and so
in essence she-hulk has now stood
against the avengers and she's now
currently operating alongside the
incredible hulk family more or less
that's kind of nuts because basically
everybody who's irradiated with gamma
mutation is now aligned on a particular
side right this is probably the most
true statement if there's ever been one
of a of really an entire hulk family
right that's really what it is here but
i'm kind of curious like what direction
this is going to go in like i'm curious
where we're going to end up seeing this
kind of conclude
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking back up with the immortal
hulk now one thing to know we are only a
handful of issues out until this thing
ends right i think we have what is this
this is technically july so i think we
have august september and october so we
got three issues left until this whole
thing is finished and it's all wrapped
up and done so i'm really excited to see
where this ends because i'm you know let
me know down in the comments i'm curious
what y'all's take is on the immortal
hulk run up to this point but in this
video we're covering what is basically
the secret origin of joe fixit hulk now
one of the things to keep in mind when
it comes to joe fix it is that what you
had originally at marvel comics as most
of you guys know is you had the
incredible hulk who was gray and a lot
of that was because they just didn't
want him to tie into any kind of racial
ethnicity or anything like that but the
difficulties that came with making the
incredible hulk gray in color basically
couldn't be overcome so they ended up
making him green now years later under
peter david's run with the incredible
hulk 347 they brought the grey hulk back
but call him joe fix it and the
incontinuity explanation is that
technically the very first variation of
the incredible hulk we saw was actually
joe fix at hulk hence the reason why he
was great but the geofixit persona took
a backseat to the savage hulk persona
which is why he turned to green and so
it was a pretty neat way to kind of wrap
those things up but the reality is we
never really seem to get a tried and
true explanation of joe fix it and so a
lot of this really seems to cope with
that now one of the things this does
here is it kind of has a bit of a
flashback with regards to betty ross and
all that kind of stuff a bit of the
history there between her and bruce and
anybody who's been reading the
incredible hulk for any measure of time
will tell you their relationship is
tumultuous at best
[Laughter]
right they have been lovers and they
have been head over heels for each other
and there's been times where they've
been at each other's throats right they
just absolutely want to kill each other
really good example of that was red
she-hulk versus the incredible hulk
right but the whole thing behind this is
that a lot of what happened with betty
ross the struggle she went through a lot
of even the even the death of her
character was all based on her
experiences with the incredible hulk if
bruce banner had not become the hulk she
wouldn't have endured all those
different things and a lot of this is
designed to kind of juxtapose things
right the idea that in the early days
when she was talking to her dad oh you
know don't be unfair to bruce spanner
you know he's a cool guy everything's
gonna be fine you know no matter what
happens i'm sure he knows what he's
doing all the while kind of giving us
this this you know these kind of panels
that show us that yes they got married
and their life basically went to crap
and she ended up dying then came back as
red she-hulk and then all this kind of
crazy stuff right he basically turned
her life upside down and all this really
kind of segues into what is one of the
most weird moments of probably any
incredible hulk series ever
when you've basically got red harpy
right betty ross in bed with joe fix and
hulk imbued with the power of the red
hulk it's weird
it's a little strange but it's kind of
cool right because there's a little bit
of banter that kind of goes back and
forth between the two but one of the
other funny things that really goes on
here is that when betty turns back into
herself there's a big conversation about
the nature of bruce banner about how she
sees bruce how she's seen him for quite
some time and how she sees joe fix it
and the way this works is that bruce has
in a lot of ways kind of push betty away
that it's one of these things where he's
come to her for a but he's also pushed
her away and a lot of it's subject to
whatever it is that he happens to be
going through at the time and it really
all kind of boiled down to this
mentality of bruce doesn't want betty
exposed to the life that he lives in but
he doesn't want to live without her and
so how do you square that circle right
how do you keep somebody safe from this
life that you live but at the same time
keep them close by you and a lot of ways
you can't and that's one of the reasons
why you saw these saw a lot of these
instances over the course of the
incredible hulk mythos right bill mantlo
peter david uh greg pack jason aaron all
these guys where it was basically bruce
banner in a lot of ways pushing betty
ross away but at the same time also
trying to keep her close right this kind
of tug of war that went on and for her
it was exceedingly frustrating and
exceedingly irritating more so than that
she hasn't seen bruce banner for quite
some time that he hasn't appeared to her
and had any real kind of conversation
with her now a lot of what's gone on
recently if you guys have been following
our coverage of the immortal hulk is
that bruce banner's in hell so we can't
he can't hang out with her he can't
spend time with her but even when that
wasn't the case he just didn't really
like her and the reason why was because
she was a mirror for bruce when you look
at it if we kind of go the the route of
like bill mantlow and peter david and
look at it as a more introspective
philosophical approach to the reason why
bruce was this way it's because when
betty ross was just betty ross she was a
normal human she represented everything
that made bruce banner's life pure and
great and perfect this idea that he
could return to a state of normalcy and
this chaotic life that he led but when
the time came when betty ross died
suddenly bruce banner lost everything
that was pure and great in his life when
she returned as the red she-hulk any
chance he had of normalcy was stripped
away when she didn't want to have
anything to do with him and seem to
outright hate him and then when she
ended up becoming the red harpy or at
least returning back to the red harpy
and taking on this kind of you know red
she-hulk red harpy approach then
suddenly she was a mirror of all the
things that bruce banner hated about
himself i.e gamma radiation and the hulk
and so then he was basically avoiding
her and so it was one of these things
where consistently any possibility he
had with a great life with betty
returning to that kind of pure time when
everything was perfect was gone and
betty ross looking at joe fix it came to
this realization that where bruce
spanner shied away from that joe fixit
embraced it and so in her mind joe fixit
basically saw her for who she really was
and accepted it that in reality with
everything that she had gone through as
betty ross interprets it this harpy form
is who she really is right that's that's
who she really is the person on the
inside that's physically manifested and
joe fix it embrace that and so in a lot
of ways that kind of acceptance led to
what she believed to be the process of
falling in love the problem with this is
that joe fixit reveals his true colors
here we all know that joe fix it was not
a very good guy
and that while he does talk a big game
in a lot of ways he was kind of a coward
and that's what he reveals to her that
in this moment when he was whisked away
to hell and then everything was popping
off all joe fix it cared about was
trying to find a way out right getting
himself out of there all the while he
knew bruce spanner was there but made
absolutely no effort to get bruce
spanner out of hell and he tells her
that he's like look i mean you know the
reason why bruce hasn't been talking to
you is because he's in health and yes i
was there and i could have saved him but
at the end of the day i just wanted to
find a way out and she freaks she's like
you left bruce in hell
and immediately starts going off on it
right immediately starts losing it and
attacking him now you do kind of switch
over for a second between jennifer
walters and jackie mcgee of course as
you guys recall in the last video that
we did jennifer walters essentially
defected from the avengers and joined
the immortal hoax team which was really
kind of al ewing essentially
consolidating all the members of the
gamora radiated community into one place
but what she of course does is take the
phone of jackie mcgee and then she
basically hops on the old fantastic four
line now the reason why this happens
this is a great reference by al ewing i
love that he did this jennifer walters
was a member of the fantastic four at
one point in marvel comics a lot of you
guys may not know that but there was a
point when different characters shifted
around and so you had characters that
would stand in for these guys jennifer
walters was one of them and so because
of the fact that that was the case she
has access to the kind of fantastic four
back channels right their communication
lines and she basically sends off an
encrypted message to ben grimm which
says like the incredible hulk's cool
everything is okay i'm safe i got
everything under control the question he
asks to what is an effect an entire
assembly of all the biggest heavy
hitters in the in the marvel universe
right so all the members of the
fantastic four and all the members of
the avengers is are we gonna do the same
thing
are we gonna tell her that we're all
basically mustering our forces to launch
an attack on the immortal hulk and the
entirety of the the hulk family or do we
keep that to ourselves right now we
don't really get an answer to that
instead what we get is basically the
aftermath of of joe fixit hulk revealing
to jennifer walters that he left bruce
banner in hell and essentially she lets
him have it right that she's kind of
like you so i've been operating under
this fall false pretense this whole time
this whole time i thought you were a guy
who saw me for who i really was and all
that kind of stuff and said it turns out
you're just a coward and a dick like
really you know and just just like lays
into this guy and where he apologizes
her response is no you don't know how to
be sorry right you want to look sorry
but that's just a camouflage to hide the
real you that you only care about
yourself and at that point she writes
him off and in the end he tries to make
up for this by kind of offering an
explanation and saying look you know
there's something that you need to
understand about who i am right there's
something that you need to understand
about who like who i am as a person and
where i came from right that i am simply
just a version of the incredible hulk
that you ran across one day just one of
bruce banners alters right as alternate
personalities but there's another thing
that you need to know here there was a
kid like when bruce banner was a little
kid he was you know beaten by his father
his mother was beaten by his father but
his life was absolute turmoil and
absolute health and that while his
father was sleeping it off one night
while his mom wasn't there he watched a
black and white movie through both of
his black eyes that had just been been
made that way by his father and
somewhere in there was an idea of what a
grown-up is somebody who could take the
pain and he says that's where i started
from now this is not a lengthy secret
origin here but it's tragic as hell
because one of the things to know
especially when it came to the
incredible hulk mythos for a lot of you
guys who are new to the incredible hulk
new to this channel don't really know
about a lot of this stuff the old
stories with stan lee and jack kirby
were straightforward incredible hulk
stories right hulk just smashing things
he fights from people the story ends and
then you do it again in the next issue
when it got to bill mantlow and peter
david especially really it started with
bill matlow and continued through peter
david it was very much an introspective
philosophical run on what makes the
incredible hulk the incredible hulk how
did banner become the person that he was
did the incredible hulk just manifest
randomly because of gamma radiation or
is there something deeper than that and
one of the things that they really built
on there is that everything the
incredible hulk represents is
essentially the rage that bruce banner
fields towards his father brian banner
and that being left alone is one part
whenever the incredible hulk says that
it's one part telling the people who
were there leave me alone and two crying
out to when he was a little kid begging
his father to leave him alone the run of
bill mantlow and peter david you talk to
anybody who knows anything about the
incredible hulk and they'll tell you
it's one of the most significant runs in
the history of the character because
everything that you've seen with the
incredible hulk following those runs is
built on those ruts right every concept
that you've seen is predicated on that
right just because of the work that was
done and the things that went into it
and so ty you know al ewing doing this
ties into that old stuff where it
basically really takes a page out of the
stories of bill matlow and peter david
and it says that like the notion of of
bruce banner sure the savage hulk is a
reflection of the rage that he feels
towards his father joe fix it the reason
why he's so hardcore the reason why he's
you know the guy you don't mess around
with while he has this kind of
intelligence but at the same time is
what you would define as kind of being a
man's man is because it's predicated on
a movie that bruce banner in his younger
years developed this alternate
personality because he wanted to be the
kind of person that could withstand the
pain that his father dished out to him
and that's why when things get really
really really really bad sometimes joe
fix it will manifest the personality
that takes over needs to be the
personality that can cast everything
aside emotional ties the whole nine
yards and do what needs to be done and
that's what joe fixit is right he is a
kind of romanticized perception of what
bruce banner thinks a man is based on
the movies that he's seen so it's a it's
a great concept right it's a really
really cool idea but at the end of the
day in saying all that he says like it's
not really me that i'm in love with
anymore i don't want to be that person
anymore and when she's like so what what
does any of that mean he says i love you
right he's like that's what that means
is that i'm i'm in love with you right
like i joe fix it i'm in love with you
betty ross which i mean i under like the
the whole motivation behind this it's
it's beautiful looking at it is weird
joe fix it hulk like joe fix and hulk
with the power of the red hulk is saying
this to a red harpy it's a little wonky
but if you can look past that
and kind of look at it as two
personalities saying this then it makes
sense but at the end of the day betty
ross is like i don't know what to do
with this right i don't know how to
respond to this and so she does the only
thing that she can do the only thing
that she really knows how to do is that
when he's spilling his heart and saying
like you make me want to be a better man
like i know it was done to leave bruce
there but this time that i spend with
you this time that i'm around you makes
me realize all my shortcomings all my
mistakes and it makes me want to be
better betty ross does what she always
does she runs she flees right she
basically ends up taking off and so when
joe fix it you know kind of continues
this conversation not realizing that
betty ross is taking off and he's saying
things like you know now that i've come
out during the day and and i'm around
people more i've learned to understand
people better i've learned to grasp
people better so on and so forth and
i've kind of learned the error of my
ways once he asks her what she thinks
she's gone right she's totally taken off
and so he's like okay well then i guess
that kind of answers that question to a
degree and so ultimately he ends up kind
of stepping out of the room because this
whole thing took place just in an
apartment room which is pretty cool you
know i love i love the idea when you
have comic book stories where the whole
story takes place in like a room right
it just takes place in like a singular
location because it's a real testament
to whether or not a writer can write
characters in a way that that people can
find receptive right can they really
understand those characters if they can
write them in what is in effect a static
location without a whole bunch of action
sequences and things to mask the poor
handling of the characters but
nonetheless al ewing of course as you
guys know writes immortal hulk just
stupidly well it's ridiculous how good
it is but when the when the question's
asked like what's the plan like what
what are we doing here right i mean like
is there some goal that we have because
right now we're just hiding out from the
avengers on the fantastic four what what
what are we doing
what's the next step and the answer that
joe fix it has is i'm gonna go to hell
i'm gonna go to hell i'm gonna face the
one below all and i'm gonna save bruce
banner whether i'm ready to do this or
not it's cool this is obviously leading
up to something massive
okay this comic book man this comic book
man this comic book let me tell you
something
i'm sorry i'm so excited people but it
is an exciting comic book right it is an
exciting story there's this amazing
conclusion to immortal hulk it's it's
ridiculous it's crazy it's
man i love this thing al ewing man al
ewing oh al you god i love valuing okay
so here's the thing this picks up in
ohio back in 1901 in like the middle of
a blizzard right and it's long before
the incredible hulk before bruce banner
was ever born ever came into existence
or anything like that and there's a
couple of guys who are basically meeting
up now one of these guys is named samuel
so obviously you can basically derive
from this given just the context of the
situation this guy basically seems to be
the guy who is who basically came before
samuel stearns right like his family
line and so the crazy thing about this
is that as most of you guys know we had
that story about like that crazy looking
demonic hulk being whatever it is the
skull of it's basically here and what
seems to have been going on is that
these brothers have basically been going
through and essentially finding like all
these different artifacts that just kind
of exist around the world and i wouldn't
go as far as to say they were based on
the notion of like hulk itself so much
so as they were basically trying to like
find their fortune or trying to find
something great i mean like like one of
the things for example when the
questions asked about that giant skull
is that samuel responded saying that was
a gift from a paleontologist i know some
fool dug it up in the ottoman region
tried to pass it off as a new dinosaur
right like it's a clear fake the bones
aren't even fossilized but even so it's
well made right so they don't really
know the kind of stuff that we're
dealing that they're dealing with here
right we know that's the head of what is
in effect the first hulk on earth they
just don't really know that and so one
of the things that happens here is you
end up discovering that essentially a
kind of radioactive wave has been
discovered this is basically the first
time humanity ever discovers gamma rays
right gamma radiation no one's ever
really discovered it before and it's one
of these things where samuel is like
this is going to be it man like this is
the night that our
great-great-grandchildren will will
remember right everybody like our family
lines are going to remember this forever
and ever and ever but you basically pick
up in what is essentially the below
place right the the realm of the one
below all and one thing to understand
here is that while you do see hulks
these are more of like the personalities
of hulk shooter given form bruce banner
of course is possessed by the one below
all or a prisoner of the one below all
who's basically siphoning off all his
gamma energy right so the various hulks
you see here are just personalities of
the hulk right so jackie mcgee of course
is hanging out with them and remember
jackie mcgee is apparently or has
apparently been touched by gamma
radiation due to her exposure to it but
unlike a lot of people around her right
walter lankowski or doc sampson or the
leader or anybody like that she doesn't
really have a physical mutation that
pertains to gamma radiation she doesn't
really hulk out in the traditional sense
instead she has the ability to see
ghosts right gamma-based ghosts so again
how exactly that translates i'm not
entirely sure one thing to keep in mind
when it came to al ewing's run
technically it was kind of cut short it
was supposed to run longer than this and
for reasons that i'll never fully
understand marvel cut it short maybe
it's due to poor sales i don't know who
wouldn't be buying this comic and
reading it it's absolutely amazing but
it's still kind of a cool thing right
because one of the things to bear in
mind is that this depiction of the
incredible hulk as you see him here is
still very childlike in nature whereas
you have the red hulk personality which
again is very authoritative in nature
right it's kind of these these aspects
now again red hulk is not normally a
personality trait of uh of bruce banner
but again this is basically joe fix it
in hulk form right joe fix it of course
being one of the personalities of bruce
spanner but the important thing here is
they end up basically coming across what
is the layer of the leader as he's
currently possessed by the one below all
right that's one of the things to
remember is that the one below all his
first real appearance on earth as far as
we're aware at least in this particular
universe came in the form of him
basically possessing brian banner or
appearing as brian banner using him as a
vessel to influence people on earth with
regards to the notion of the leader he's
the one that essentially took over after
brian banner right and so that's why the
leader is kind of the one that's being
manipulated here again i invite you guys
to check out our immortal hulk playlist
down in the description to get a better
idea of everything that's going on but
the important thing kind of a side
effect here right you basically have the
fantastic four who are trying to figure
out how to open a portal to the realm of
the one below all so they can rescue
like bruce banner and all those
different guys right and then you have
walter lankowski sasquatch who's heading
he was going through the holland tunnel
and he's heading to meet with a
fantastic four not a major plot point
here right that's not a not a super
important thing switching back to these
brothers as they're kind of going
through and experimenting with or at
least analyzing this gamma radiation one
of the things that happens here is that
one of the brothers makes a remark right
this brother robert makes a remark to
his brother samuel and saying beatrice
sends her warmest regards one of the
things you find out here is that samuel
is basically sleeping with robert's wife
and the reason why is because due to
robert's cold nature he basically pushed
his wife away and she just ran into the
arms of what was basically his brother
but robert's still pissed off so he
literally loses his mind and just starts
attacking him right just starts
attacking samuel and then in turn like a
great big huge fight breaks out now
switching back to what's going on right
now once you have these depictions of
the hulk who basically arrive at the
layer of the leader this is obviously
not some stick fort right i mean this is
not the three little pigs right i'm
gonna huff and i'm gonna puff and i'm
gonna blow your demonic home down right
that's not really what this is this
thing is wildly difficult to get through
and the only way to get through it is to
be allowed through it and so that's one
of the things that happens as savage
hulk goes through and literally starts
punching this thing as hard as he
possibly can that you do end up having
the leader or at least the one below all
kind of in possession of the leader
appearing to him and kind of goading him
on and he ultimately manages to punch a
hole through this wall and then he just
walks through and then the wall
basically closes down around him and the
whole idea behind this and the reason
why this is important is because for the
most part this is kind of how this works
right it is basically a trap that he was
in effect quote unquote allowed in and
so once he gets in there he immediately
basically sees all the people over the
course of his life that have essentially
died off one of whom is jarella right
now jarella was basically the wife of
the incredible hulk at one point in time
now that whole era kind of takes place
during what we call the micro verse saga
and the incredible hulk comics which
really lasted between issue 140 running
up to 205 between 1971 and 1975. uh it
was all written by roy thomas it was the
idea that the incredible hulk had
basically entered the microverse and it
was one of those things where roy thomas
was kind of experimenting with the idea
of the hulk possibly finding some
location for himself just kind of
introducing concepts ideas just to see
how people took them it was interesting
for what it was nowhere near as
significant as bill mantle and peter
david's run but it was still pretty cool
of course jarella basically ended up
dying in issue number 205 but one of the
things to go on here is that that's kind
of the consistent depiction here that
these are all basically people who in
some form or fashion are related to the
incredible hulk by some way and that in
turn they have all basically ended up
perishing now there is a guy with the
most amazing mustache ever that
basically approaches the incredible hulk
and he doesn't know who he is right like
hulk doesn't know who this guy is i mean
he says he knows him but at the same
time he kind of doesn't know him he
seems like he's basically like he looks
a lot like samuel stearns and that's
when you kind of flash back to these
brothers and you basically have again
robert who in turn is fighting samuel
and so because robert felt like this was
such a huge betrayal that his wife had
basically ran off and then in turn got
with his brother that he basically ends
up beating samuel stearns to death right
or it seems like he beats him to death
and he actually ends up taking this
little green orb right that little piece
of of gamma radiation and just plunges
it into the mind of samuel stearns and
then basically leaves him there where he
seemingly dies and so one of the things
that happens is that as he walks away
right where he's basically choked to
death and robert in turns just walks
away and leaves suddenly the green light
starts emanating now this is a very very
important thing because while al ewing
will not give us a definitive answer on
what this means there is something that
we can kind of take away from that right
there is something that we can sort of
see or we can kind of discern based on
what we'll see later on and one of the
most insane revelations in the history
of marvel comics okay so what ends up
happening here
is you switch back over to the red hulk
and i i call him the red hulk loosely
right we just call him joe fix it you
basically pick up what joe fixes again
he punches through this this fortress
you know quote unquote again being
allowed in and as he gets in there he
actually ends up coming across mike
berengetti now unless you are someone
who is knowledgeable about joe fixit
this guy's totally lost on you but he's
probably one of the most important
characters from the incredible hulk
mythos that you've never heard of so the
idea behind this is that when joe fix it
basically appeared in las vegas and
operated in las vegas for quite some
time that one of the things that took
place is that mike berengetti basically
became a father figure right that where
the world had largely shunned hulk and
even mike barangetti in the early days
kind of saw you know joe fixed hulk as
something he could use for his own ends
in effect a father-son relationship
formed between the two of them but
because of the nature of joe fix it
because of the nature of what it means
to be a hulk that while he was more of a
thinker than your traditional savage
hulk while he was in some ways more
capable and in other ways far less
capable the reality was his presence in
vegas caused a lot of disturbances more
often than it didn't right like violent
fights and things being torn up and so
on and so forth and so ultimately baron
getty basically made him leave the
problem with this is that baron getty
had a lot of enemies and they gunned him
down when when joe fix it had
essentially left and so in a lot of ways
it's kind of this this feeling of guilt
that uh that joe fixit carries around
that had he not left mike barangetti
would still be alive and so basically
his inaction or his leaving is basically
what got mike baron getty killed because
it's not like it's something he didn't
know about right he knew that mike baron
getty had a lot of enemies but at the
end of the day it was really more
respect for mike that drove him to leave
than anything else and so because of
this much like what you saw with with
the incredible hulk right with with
green hulk himself where he basically
follows jarella up these penrose steps
for the purpose of trying to get her
back and bring her you know bring her
back to life that red hulk almost kind
of does the same thing again the
difference here is that joe fix is more
intelligent right he's smarter than your
average bear and so he knows it's a trap
and is some kind of a ruse and following
this thread basically leads him directly
to where the leader is right where the
one below all is and so what you of
course end up having is like you know
the one below all kind of manifesting
these weird crazy looking mouths they
start talking to to you know joe fix it
they've basically seized control of the
hulk himself who of course you know goes
to attack joe fix it and at the end of
the day one of the crazy things about
this is that while he's not necessarily
on par with like world breaker hulk in
terms of physical strength that he's
certainly enough to just pummel joe fix
it right almost beat him to death and
that just kind of happens over and over
and over again now one of the things
that also happens here is that where
each of these people has basically
experienced ghosts of their past right
and in effect the physical
manifestations of what is really their
own guilt that jackie mcgee experiences
the exact same thing when she talks to
her dad the difference here is that
where she sees her father her father was
always a man who believed in something
greater than himself right always
believed that there's a plan right
there's always a plan here god always
has a plan and so because of that where
jackie mcgee had kind of doubted this
and even so far in her dealings with the
immortal hulk and with joe fix it and
just the sheer insanity of everything
that's happened the fact that she can
now see gamma ghost she kind of sees
herself as having lost herself right
she's not the person she used to be the
reality is she definitely is right she's
the same person she always was her
perception of herself is in her head and
that's changed based on her life
experiences but regaining her tangible
self right when her dad says like look
at you like you're a reporter you're the
person who asks questions right on his
deathbed kind of having this
conversation right i'm so proud of the
person that you've become jackie you're
the person that's going to ask the
hard-hitting questions you're the person
who's going to be able to see things no
one else can see so again al ewing kind
of plays it with this idea that all
these different paths that people have
taken right the path of samuel stearns
be being born and becoming the leader
the path of bruce banner the the abuse
he stood at the hands of his father the
path of all these different people that
have kind of happened over the years
that it all basically comes down to the
fact that they are all basically being
led here right that it's almost like a
pre-ordained path which was all destined
to end at this particular location and
so that's when it kind of dawns on
jackie like yes i've not lost myself
right i'm jacqueline mcgee i'm an
investigative reporter i look into
things and in turn she sees directly
into the leader right and actually has
this kind of piercing gaze that
basically punctures the leader and
creates a kind of moment of weakness
that actually allows samuel stearns to
fall out now again we don't really get a
lot of explanation here from al ewing in
terms of exactly how this works we
simply just know that it does and by and
large it kind of works here right a lot
of what you're seeing is just
metaphysical stuff right i mean all this
right now is basically taking place in
the dimension of hell but when samuel
stearns finally like falls out right
kind of falls out of this this shell
this cocoon that he has right which was
basically kind of being uh was created
at least by the one below all and was
being used to basically control samuel
stearns or samuel stearns using it to
consolidate his power that one of the
things you find out here is that given
everything he's seen and everything he's
experienced he doesn't want to
experience it anymore and so it's
basically one of these things where he
made a bargain with the one below all
because he wanted to basically destroy
the incredible hulk and expand his own
power but he didn't realize the bargain
he was making and the sheer amount of
knowledge and the torment and torture he
would endure in being a part of all this
and so what he basically says is that
essentially the one below all has
siphoned off enough energy from bruce
banner that now it's arriving right the
one below all is finally here so that's
the crazy thing because now we get to
see the one below all's true form right
because up to this point it's just been
like a giant cloud monster right and so
that's kind of the crazy thing is that
that this child hole kind of lashes out
right just freaks out starts screaming
and yelling you know why was the hulk
hurt so much why is the hulk broken
inside why am i always afraid right like
i want to know why is there a hulk why
does the hulk exist what's the purpose
behind me am i really just some kind of
you know result of exposure to gamma
radiation and that's it is it of some
basic mutation and if i am then how do i
tie into you how am i involved with you
right like explain it all make it all
make sense and so that's one of the
funny things is because the one below
all responds with this kind of cryptic
phrase right like i howl through minnie
mouse i break with many hands yada yada
you know they are themselves but they
are also me and so in effect the one
below all basically responds by saying
you are a physical manifestation of my
wrath right you are physical
manifestation of me right i the one
below all and basically a being here
that represents destruction i represent
chaos i represent violence i represent
the end of things you are my earthly
avatar you represent me on earth all of
you who are who have been touched by
gamma radiation who by by whatever
manner and whatever means pass through
the green door when the opportunity was
given to you you are you are a
reflection of me right you are imbued
with a portion of my power but the
responsive of joe fix it is that's not
what he asked right that's not what's
going on here and honestly we're tired
of the games right we're tired of like
this giant cloud appearing we're tired
of all this stuff what we want we want
you to show us your real face show us
who you really are behind this mask and
so in response the one below all says
very well and that's when the one below
all reveals its real identity it is what
happens when the one above all basically
hulks what's going on here is that if
the one above all represents creation it
represents life and all that kind of
stuff then the one below all is its
complete antithesis it represents
everything opposite of that and so
that's one of the things that's kind of
crazy is because ultimately you get this
kind of really wild explanation right
and it's not even really a clear
explanation it's just you are my
creation you are necessary right there
is weight and there is counterweight
where were you when i laid these
foundations declare if you have
understanding and so with the one above
all really kind of reveals here is the
the incredible hulk the concept of the
hulk and any and really just the hulk in
his most pure form is basically the
counterweight that much like what the
one below all said that the incredible
hulk is just violence incarnate it's the
darker side of the one above all in
human form physical form on earth and
the reality is that all their paths
really did lead to this point that it's
always this way and it's always been
this way it's always been that that that
kind of thing right where he says the
left hand is strength what this seems to
indicate is that the immortal hulk or
the incredible hulk whatever you want to
call him is the strength of the one
above all incarnate and that seems to be
the reason why or at least an
explanation that al ewing is giving us
as to why it is there is no discernible
limit to how strong the incredible hulk
can get he just there's just an infinite
level of strength here i mean that's
something that we hypothesize as comic
book fans and theorized until you got to
secret wars and then secret wars
confirmed it and then in the aftermath
of secret wars you would just see these
moments where the the incredible hulk
would just have this astronomical level
of strength and the highest level of
strength the incredible hulk ever
achieved of course was during the heart
of the monster storyline where he was
quite literally shattering the dark
dimension of dormammu and umar right
like breaking their reality apart that's
the power that he has now it's not the
one above all saying you have an
infinite number infinite level of
strength and here's how you reach my
godly level of strength it's simply
saying you are a reflection of my
strength right you are a reflection of
me and therefore because you are my
earthly avatar insofar as you represent
the antithesis of me that i am creation
therefore you are the mortal physical
manifestation of destruction that in
turn that's your role that's why you are
the way you are i created you to serve
that purpose and with that role comes
pain with that role does come suffering
but that's why you exist that's why
you've gone through all the things
you've gone through that's why you
suffered through all the things you
suffer through because with this role
that i've created for you as basically
the god of destruction on earth that
just comes with it right so again one of
the things about the one above all when
it comes to marvel comics is we you
don't really get straight answers right
it's not one of those things where the
one above all sits down and breaks
things down in an easy to digest way
right where the red hulk's just like
okay give us the whole run down and
everything that's happening and the the
one above all's like okay so here's the
rub seven universes ago i got this
really really good idea right it doesn't
really work that way right it's just not
it's not like that that the one above
all always answers in just a super
cryptic way the only way you're ever
really going to get any clear-cut
answers from the one above all is if
somebody like jim starlin's writing him
and the circumstance is relatively
simple right i mean even then it's not
necessarily the case right if you go
when you read the infinity storyline
where adam warlock became the new living
tribunal in the aftermath of secret wars
from 2015 even then the one above all is
kind of like i mean you're gonna have to
basically leave your world behind and
become the living tribunal but maybe you
can and he was just speaking in like a
super cryptic way right ultimately it
was both thanos and adam warlock
deciphering it figuring it out and then
you know kind of going forward from
there but it's just one of those things
where the one above all just never gives
a clear-cut answer it's always some some
kind of you know
weird situation where it's just speaking
in riddles and that's basically it but
where the left hand of the one above all
is strength the right hand is mercy and
that's why you actually end up seeing
the hulk here being merciful towards
samuel stearns and saying basically
you've hurt me multiple times over the
years right you've hurt me so often over
the course of my life but i forgive you
now something that i do want to explain
here something that needs to be stated
here is this is not just the incredible
hulk forgiving samuel stearns it's
forgiving everybody else his father the
whole nine yards right letting all that
guilt and all that rage go because now
he's got a much better understanding of
who he is and what he's about he's got a
much better understanding of what he
stands for and so what this basically
leads to is again because walter
lankowski sasquatch met with a fantastic
four they basically found a way to open
a portal to hell that you know ben grin
comes through with sasquatch and like
hey guys we got you i got your way home
and they're like cool so they basically
go through the portal and and that's
essentially it right they just kind of
go back and again all these
personalities they don't pass through
and so that's why you don't really see
joe fix it here you don't really see
like you know the savage hulk here
because they're just personalities in
the mind of banner and so basically
banner passes through and those
personalities kind of incorporate back
into him again and then it's basically
just bruce himself but going forward
bruce now is is far more whole than he
used to be there aren't really any parts
of him that are kind of broken and
fractured where he's kind of split all
over the place he doesn't really know
what his purpose is he doesn't know why
the hulk exists in the first place he
was basically told quite literally by
god you are my avatar of destruction on
earth that's just the role that you play
right that's the role that i created for
you and i got to be honest man if ever
you felt fractured and broken and
scattered all over the place like you
were somehow a you know an actor in your
own life that the reality is if god
comes and talks to you and offers you
even any measure of a meaningful
conversation well it only means one of
two things either god actually did it
and it'll make you feel whole or it
means you're schizophrenic right i mean
ideally it'd be the first that you're
you're not some kind of schizophrenic
and you know
struggling with mental illness right you
would certainly hope that's not the case
but it's cool because basically bruce
banner goes forward with a clear-cut
understanding of who he is what he's
about and he doesn't really see the
incredible hulk as a curse so much
anymore instead he sees the incredible
hulk as what is in some ways a gift from
god even if he doesn't always want to
see the hulks that are looking back at
him even if he knows in these times when
he's going to descend into violence and
tear things up at the end of the day he
knows that's the role that was given to
him by god himself that now he has a
purpose where previously he didn't feel
like he had one but with that being said
guys this is the end of the immortal
hulk this this wraps the whole thing up
and i got to tell you guys while it's
not the best in like incredible hulk
story there ever was it's certainly the
most interesting right i loved this run
of of al ewing when it came to the hulk
it was phenomenal right this this was
this was just absolutely fantastic but
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section keep an eye out
what we're probably gonna end up doing
is just making a big full story video of
the whole incredible hulk thing yeah
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace